Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wer ist die größere, Taylor oder Kamala?
Das ist eine sehr schwierige Frage, die ich nicht beantworten möchte.
So, damit konstatieren wir, der Juli erfordert Aufklärung.
Ja.
In wichtigen Fragen. Die erste möchte ich lösen. Taylor Swift natürlich. Sie ist die größere.
Manche würden jetzt sagen Céline Dion.
Ja, jetzt gerade. Aber es scheint ein Strohfeuer zu sein.
Na ja, also Céline Dion ist schon eine Weile im Geschäft und hat jetzt nach schwerer Krankheit ein großes Comeback erlebt.
Da will ich gar nichts gegen sagen. Ich habe allerdings noch nichts von Olympia gesehen. Also ein paar Skateboarder. Trotzdem finden einige Menschen Kamala Kamala Harris, wie auch immer sie ausgesprochen wird. Kamala, glaube ich, mit Arzen ist auch ein recht großer Hype.
Wie gehypt bist du?
Ich bin nicht sonderlich gehypt und würde auch mich davon distanzieren wollen, von diesen ganzen Hypes, die es gerade gibt. Also wir jetzt hier ein deutsches Publikum, das nicht wählen kann in den USA.
Aber wir können doch unsere amerikanischen Brüder und Schwestern unterstützen in ihren Wählerentscheidungen.
wir können sie gar nicht unterstützen. Also wir sind nur Beobachter. Das müssen wir schon mal verstehen. wir sind nur Beobachter und wir brauchen die Wahl nicht zu treffen. wir müssen gar nicht zwischen Kamala oder Trump wählen.
Aber es betrifft uns auch, wenn es passiert.
Es betrifft uns und wir werden ja heute sehr viele Beispiele hören, was könnte dann passieren, wenn das eine oder das andere passiert. Aber wir können deshalb beide Kandidaten kritisch betrachten, müssen uns also diese Frage, wen wähle ich denn jetzt am Ende, gar nicht stellen. Und jetzt würde ich erst einmal festhalten, für die amerikanische Bevölkerung wäre es sicherlich besser, wenn Kamala Präsidentin wird, als wenn Trump es wird. Geopolitisch sieht die Sache sehr viel verrückter, vertragter aus, wie wir heute noch hören werden. Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, Trump bringt uns allen den Frieden. Aber wir werden heute sehr viele Beispiele für das hören, was Trump machen könnte. Und man weiß es nicht, wohin es mit Kamala geht. Sie hat ja jetzt auch gar keine Möglichkeit, das auszubuchstabieren. Ich würde jedenfalls Abstand nehmen vor einem Hype, denn das macht ja jetzt eigentlich wieder das Falsche. Man versucht ja jetzt wieder nicht klar, auf die Dinge zu blicken, sondern man wartet jetzt einfach auf eine andere Erlöserfigur. Also man hat für die Rechten und die Verrückten Trump. Und jetzt wollen aber die anderen auch eine Erlöserfigur haben und finden die dann in Kamala Harris. Und ich muss eines konstatieren. Durch Trump sind wir alle dümmer geworden. wir sind alle dümmer geworden. Und ich will Beispiele dafür geben, wie die Debatte läuft. Lass uns mal beginnen mit einem Beitrag, den Trump abgegeben hat. Wahlkampf 2020. Also da war Kamala Harris nur als Vizepräsidentin angedacht, ist es ja dann auch geworden. wir hören uns jetzt mal an, was Trump 2020 gesagt hat über Kamala Harris. Gut. Das Lachen von Kamala Harris ist ja ein Thema. Also das 2020, als sie noch mit als nebenbei betrachtet wurde, dann ist das großes Thema bei Fox immer wieder dieses Lachen. Es gibt Interviews, da hat Tucker Carlson eine Stimmenimitaturin zu Gast, die lachen kann wie Kamala Harris. Es ist sehr absurd. Nur die Frage ist, wie antwortet man darauf? Ich finde, dass das Team Kamala Harris gerade eine ganz gute Idee hat, nämlich einfach zu sagen, die sind weird. Das ist eine sehr, sehr gute Strategie. Dass man nämlich einfach sagt, die sind seltsam, die sind ein bisschen komisch. Das stimmt fast nicht mit denen. Das ist nämlich etwas, womit man die einfach abräumen kann. Und dann geht man zu den eigenen Themen über. Wenn Kamala Harris bereit ist, sie zu setzen, ich bin da noch unsicher. Also nur zu sagen, ich bin identitätspolitisch bestens aufgestellt, wird nicht genügen. wir müssen auch noch uns daran erinnern, dass sie eigentlich als Vizepräsidentin dazu da war, die rechteren Demokraten mit einzufangen. Sie ist nicht die linke Progressive, wie das hier zum Teil dargestellt wird. Und sie ist auch nicht in den schwarzen Communities unbedingt die Favoritin. Ich kenne noch aus den vergangenen Jahren diese ganzen Memes von linken Aktivisten, she's a cop. Ja, also sie gehört zur Polizei.
Aber Trump hat gesagt, sie wollte doch die Police defanten.
Okay, ja, aber wir müssen also hier schon sehen, sie ist jetzt nicht die große Progressive. Wahrscheinlich waren beiden der Progressivere. Wahrscheinlich werden wir, trotz all der Geprächtigkeit, die wir thematisiert haben, noch in Situationen kommen, denen wir sagen, schade, dass Biden nicht mehr da ist. Ist durchaus möglich. Wie antwortet man nun jetzt aber auf solche komischen Angriffe da? Man kann sagen, das ist weird. Und damit wäre es eigentlich gut. Wie man nicht darauf antworten sollte, macht jetzt ein Tagesthemen-Kommentar von Katrin Brandt vor, vom WDR. wir spielen es einfach mal ab.
Wenn Kamala Harris lacht, dann verzieht sie nicht nur den Mund. Sie rührt, sie gluckst. Sie lässt das Lachen aus dem Bauch aufsteigen bis zu ihren Augen. Sie lässt ihr ganzes Gesicht strahlen und ihren Körper beben. Ich finde das ansteckend. Die Republikaner nicht. Sie zeigen in ihren Werbespots Bilder der lachenden Vize-Präsidentin und machen Harris als vierende linksextremistische Irre lächerlich. So ist das im US-Wahlkampf. Er ist hässlich und persönlich. Man braucht ein dickes Fell und die volle Rückendeckung der eigenen Leute. Kamala Harris wird gerade von einer großen Welle der Euphorie emporgehoben. Eine schwarze Frau als Präsidentin? Das hätte es noch nie gegeben. Und dann noch eine frühere Staatsanwältin, die einen verurteilten Straftäter an der Wahlurne besiegen könnte. Was für eine großartige Geschichte. Aber reicht das wirklich? Ist sie nicht 2020 kläglich bei den Vorwahlen gescheitert? Müssen wir den komplett hören? Gibt es nicht diese ungelenken, peinlichen Momente in ihren Interviews? Sollten die Demokraten nicht jetzt ganz offen und demokratisch nach einem wirklich guten Kandidaten oder Kandidatin suchen? Alles richtig, wenn es Januar wäre. Aber es ist Juli. Die Zeit ist viel zu kurz, um jemand anderen zu finden, auszuprobieren und aufzubauen. Um Kamala Harris führt kein Weg herum. Sie hat dreieinhalb Jahre an der Seite des Präsidenten ihre Erfahrungen gemacht. Sie kann es. Sie wird es können. Sie wird es können müssen. Und ich freue mich schon darauf, wie Harris, wenn sie denn die Kandidatin wird, in ihrer ersten Fernsehdebatte den wütenden, düsteren, quängelnden Donald Trump einfach an die Wand lacht.
Für mich ist das eben so weird, wie das, was Donald Trump so von sich gibt.
Allerdings.
Wenn man sich auf dieses Niveau einlässt, wir reden jetzt mal alle über das Lachen und wie befreiend das Lachen sein kann. Und das Lachen hat auch eine emanzipatorische Kraft und so weiter. Dann ist das einfach ein Nonsensdiskurs. Bitte Inhalte.
Also in der Neuen Zürcher Zeitung haben wir alle mitgekriegt. Ich habe da eine Autorin, birgit Schmitt. Kamala Harris lachend irritiert. Das hat auch nicht nur damit zu tun, dass sie eine Frau ist und so weiter. Dieselbe Frau hatte neun Tage vorher auch in der Neuen Zürcher geschrieben. Georgia Meloni fällt auf mit ihrer miemischen Ausdruckskraft. Sie gibt sich grimassierend volksnah.
Ach so, das ist dann das Positive.
Also die Journalisten sind sich selber nicht ganz einig. Ich würde sagen...
Gut, das ist jetzt die konservative Schlagzeite da aus der Zerstärkung.
Also wenn man jetzt ein Tagesthemenkommentar gehört, der könnte in einer Woche auch und so weiter, ne? Also das ist ja, das sind ja diese... Hier wird ja Strohfeuer begleitet.
Nun, ist das ja die konservative Ansicht jetzt oder die rechte Ansicht, dass man auch dieses Lachen problematisiert, das Grimassieren von Meloni großartig findet? Und die Antwort kann aber nicht von links darauf sein, dass man jetzt über das Lachen redet und sagt, ja, das ist doch herrlich, dass wir eine lachende Präsidentin bekommen. Also ich möchte auf dieses Niveau einfach nicht herunter.
Musst du auch nicht.
Aber das wird so gemacht.
Ich biete dir einen Ausweg an.
Moment, lass mich noch, bevor du hier... Ich hatte geahnt, dass du gehypt bist.
Du weißt gar nicht, warum ich gehypt bin. Du denkst, ich bin Kamala Harris-Fan.
Nein, aber ich...
Führe aus, dann führe ich aus.
Okay.
Warum redet eigentlich unsere Außenministerin so viel Unsinn? Sie wird auch gefragt zu Kamala Harris. wir hören drei.
Und sie wird es nicht überraschen, dass mit Blick auf eine Welt, in der vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel Testosteron manchmal herumfliegt, starke Frauen vielleicht auch gewissen Situationen nicht schlecht tun, sondern eher gut tun. Aber das Schöne an unseren Demokratien ist ja, auch im Vergleich zu anderen Regierungsformen, dass die Entscheidung sowohl vernominiert wird von Parteien, als auch, wer dann die nächsten Staats- und Regierungschefin werden, in den Händen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger liegt. wir haben selber erlebt in unserer direkten Nachbarschaft in Polen, aber auch gerade wieder in Frankreich, dass das Zusammenarbeiten von Demokraten in solchen Momenten essenziell ist. Das tun wir als starke europäische Demokratinnen und Demokraten. Und dass vor allen Dingen die Wahlen oftmals erst in den letzten Momenten entschieden werden. In diesem Sinne wird es sicher eine sehr spannende Zeit, nicht nur für die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika, sondern gerade auch für uns hier in Europa.
Erstes Argument, Testosteron. Ich möchte es einfach nicht mehr hören. Es ist nicht das Problem der Weltpolitik. Ich kann sagen, ja, Putin ist Testosteron getrieben. Meinetwegen, was ist Georgia Meloni? Das ist eine liebe, gute Frau oder was, weil sie eine Frau ist. Und also ich verbitte mir wirklich diesen Diskurs. Zweitens, kannst du dich erinnern, dass du schon mal einen Kandidaten für die Bundestagswahl, für das Kanzleramt geballt hast?
Nein, und wenn hätte ich mir gewünscht, dass da irgendwann mal ein Testosteron eine Rolle spielt. Aber das sehe ich wieder bei Olaf Scholz, noch bei Friedrich Menders, noch bei Linnemann, noch bei Robert Habeck. Aber wo ist unser Hulk Hogan eigentlich, frage ich mich.
Nein, aber was redet sie denn an, dass das schön an der Demokratie ist, dass die Bürger das entscheiden? Also, hier Kamala Harris, ja, ich ein Tweet von Adam Toos. Die amerikanische Vorstellung von der Präsidentschaft ist so monarchisch, dass Biden als Herrscher gefeiert wird, der zugunsten einer gesalbten Nachfolgerin die Macht abgibt und nicht als eitler Politiker, der sein Verfallsdatum falsch eingeschätzt hat und sich erst später zu überreden ließ, sich eine Demütigung zu ersparen und den Demokraten eine Chance zu geben. Das heißt, das ist die Entscheidung eines Einzelnen. Und jetzt kommt hinzu, dass sehr viele Geldgeber auf Kamala Harris angesprungen sind und sehr viele Spenden geben. Das ist nicht die Entscheidung der Bürger. Also dazu sagen, das ist ja so großartig, dass wir eine Demokratie sind. Das ist doch einfach Quatsch. Und das ist jetzt auch nicht ihr als Lapsus passiert. Sie sagt es dann nochmal später im ZDF-Interview.
Ich glaube, in diesen Zeiten wäre es für das erste Mal, eine Frau im Präsidentenamt zu haben, ja auch ein großer, großer Beitrag mit Blick auf die Gleichstellungsfragen. Also das wird sicherlich ein sehr spannender Wahlkampf. Aber wie gesagt, bisher ist ja noch gar nichts entschieden. Es zeigt aber ja, wie spannend Demokratie sein kann.
Ja, aber das ist ja gerade nicht Demokratie. Also ich kann natürlich sagen, Biden wurde mal gewählt. Und insofern ist eine Biden-Entscheidung dann auch noch irgendwo demokratisch abgesichert. Ja, es ist definitiv nicht so wie in Putins Reich oder gar im Iran. Aber das sind nun keine demokratischen Prozedere, die hier laufen. Die Frage ist auch, braucht man die? Wäre das sinnvoll, wenn das demokratischer wäre? Das kann man alles groß diskutieren. Nur kann man nicht behaupten, dass das jetzt gerade besonders demokratisch ist. Es gibt ja auch die Überlegungen, dass man doch noch da so eine Convention macht und dann die Demokraten andere Kandidaten haben. Und dann ist aber oft die Argumentation nicht, dass andere dann eine Chance wirklich hätten gegen Kamala Harris. Nur, dass man ein bisschen simulative Demokratie eigentlich da präsentiert. Aber du darfst jetzt gehypt sein.
Gut, zum einen zu dem letzten Punkt. wir werden diesen Text lesen von Esra Klein, der das vorgeschlagen hat. Der hat ja vor Biden zurück trat, lange mit der Unterscheidung gespielt, macht man eine Krönung oder eine Competition. Also ist ja dann auch noch eine Frage der Zeit. Wie viel Zeit hat man denn noch? Und jetzt hat er ja eine Synthese daraus vorgeschlagen und hat gesagt, wir machen eine Exhibition. wir stellen, nachdem alles immer nur Biden Biden Biden Biden hieß und Biden alt, nicht zu gebrauchen und es spricht auch niemand für ihn. Ehrlich gesagt, man hat ja niemanden gesehen. Sagt man, okay, wir machen nicht eine Vorwahl im Sinne von Vorwahl. Es geht ja auch nicht nur um das Amt des Präsidenten. Trump kommt und sagt, wir wollen 50.000 Stellen auswechseln. Man kann da ruhig mal eine Exhibition machen, eine Ausstellung mit Personal, das man so hat. Und ich glaube, sehr viele Leute sehen jetzt gerade Pete Budicic durch die Talkshows inklusive Fox News tingeln. Und es macht einfach Spaß zu gucken, weil man da auch einfach jetzt wieder Leute sieht, die in unserem Alter ungefähr sich mit Fox News Hosts anlegen und dort wirklich intellektuelle Hochleistungsarbeit betreiben. Also das ist eigentlich die Olympiade, die ich mir so anschaue, wie sich Pete Budicic in diesen ganzen Dingern da schlägt. Zu diesem, ja, Annalena Baerbock sagt immer, was sie sagt. Ich würde sagen, das kann man ja heute wirklich mal alles verkürzen. Und damit gehe ich auch den Schritt, den ich gehen will. Denn ihre Chefin, Ricarda Lange, hat ein Video gepostet. Vielleicht hast du es gesehen? Nein. Also ich zeige es dir mal hier auf dem Handy. Ich beschreibe, was man sieht, aber du, dir zeige ich es natürlich direkt. Ricarda Lange war bei Taylor Swift. Und ich weiß nicht genau, es gibt jetzt sieben Trillionen Videos von, wie man sich bei einem Taylor Swift Konzert filmt. Man hält das Handy eigentlich neben sich, filmt sich dann seitlich, zeigt aber auch sozusagen Menschen und die Bühne und sowas. Ricarda Lange hat sich entschieden, so das Handy direkt vor sich und dann singt sie Fakte Patriarchy in das Ding rein.
Aber das könnte doch auf der kirmes in Koblenz sein.
Dieser kleine Ausschnitt, ja genau, hinter ihr sind einfach Leute. Man sieht jetzt überhaupt keinen Bezug, wo sie ist und so weiter. Also man kann das alles noch viel blöder machen, als sie das schon gemacht hat. Und jetzt würde ich aber sagen, warum ich gehypt bin. Als großer Verfechter guter Soziologie haben wir doch jetzt festgestellt, in der Politik geht es um Macht. Macht haben, Macht nicht haben. Es zählt nichts anderes. Es zählt nicht, ich sehe mich aber als links an, ich sehe mich aber als vernünftig an, ich sehe mich aber als ordentlich trainierter Sprecher an, ich rede nur Blödsinn oder alles egal, es ist alles zweitragig. Entscheidend ist, Macht nicht Macht. Und die Welt und vor allem ich, habe jetzt acht Jahre darunter gelitten, dass Trump das verstanden hat und die anderen nicht. Trump hat eine Macht errungen, er war Präsident. Nicht mit, ich bin der bessere Kandidat, ich rede besser, ich rede klug oder was auch immer, sondern die Leute wollen Action, die Leute kriegen Action. Jetzt hat Joe Biden gesagt, ich bin es nicht, ich trete von meinem Arm zurück, da würde ich Adam Toos auch widersprechen. Ja, es ist halt so ein monastisches Verfahren, wo es einfach nur darauf ankommt, ist er jetzt bereit, diese Entscheidung zu treffen, ja oder nein. Man kann ihn nicht drängen, man kann gar nichts. Man kann ihm sagen, du hast aber gar kein Spendengeld mehr, ja und?
Ist doch egal.
Du hast gar keine Unterstützer mehr, ist doch egal. Niemand spricht für dich und du auch nicht, ist doch egal. Ihm kann das alles egal sein. Trotzdem hat er diese Entscheidung getroffen, ich bin es nicht. Und ab dann, sag mal so, ab eine Stunde danach, als dann schon 40 Minuten klar war, Kamala Harris ruft er aus und die anderen haben keinen Wettkampfapparat, der da irgendwie dagegen gehalten kann, hat sich irgendwie die progressive, eingeschüchterte, junge, weibliche, urbane Schicht in Amerika gedacht, scheiß drauf, wir gehen jetzt hier all in. wir shitposten den Scheiß, wir machen jeden Tag 100 Videos, in denen wir die letzten Auftritte von Trump einfach nehmen, uns darüber lustig machen. Hatte JD. Vance Sex mit einem Sofa, ist die wichtigste Frage der Welt gewesen und so. Und ich denk mir, jawohl, genau so geht's.
Ja, ich bin absolut auf deiner Seite.
Was ist in den Nachrichten, was sagt Annalena Baerbock, ist mir alles egal. Ich will einfach nur aufstehen morgens und dann kriege ich nicht einfach nur John Stewart oder zwei andere Comedien, sondern tausende Videos, in denen ich mich darin suhlen kann, dass Trump ein Idiot ist, und man sich jetzt auch endlich traut, es auf diesem Niveau, auf dem es gesagt werden muss, zu sagen. Und das findet gerade statt und das finde ich großartig.
Man macht das aber tatsächlich dann mit Humor. Das ist super witzig. Und nicht in so einer kirsentags-predigt wie aus den Tagesthemen.
Es gibt so viel Shit-Talking gerade auf YouTube. Es ist wirklich eine Freude.
Nur werden wir irgendwann auch über Inhalte reden müssen und da...
Warum? Trump hat auch nicht irgendwann mal über Inhalte reden müssen, um die amerikanische Perspektive zu gewinnen.
Nein, wenn man jetzt aus der kritischen Perspektive heraus Kandidaten beurteilen will. Also für mich macht das ja erstmal keinen Unterschied, ob die da ein Hype im Internet produzieren. Naja, die Frage ist ja schon interessant und die können sich deutsche Journalisten ja mitunter mal stellen. Welche wirtschaftspolitik will eigentlich eine Kamala Harris? Welche Geopolitik will eine Kamala Harris? Wenn man aber in den Tagesthemen hört, dass sie so herrlich lacht, dann die Tagesthemen sind ja nicht TikTok. Also dass sie jetzt da irgendwelche 22-jährigen großen Spaß daran haben, diese Videos zu produzieren und dass das einen Effekt auf die Wahl haben wird. Und dass das möglicherweise ihr den Weg ins Amt bereitet. Alles gut und schön. Nur muss ja die journalistische Auseinandersetzung eine andere sein. Und da sehe ich in Deutschland schwarz. Ich habe jetzt in den vergangenen Tagen, als dann bekannt wurde Kamala Harris, wird es wohl werden eigentlich ein reines Deja-vu-Erlebnis, nämlich man hat nochmal den Hillary Clinton-Kram neu aufgerührt. Also das ist ja eigentlich jetzt, wir haben Hillary Clinton nicht bekommen, jetzt bekommen wir Kamala. Die meisten deutschen Journalisten verlieben sich blind. Und mit blind meine ich ja auch, dass sie bis vor drei Wochen oder bis vor vier Wochen nicht bereit waren zu erkennen, dass Biden sehr geprächtlich ist. Die haben ja noch bis vor kurzem in Interviews gesagt, der ist sharp as a knife, der ist super drauf.
Also das werden wir nachher, also zum einen nachher und dann aber auch anders diskutieren, denn was deutsche Journalisten inhaltlich in diesem Medium Fernsehen dazu sagen, können wir aber jetzt ignorieren. Das gibt es noch. wir haben eine gewisse Pfadabhängigkeit. 70-Jährige sitzen vor dem Fernseher, wollen wissen, was passiert so grob in der Welt.
Für die wird das gemacht.
wir wissen auch noch, unsere Eltern haben ja auch noch Fernsehen gesehen oder unsere Großeltern, aber es wird...
Ich kenne dein Argument, nur diese Fernsehanstalten sind ja im Internet sehr stark vertreten. Das heißt, was dort so gesagt wird, doch, doch, doch. Was da schon so gesagt wird in den Talkshows findet auch bei TikTok, findet bei Twitter überall dort statt. Bei YouTube wird es sehr viel sich angesehen. Das heißt, es hat schon einen Ausschlag, was in diesen Talkshows verhandelt wird und wie diese Nachrichtensendungen aufgebaut sind. Und wenn sie vor allem sich mit dem Lachen der Kamala Harris auseinandersetzen, dann hat das einen allgemeinen Verblödungseffekt.
Also die Tagesschau 20 Uhr vom 30.07. gestern, 13 Stunden alt, bei YouTube hat 118.000 Views. Und ich kann dir 100 Kanäle nennen, die gerade die amerikanische Wahlkampf-Sachen thematisieren, die innerhalb von 13 Stunden entweder 10-mal oder 15-mal so viele Views haben.
Jaja, das ist wirklich...
Es spielt wirklich keine Rolle, was die Tagesschau dazu macht. Auch nicht in der 20 Uhr. Und man muss eben dazu sagen, die Leute, die die Tagesschau gucken, sind zum Teil Redakteure in irgendwelchen Redaktionen und nehmen diese Themen mit. Ansonsten sind das aber Leute, die wissen nicht mal, was Social Media ist. Also die verbreiten da nichts. Dass wir hier so einen Clip aus der Tagesschau gesehen haben, ist schon eine Orchidee in dieser Medienlandschaft, dass wir nochmal ein Tagesschau-Kommentar hören. In der Ansicht, ich bin sehr gehypt. Endlich läuft dieser Wahlkampf auch auf der progressiven Seite dort, wo er laufen muss. Und damit meine ich nicht nur eine Verortung regional, sondern auch eine Verortung intellektuell. Niemand wird gequält mit irgendwelchen Inhalten. wir haben uns sehr, also wie oft haben wir uns darüber beschwert, das lustig gemacht, das intellektuell durchdrungen in Salonbüchern und so weiter besprochen, dass es absolut absurd ist zu sagen, das Schicksal der Welt hängt davon ab. Erstens von einer Person, zweitens von der Tagesform 5.
November. Ist doch egal.
In Deutschland werden noch auch Koalitionsverträge geschrieben und dann heißt es schon drei Wochen später, ja, dass jetzt Putin in der Ukraine einmarschiert, da konnten wir ja nichts für. wir mussten jetzt erstmal eine Grundgesetzänderung machen, 100 Milliarden hier, 200 Milliarden da und so. Ist doch eh alles egal. In deren Sicht, dieses amerikanische Wahlmodell, was wir da haben, ist absurd. Es ist viel zu sehr auf Personen zugeschnitten, es ist viel zu sehr auf Wahlzeitpunkte zugeschnitten.
Es ist monarchisch, wie du sagst.
Es ist noch viel monarchischer, als wir dachten. Blümport hat gesagt, ja, es ist ein Königreich. wir haben jetzt König Tümer wieder neu gegründet.
Es ist völlig absurd.
Und das, was wir jetzt inhaltlich an Wahlkampf die letzten zehn Tage erlebt haben, ist auf Augenhöhe mit dieser Absurdität und hat dadurch endlich die Chance, Donald Trump aus dem Spiel zu nehmen. Ich bin nicht mehr so überzeugt, dass Donald Trump diese Wahl gewinnt wie vorher, denn wir haben auch gesehen, Donald Trump ist wirklich der Einzige, der diese mediale Ansprache, die dieses Publikum braucht, beherrscht.
Jaja.
Alle anderen scheitern auf ganzer Linie. Dass selbst sein Vizepräsidentschaftskandidat so versagt ist, das hat historische Ausmaße, diese Art von Fail, die da stattfindet.
Das heißt, du schlägst vor, und dem kann ich mich ja eigentlich nur anschließen, wir beobachten das jetzt auf der reinen Performance-Ebene und sagen, die Demokraten haben nun die Chance, auch gut zu performen, eine tolle Show zu liefern. Beyonce hat schon ihren Freedom-Song freigegeben, in diese Richtung geht es. Und wir sehen jetzt auch die Performance von Trump. Allein, dass es eine jüngere Gegenkandidatin gibt, wirkt älter.
Ist 59, eine jüngere Gegenkandidatin.
Ja, aber er wirkt hier direkt zehn Jahre älter, dadurch, dass Biden nicht mehr daneben steht. Das ist ja immer in Relation.
Ja, Trump will ja auch schon dafür entschädigt werden, dass er hin das Licht geführt wurde. Er hat ja Investitionen in den Wahlkampf auf Thema Alter gemacht. Und jetzt ist aber das Alter nicht mehr das maßgebliche Thema. So hätte er gerne ein Reimbursement. So absurd ist es ja. Und auf der Ebene will ich das auch behandelt haben. Über Inhalte, so traurig es ist, können wir wirklich erst nach dem 5. November. Jetzt ist Wahlkampf, danach ist Politik. Beim Wahlkampf möchte ich, dass alles getan wird, um die Macht zu erregen.
So dumm, wie es geht.
Und wenn das amerikanische Publikum dumm ist, dann muss der Wahlkampf auch dumm sein. Aber es ist unterhaltsam. Es ist wirklich wahnsinnig unterhaltsam. Jeder hat gespürt, wie in Europa natürlich insbesondere, wie erlösend es war, nicht mehr Joe Biden ausgeliefert zu sein. Und das alleine ist schon ein kleiner Hype-Moment, den kann auch jeder emotional für sich einfach mal ausleben, statt ihn gleich wieder akademisch, intellektuell durchdringen zu wollen und so weiter. Dieser Wahlkampf...
Also ich habe noch andere Freuden im Leben, außer an der politischen Präsidentschaft.
Aber trotzdem war es doch ein sehr drückendes Gefühl zu wissen, da ist irgendwie ein 81-Jähriger, der es echt nicht mehr auf die Kette kriegt, aber wir sind ihm ausgeliefert.
Ja.
Und das ist jetzt anders.
Das hält sich bei mir im Grenzen. Weiß ich nicht, ich denke nicht so viel darüber nach, wie die in Washington so gerade drauf sind. Beziehungsweise, wenn es um große Geopolitik geht, ja, aber ich verfolge den Wahlkampf nicht in dem Sinne, dass die Performance mich besonders interessiert. Ich gehe da lieber ins Konzert, aber ich kann sehr nachvollziehen, was du da meinst. Du hast aber jetzt gerade einen Satz gesagt, nämlich wenn die Wähler dumm sind, dann muss man einen dummen Wahlkampf machen. Und das führt uns zu einem...
Dumm meine ich übrigens nicht dumm im Sinne von dumm, sondern nicht meinung.
Pognitiv, sondern wenn die blöden Wahlkampf wollen, so muss man es eigentlich sagen, dann machen wir einen blöden Wahlkampf. Wenn sie unaufgeklärten Wahlkampf wollen, dann machen wir unaufgeklärten Wahlkampf oder absurden Wahlkampf.
Also lass mich da wirklich kurz anfangen. Ich finde das wahnsinnig aufgeklärt. Und man muss es aber nicht soz sagen akademisch durchdringen, sondern man kann es einfach fühlen, es bringt jetzt nichts, eine Debatte über irgendwas zu führen, sondern wenn Trump auf der Bühne steht, muss man das spiegeln. Man kann jetzt nicht irgendwie erwarten, dass Obama das Supreme Court-Urteil in der staatsrechtlichen Vorlesung eine Stunde lang durchdringt und die Leute dann überzeugt sind, ach so, ja, nee, dann müssen wir jetzt so und so wenden. Sondern nein, das muss jetzt go with the flow, es muss jetzt richtig ausgelebt werden.
Ja, ich befürchte, dass man schon eine gewisse Vision braucht. Also Trump hat Make America Great Again, da steckt etwas Retrotopisches drin, aber auch wiederum, was in die Zukunft gewandt ist, also die Zukunft wird besser. Wenn Kamala Harris nur anzubieten hat, we are not going back, dann ist das auch zugleich eine Bestätigung des Status Quo, mit dem sehr viele Amerikaner nicht einverstanden sind, weshalb man sich da nochmal was einfallen lassen muss. Aber du hast es da schon angesprochen, ja wie ticken denn die Wähler, wie sind sie drauf? Man könnte ja auch sagen, warum wählen denn eigentlich die Kinder nicht? Und damit kommen wir jetzt gleich zu unserem Kinderfamilienwahlrecht. Lass uns aber erst ganz kurz ein paar Ankündigungen machen, bezüglich des Salons. wir haben den Sommersalon am 24. August. Er ist so gut wie ausverkauft. Ich glaube, es sind noch 24 Karten da.
Er ist zu 95,5 Prozent ausverkauft. Es gibt noch 36 Karten. Ah ja. Man kann also noch kommen. Okay. Und wir müssen schon mal dazusagen, wenn ihr dann am 23. feststellt, ich habe Husten, ich bin doch verreist oder wie auch immer, schickt nicht uns die Nachricht. wir können gar nichts machen, ja, sondern ihr müsst es twittern oder bei Instagram. wir können es dann teilen. Aber die diese Art von Ich habe noch ein Ticket. Also Wolfgang und ich haben schon ein Ticket für diese Fahrtsteigen. wir brauchen dann keinen.
Sie können auch. wir haben keinen Zugriff auf den Server, können nicht einen Platz frei machen oder immer wieder die Mail an uns.
Nein, ihr müsst es selber twittern, uns dann erwähnen, wie auch immer.
wir können das dann teilen.
Mehr als das einfach resharen können wir nicht.
Ja, und wir werden natürlich das auch aufzeichnen. Und dann ist das für alle hörbar. Und zwar im Salon. Im nächsten Salon sprechen wir ja über ein Buch, das den interessanten Titel trägt, Unhaltbarkeit auf dem Weg in eine andere Moderne von Ingolfur Blüthorn. Da geht es um die Frage, ob das ökologisch-emanzipatorische Projekt an sein Ende kommt oder gescheitert ist. Warum es ist gescheitert, hat es sich vielleicht selbst unterminiert. Mit anderen Worten ist vielleicht diese liberale Demokratie gar nicht mehr die Antwort auf unsere Fragen. Es ist ein Buch, über das wir dann trefflich streiten können, nehme ich an.
Meine Argumente liegen schon bereit.
wir müssen nur sagen, dass sich beim Salon ein bisschen was ändert. Und zwar für alle, die jetzt im Salon schon sind, ändert sich gar nichts. Für die läuft alles genau weiter. Aber Steady hat uns freundlich gebeten, eine Preiserhöhung zu machen. wir wollten das aber nicht für unsere schon Bestandskunden machen, für die, die uns schon so lange die Treue halten, sondern für die, die neu kommen, werden wir den Preis anheben. Aber nicht jetzt sofort, sondern am 24. August. Bis dahin hat man Zeit, kann also sich jetzt noch die günstigen Pakete sichern. Und du sagst noch gerade was zur Preisstruktur.
Ja, ich will auch nochmal was sagen zum Preis. Also der Preis ist 2,50 Euro bislang und noch bis 24.
August.
Danach springt der Mindestpreis also pro Monat in der jährlichen Abrechnung auf 3 Euro pro Monat. Und nicht nur haben wir erfragt, ob wir das dürfen, sondern jetzt wurde uns angeboten, wir dürfen sagen, Steady ist schuld. wir wollten das nicht.
Steady ist schuld.
Finde ich auch ein bisschen witzig, dass es gleich in der ersten Mail drin stand. Aber wir haben uns jetzt zwei Jahre oder so dagegen gewehrt. Man kann auch derzeit, wenn man bei Steady ein neues Projekt eröffnet, nicht unter 3 Euro pro Monat anfangen. Das heißt, wir waren noch eins der ganz wenigen. Vielleicht das einzige Projekt, das für 2,50 Euro im Monat zu haben war. Aber wir gehen jetzt auch den 3-Euro-Schritt mit. In den Salon kommt man, wie wir es immer betonen, über die Webseite Die Neue zwanziger.de oder man googelt einfach Neue Zwanziger Salon oder mein Lieblingspodcast Salon.
Da kommt man auch aus.
Wahrscheinlich. Dort ist ein goldner Button, dem kann man dann folgen. wir haben erstaunlich wenig, es ist wirklich erfreulich, technische Probleme bei Hörern, wenn klärt Steady die sofort. Also man kann einfach auf den Button klicken und sich ein Paket buchen oder zu Apple gehen. Diese Preise werden allerdings auch erhöht. Und bei Patreon auch. Also wir sind auf diesen drei Kanälen. Stehen wir zur Verfügung. wir präferieren aber Steady.
Und da kostet das jetzt bei Steady dann, wenn man das Jahresabonnement abschließt, drei Euro im Monat, also 36 Euro im Jahr. 36 Euro und ab 24. August bei Apple dann ein bisschen mehr. Also wer jetzt sich noch schnell ein Paket sichert, der hat also noch den günstigen Tarif und wird den dann auch über diese Preiserhöhung hinaus haben. Für alle, die sowieso schon Abo haben, ändert sich wie gesagt gar nichts. Und vielleicht auch nochmal hier der Hinweis. wir freuen uns sehr, wenn ihr den Podcast teilt, weil ich das jetzt weit empfehle. Es ist gerade Sommerpause, viele Podcaster sind im Urlaub, wir nicht. wir arbeiten durch sozusagen und würden uns sehr freuen, wenn ihr den Podcast ein bisschen teilt oder auch gut bewertet auf den entsprechenden Plattform. Das hilft uns sehr, dass der Podcast sichtbar ist und uns hilft natürlich auch, wenn ihr uns über Steady, Patreon oder Apple unterstützt und dann Zusatzinhalte genießt, die doch sehr reichhaltig inzwischen sind, denn wir machen das ja seit Januar 2020. Das heißt, da sind sehr, sehr viele Salonfolgen, sehr viele Buchempfehlungen, sehr viele Diskussionen, die man noch nachhören kann.
Zum Beispiel wir lesen im nächsten Salon ein Text über JD Vance natürlich, den von Esra Klein angekündigten oder auch einen älteren über JD Vance, also verschiedene Sachen und dabei fiel mir wieder auf, wie toll unser Salon ist, denn im Januar 21 haben wir von Jeff Kin das Buch über Peter Thiel besprochen, in dem stecken gigantische Pointen zu JD Vance drin. wir werden sie im nächsten Salon noch mal rausholen. Es war wirklich grandios, dass wir, bevor das alles losging, im, glaube ich, zweiten Monat des Erscheins des Buches es gleich bei uns besprochen haben, also wer ein Salon-Hörer ist. Und das ist jetzt eins von ungefähr 80, 90 Büchern oder so, die wir insgesamt im Salon besprochen haben. Da ist man wirklich ganz vorne dran.
Das müssen wir auch nochmal wirklich empfehlen. Diese Biografie über Peter Thiel, über die wir sehr ausführlich gesprochen haben, kann man, wie gesagt, nachhören, weil man dann nochmal sehr genau versteht, wie jetzt so eine neue Generation bei den Republikanern, das wahrscheinlich so sehr an sich reißen wird, dass das also die Zukunft sein wird, eines großen Teils von Amerika. Also die Sache ist jetzt auch, Trump kann verhindert werden durch Kamala Harris. Ich bin da auch vorsichtig optimistisch. Danach aber werden ja die Karten wieder neu gemischt.
wir reden hier wirklich nur über das Präsidentenamt.
Genau.
Also es gibt noch ganz viele andere Posten.
Und wir sehen, welche Auffassungen dort vertreten werden. wir sehen auch gerade, wie Trump die Bitcoin Bros umarmt. Man kann also darüber sehr viel lernen, wenn man sich mit dieser Petatil-Biografie auseinandersetzt.
Ja, also zeigt mal, wie das Lesen hilft.
Und wir lesen.
Eine Sache möchte ich hier noch ankündigen. Es gibt eine neue Subscribe von 18. bis 20. Oktober in Berlin. Subscribe ist unsere, aus der Community geborene, von Tim Brittlaff getragene, vor allem auch diese ganze Technik, über die auch unser Podcast hier läuft. Da war natürlich jetzt Corona-Pause. Die letzte hatten wir ja 2019 beim Deutschlandfunk in Köln organisiert. Diesmal gibt es sie in Berlin und es sind sehr viele sehr krasse Projekte damals entstanden. Joscha zum Beispiel ist da reingekommen in das ganze Podcast-Game und produziert jetzt ein prämiertes Ding nach dem anderen. Danny ist Civic-Preisträger, das ist auch ein Podcast, der aus der Subscribe geboren wurde. Oder er hat Podcasts, die aus der Subscribe geboren wurden und macht damit, äh, Alex diesen Ostpodcast und so weiter. Also sehr cooles Zeug. Ich nehme an, das wird wieder historisch. Meldet euch an im Oktober. Und wir haben eine Mail bekommen, lieber Steffan, lieber Wolfgang. Es scheint große Schwierigkeiten zu geben bezüglich der Aussprache des Namens, wenn ich sage jetzt, Rutger Bregman. Ich bin Niederländerin, wohne seit über zehn Jahren in Deutschland. Seit vielen Folgen wird der oben genannte Name, also Rutger Bregman, ihr hattet ihn zum letzten Mal falsch, auf verschiedene Weise falsch ausgesprochen. Deshalb einmal hier die Aussprache für euch. Ich habe die direkt auf meine Aussprache-Datenbank gelegt. Also liebe Maeline, sofern ich diesen Namen jetzt richtig ausgesprochen habe, M-Y-L-E mit Apostroph N-E, also Maeline wahrscheinlich. Sie sagt, der Name wird so ausgesprochen, wir hören das jetzt und stellen dann fest, niemand kann das so aussprechen.
Rutger Bregman.
Ja, ich will es gar nicht versuchen, aber du hast es immer da.
Ich habe das immer.
Rutger Bregman.
wir sagen jetzt immer, wir wissen noch, die große Frage, die gestellt wurde, werden auch nachher darauf zu sprechen kommen.
Hatte doch gesagt, mit den Politikern stimmt irgendwas nicht im Kopf. Jetzt haben wir dankenswerterweise den ersten Eintrag in unserer Aussprache Datenbank. Soviel zum Housekeeping, kommen wir zu einem lebensbedrohlichen Thema für mich.
Hast du diesen Clip dabei? Ich habe ihn dir auch noch mal extra ausgenommen.
Nicht nur du, sondern ungefähr auch 75 Hörer.
Und zwar muss man sagen, gibt es JD Vance, der möglicherweise der nächste Vizepräsident werden könnte, wenn Trump gewinnt. Und JD Vance denkt eigentlich ganz genauso wie unser Stefan.
No.
Also ich werde gleich dagegen anargumentieren, warum ich auch der Meinung bin, es braucht ein Wahlrecht für Kinder, aber nicht so wie JD Vance. Soll ich anfangen oder willst du anfangen?
Willst du erst mal den Clip von JD Vance spielen, damit alle aufstanden sind?
Ja, ich würde ihn ansonsten nämlich direkt einbetten in meine Argumentation, denn ich bekomme ja auch eine Mail. Also okay.
Dann lass mich nun mit einem Satz anfangen, um nicht missverstanden zu werden. Ich mache mir keine Illusionen über unsere Demokratie und über unsere Regierung. Ich habe in den letzten Wochen sehr viele Interviews gesehen, mit Christian Lindner und Carsten Linnemann. Und gehe so weit zu sagen, ich würde lieber von Siebenjährigen regiert werden.
Ja, siehste. Punkt.
Da geht es schon gar nicht mehr ums Wählen, sondern ich würde sagen, wegen mir können die auch regieren. Aber jetzt fangen wir an.
Kinder an die Macht. Herbert Grönemeyer hat schon immer recht gehabt.
Nun ja.
Okay.
Also ernstes Thema, denn dieses Thema wurde, das muss man wirklich sagen, nicht nur torpediert, sondern da ist so eine Atombombe draufgefallen. Weshalb ich zum Beispiel auch, also wir beide eine Mail bekommen haben von Johannes, ich habe auf einige schon reagiert. Ich lese sie mal vor. In puncto Stimmenrecht pro Kind deckt sich Stephans Position mit der von JD.
Vance.
Gehören wir eigentlich mit zu den Shit-Talkern, die jetzt immer JD. Vance sagen oder lassen wir es JD.?
Ich möchte JD sagen.
JD. Vance, okay. Dem Running Mate von Donald Trump, der Vizepräsidentschaftskandidat, und jetzt wird es schon ein bisschen toxisch in der E-Mail, Klammer auf, oder laut Stephans zukünftige Vizepräsident, Klammer zu, verdreht schon länger dieses Wahlrecht, dass dieser Vorschlag aus dem rechtskonservativen Lager kommt, ist kein Zufall. Ich kann da nur ergänzen, die Pointen, ja, der größte Verfechter in Deutschland ist Jens Spahn.
Richtig.
Damit sind wir schon mal, haben wir den Thema schon mal. So, jetzt machen wir es so. wir hören nicht JD. Vance im Wortlaut, sondern wir hören nachgesprochen das Originalzitat, weil wir wollen ja jetzt uns auf Inhalte konzentrieren. Aber die Szenerie, ihr habt sie bestimmt alle gesehen. JD. Vance steht irgendwann vor drei Jahren in so einer Konferenz am Rednerpult und so ganz locker und lakonisch. Warum eigentlich nicht? Aber dieses Video ist so ein bisschen verkürzt. Ich habe jedenfalls keine vollständige Version gefunden, denn das Zitat ist in seiner dramatischen Schärfe noch etwas länger. Weshalb wir hier von India Today, also es wird uns vorgelesen, dieses Zitat, wo dann auch, finde ich, alles drinsteckt.
Vance betrug, dass die Menschen mit Kindern mehr Votingrechte als Nennern werden geben. Das Video ist von Vance Adresse zu einer Organisation, die Intercollegiate Studies Institute heißt, in der er gesagt hat, dass Menschen mit keinen Kindern keine Investitionen in die Zukunft Amerikaner haben und vielleicht kaum die gleiche Stimme bekommen. JD. Vance sagte laut, Prost! Lass uns alle Kinder in diesem Land votieren. Aber lass uns die Kinder mit den Voten.
So, wir hören hier schon, es geht ja nicht um Kinder, sondern die Parents. Parents, Parents, Parents. Oder Erwachsene, die keine Parents sind.
Zwischen Kinderwahlrecht und Familienwahlrecht.
Genau.
Du hast dich ja ausgesprochen damals für ein Familienwahlrecht. Deine Argumentation war ja, wenn jemand sehr alt ist, gebrechlich ist, dann wählt der Pfleger für denjenigen.
So hast du es ein bisschen zugeschüttet.
So darf es natürlich nicht sein.
Das ist eine technische Unterstützung.
Kann man jemanden technisch unterstützen. Es ist ja zum Beispiel auch sehr stark liberalisiert werden. Und ich unterstreiche ihr, ich bin sehr dafür, dass Menschen auch mit geistiger Behinderung in Deutschland wählen dürfen, weil sie volljährig sind. Allerdings müssen sie selbst ihren Wähler willen kundtun. Das heißt, man kann nicht sagen, ach ja, das mache ich jetzt aber mal für die. Also das geht nicht. Also das ist Betrug. Das mag irgendwo vorkommen, das ist aber nicht richtig, dass es geht. Und Familienwahlrecht würde tatsächlich ja bedeuten, dass man sagt, der Vater oder die Mutter, ist dann auch die Frage, wie ist das in Patchwork-Familien so, die wählen für ihre Kinder. Das heißt aber nicht, dass sie nur den Auftrag der Kinder, die Kinder geben den Auftrag, sondern die haben einfach eine Stimme mehr. Um es ganz deutlich zu sagen. Und man versteht auch ein bisschen, warum konservative Rechte sehr dafür sind. Was ich sagen würde, dass man, glaube ich, damit sehr gut konservative Politik machen kann. Aber das ist ja noch eine strategische Sache. Aber das ist ja erstmal die Unterscheidung. Kinderwahlrecht und Familienwahlrecht.
Genau. Also ich habe ja von Claude eine Auswertung machen lassen. So vor ein paar Tagen schon. Da sind jetzt die letzten Mails da nicht dabei. Aber ich habe das ja auch mal geschickt. Wo so zusammenfassend 30 Mails in die Richtung, oder so kreuz und quer. Ich möchte hier sagen, das wandert alles nochmal analytisch natürlich auch in meinem Buch rein. Nur es ist halt alles wahnsinnig viel komplizierter, denn Kinder eine Stimme geben und man ist sofort bei der Frage, also machen das dann die Erwachsenen? Und was ist mit Erwachsenen, die keine Kinder haben? Haben die dann weniger Stimmrecht als die Erwachsenen mit Kindern? Und was ist eigentlich mit Familie? Ist ja noch mal ein anderer Begriff. Also der meint ja noch mal was anderes als einfach nur Vater, Mutter, Kind oder Vater, Mutter ohne Kind. Nee, das sind ja dann nicht Vater, Mutter, aber es ist trotzdem eine Familie und so weiter und so fort. Also mein Plädoyer wird ja dafür sein, wir brauchen den wirklich gänzlich und ich meine jetzt wirklich, auch wenn du gerade hier zuhörst und denkst, ich habe schon einen modernen Familienbegriff, nein, ich werde einen noch weitergehenden, wir müssen das wirklich zertrümmern, was wir bisher, was ist Familie und so.
Okay, aber bleibt man bei der Wahl, was heißt das?
Johannes hat jetzt hier in der Mail weiter geschrieben, ein Wahlrecht, das Eltern für ihre Kinder mit Stimmen betraut, schwächt die emanzipierte Frau und erhöht das Stimmgewicht für traditionelle Familien, was höchstwahrscheinlich zu einem weiteren Rechtsruck führen würde. Natürlich unterstelle ich Familien mit mehr Kindern nicht generell diese politische Gesinnung, aber in Anbetracht, wie Knappwahlen bislang ausfallen, halte ich diesen Vorstoß für demokratiegefährdend. Da würde ich sagen, ja, das haben wir beim letzten Mal auch schon so diskutiert, wenn wir jetzt Angst davor haben, dass jemand falsch wählt, ist das vielleicht, also ist dann der Olaf Scholz-artige Weg, so hat er das ja argumentiert. Dem würde ich nun gar nicht folgen.
Damit kommt man auch nicht weiter. Also dann kann ich auch sagen, dann sollten Leute, die zum Mindestlohn arbeiten, lieber nicht wählen, weil die häufiger die AfD wählen oder so was.
Das treiben die in Amerika sehr weit. Du wohnst in dieser Straße, dann gehörst du nicht in unseren bezirk, sondern dann wählst du einfach für die Assis.
Also ich halte das auch für keine gute Argumentation, würde aber unterstreichen wollen. Also weil manche glauben, dass man mit so einem Familienwahlrecht was Progressives schaffen könnte. Das glaube ich nicht. Also wir können uns zwei Szenarien vorstellen, um das ganz kurz zu machen. Das erste Szenario ist, wir haben Familienwahlrecht. Also man wirbt um die Eltern und sagt, wir investieren mehr in Schulen, wir bauen die Tagesbetreuung aus, wir investieren grundsätzlich in Bildung mehr, wir sorgen dafür, dass es ein Grunderbe für Kinder gibt. Ab dem 18. bekommen sie das dann ausgezahlt. Das sind all die Dinge. Und dann würden hier fast alle zustimmen, die uns hier zuhören. Aber wir können uns fragen, ist das die erfolgreiche? Wäre das die erfolgreiche Politik? Also wir reden jetzt nur gerade strategisch. Oder ist die erfolgreiche Politik? Aha, ich bekomme also bei Eltern mehr Stimmen. Ich bin jetzt ein konservativer Politiker. Ich bin zu irgendwas zwischen JD Vance und Spahn und sage mir, wir brauchen dringend eine Maximalquote von Ausländern in Schulen. Wer in der ersten Klasse kommt, muss Deutsch sprechen können, sonst geht es nicht. wir müssen Migration stoppen und mehr unsere eigenen Kinder unterstützen. wir brauchen dringend mehr Polizei, weil überall Leute mit Messern rumrennen. Und damit könnte man also wunderbar konservative Politik machen. Ich hatte kürzlich das Gespräch mit einem sehr linken Vater, der sich auch sehr mit Polizeigewalt, Rassismus und all dem auseinandersetzt. Und er sagt, seitdem ich Kinder habe, denke ich auch immer wieder mal in Law and Order-Kategorien. Das heißt, das ist halt die strategische Argument, dass er erstmal nicht jetzt für die grundsätzliche Entscheidung will, aber man muss sich klarmachen, es ist nicht unbedingt progressiv, wenn man Familien wählen lässt. An sich ist vorgesehen, wenn man, ich habe eine Hausarbeit geschickt bekommen von Giuliano, dass eigentlich...
Sehr gut, wenn Sie uns Hausarbeiten schicken, das ist wirklich, dann zeigt er uns, dass ihr wirklich Premium-Hörer seid.
Also sehr interessant, weil er sagt, ja, es ist eigentlich ein Menschenrecht, dass alle wählen. Und es gibt keine Begrenzung dort. Es ist nicht gesagt, und erst ab dann und dann. Und er verweist auch darauf, 1970 konnte man in Deutschland erst ab 21 wählen. Dann hat man das bis dahin, dann hat man es runtergesetzt auf 18 Jahre. Das heißt, auch da sehen wir immer wieder Anpassungen. Und er sagt auch, das Argument der Kompetenz ist nicht das Entscheidende. Denn sonst sind wir in einer Epistokratie. Sonst müssten wir wirklich Tests machen und müssten schauen, kennen sich die Leute dann wirklich auch.
Anderen ist es ein Wahlrecht.
Aber man kann natürlich auch, wenn man diese Argumentation folgt, muss man sich immer auch gewahr werden dessen, dass die Demokratie ja an sich ein Begriff ist, der ein Ideal markiert, das auf der Welt nicht zu erreichen ist und auch nirgends erreicht wird gerade.
Ja, wir haben ja dieses, genau, Böckenförde, man muss immer ein bisschen mehr arbeiten als einfach nur Selbsterhaltung der Demokratie und so weiter.
Die Frage ist ja, wo sollte die Demokratie enden? wir haben uns jetzt darauf geeinigt, dass wir das hier in Deutschland alle vier Jahre an so einer Wahlurne machen und dann gibt es noch mal Landtagwellen und Kommune und so was. Aber wir könnten ja auch sagen, wirkliche Demokratie ist erst, wenn wir alle mitbestimmen. wir brauchen ein Schweizer Modell. Jetzt werden die Schweizer auch sagen können, dass ihre Demokratie nicht vollendet ist. Das heißt, die Demokratie, das muss einem, glaube ich, klar sein, ist immer ein unvollendetes Projekt. Und da ist nur die Frage, wie kann man es näher an eine Vollendung bringen? Und da wäre ja dann zum Beispiel eine Öffnung hin, für ein Kinderwahlrecht sinnvoll. Und ich habe wirklich noch mal darüber nachgedacht und würde auch meine Position ein bisschen revidieren wollen, weil wir ja auch so genau wissen, wie inkompetente, erwachsene Leute sind. Wenn es um Kompetenz nicht geht, dann bin ich gegen ein Familienwahlrecht, weil dann nimmt man einfach von jemand anderem die Stimme. Das kann man nicht machen. Ich kann auch nicht für meine Verwandtschaft wählen, auch wenn ich es manchmal vielleicht gerne würde. Aber was man machen könnte, ist, dass man das Alter radikal runterstuft, dass man sagt, also ab wann ist man in der Lage, ein Kreuz zu machen auf einem Wahlzettel, dass man auch nicht einfach ein willkürliches Kreuz setzt. Dann könnte man sagen, man geht runter bis auf sieben Jahre oder so. Das könnte man tatsächlich machen. Dann kommt man vielleicht dem demokratischen Ideal näher, muss sich aber auch gewissen Gefahren bewusst sein, denn das bedeutet auch, Kinder werden mit Wahlkampf adressiert. Das bedeutet also Wahlkampfwerbung im Kinderkanal.
Kinder werden mit aller möglicher Werbung adressiert.
Man muss sich im Klaren sein, die AfD wird vor Grundschulen Lutscher verteilen. Ich will das jetzt nicht als Totschlagargument nehmen, sondern ich will sagen, das ist dann die wirklichkeit. Das kann auch die SPD da machen, aber das ist dann so.
Also man kann durchaus Werbe bannmeilen um Schulen.
Aber Kinder werden adressiert werden müssen. Wenn sie wählen sollen, dann müssen sie adressiert werden von Wahlkampfwerbung.
Das klingt jetzt moralisch und dramatisch. Ich möchte es gerne humoristisch illustrieren. Ich glaube, das versteht dann sofort jeder. In Deutschland ist es möglich, mit 17 Jahren oder jüngeren Abitur zu schreiben. Man kann gerne mal auf die Server gehen und sich die Mathe-Abitur-Aufgaben der letzten Jahre anschauen und sich fragen, Leute, die das bestehen, geben wir kein Wahlrecht für einen Bundestag? Das ist absurd. Also auf der Ebene ist das auf jeden Fall absurd.
Epistokratisch argumentiert. Juliano bringt ja dieses Beispiel, das wir alle kennen, nur einer von acht Amerikanern weiß auf der Landkarte, den Irak zu zeigen. Aber man führt ja Krieg und hat aber da eine Auffassung zum Krieg oder sowas.
Ich lese mal weiter aus der Mail, denn jetzt nähern wir uns dem Punkt, der mir am wichtigsten ist. Johannes schreibt als Feindbild, das sieht man ja auch gerade in Trumps Vance Kampagne, gegen die kinderlose Harris steht die selbstbestimmte Frau, die sich in vielen Fällen entscheidet, keine Kinder zu bekommen und beispielsweise dem Berufsleben, aber auch anderen gesellschaftlichen Impact den Vorzug gibt. So, damit habe ich ein gigantisches Problem. Das ist im Grunde der Anlass, warum ich überhaupt das Buch schreibe. Diese Idee davon, die selbstbestimmte Frau ist dann besonders frei und förderungswürdig und wird deswegen von Trump und Vance bekämpft, weil sie eine freie Entscheidung kann zwischen Berufsleben oder Familie. Das ist der große Denkfehler. Das können wir uns nicht mehr erlauben. wir leben nicht mehr in diesen 50er-, 60er-, 70er-Jahren oder den 18. oder 17. Jahrhunderten, wo wir einfach immer sagen können, der nächste Jahr kommt. Sondern nein, der kommt nicht. Also die Kinderzahl pro Frau in Berlin ist gerade 1,17. Das bedeutet, innerhalb von einer Generation wird die Bevölkerung halbiert. Damit ist kein Staat zu machen. Also das ist einfach faktisch. Das ist jenseits von der Meinungslage. Wenn du 100 Leute im Rentenalter hast und es kommen aber nur noch 50 nach, dann ist aus. Also dann sind das einfach nordkoreanische Verhältnisse für alle Betroffenen. Da wird es dann wirklich kritisch, was eben bedeutet, wir können uns das gar nicht länger leisten zu sagen, ja die selbstbestimmte Frau soll einfach mit 23 entscheiden, ob sie jetzt Beruf oder Kinder. Nein, es muss natürlich beides gehen. wir brauchen eine beruflich erfüllte Frau, die trotzdem noch drei Kinder hat. Und wenn es dann heißt, ja aber der Tag hat nur 24 Stunden, ja dann braucht sie halt Personal. Jeder CEO hat Personal. Man hat eine Sekretärin, man hat einen Fahrer. Mütter brauchen das dann auch. Drei Kinder kommen nicht einfach so in die Welt. Also auf der Ebene würde ich gerne das hier neu machen.
Du musst nur bedenken, dass das Personal auch wiederum...
Da gibt es ja dann die Energieeffekte. Das ist ja das Tolle.
Na ja, in den USA haben auch sehr viele Leute Personal, aber das sind dann Mütter, die ihre Kinder nicht sehen, weil die Kinder in Lateinamerika sitzen.
Verstehe ich sofort, was du sagen möchtest. Aber ein ICE mit 30.000 PS. Der auf 400 Meter Länge so und so viele Menschen transportiert, braucht jemanden im Führerstand, fünf Leute, die anwesend sind, um sich um irgendwas zu kümmern und nochmal 100 Leute, die sich darum kümmern, dass der Betrieb läuft. So, man kriegt damit eine ganze Kleinstadt in den Urlaub gefahren, mit diesen 100 Leuten Personal. Das meine ich mit Personal. Das muss natürlich organisiert werden. Ich meine jetzt nicht vorzeitliche, aristokratische, oben lebende Dienstmädchen für die Familie und so. Sondern nein, das muss natürlich klug organisiert werden. Aber ein öffentlicher Nahverkehr läuft für mich schon unter Personal. Eine Kinderbetreuung bis 20 Uhr, Betreuungsschlüssel 1 zu 7 oder so, ist für mich, das läuft unter Personal. Also hier geht es nicht darum, dass wir nochmal zusätzlich Bevölkerung abziehen, um Mütter zu unterstützen, sondern nein, es muss einfach clever organisiert werden.
Das ist ein Prozent Feminismus, wo man sagt, die CEO bekommt jetzt mehr Personal.
Zauberwort, das hier neu vorzustellen ist, dann ist Sozialstaat.
Ja.
Ist gar nicht so kompliziert. wir wissen eigentlich, worum es geht, aber ja. Also, ich muss hier gegen Johannes und Vance Familienbild anargumentieren, während wir gerade mitgekriegt haben, dass Johannes ja totale Gegner von Vance ist. Und ich sage, ja, die sind schon totale Gegner, aber die haben beide dasselbe Familienbild. Das ungerätete Vorzeichen ändert hier gar nichts.
Was Herr, glaube ich, der Fernnesser Alba, muss man es erwähnen, sagen will, ist, dass es ja eine bewusste Entscheidung sein kann, keine Kinder zu haben. Oder manchmal ist es auch gar keine Entscheidung, sondern man kann keine Kinder haben, aus anderen Gründen.
Oder man kann keine Kinder haben und will vielleicht trotzdem welche. Vielleicht sollten wir selbst mal über die biologische Geburtenfolge nachdenken. Vielleicht muss man den Familienbegriff sogar da mal aufbauen.
So, aber wenn man jetzt Leute ausstattet mit Kindern, mit mehr Wahlrecht, mit mehr Stimmen, als die Leute, die keine Kinder bekommen können oder wollen, dann ist das eine Ungerechtigkeit. Und auf diese zielt er ja hier ab. Und das würde ich auch ganz deutlich so unterstreichen wollen, weil man dann einfach nur sagt, dass Eltern einen besseren Status bekommen. wir haben ja akzeptiert, dass Eltern zum Beispiel steuerlich besser gestellt werden, als Menschen, die keine Kinder haben. Das hat auch seinen Sinn. Und es gibt ja viele weitere Förderungen. Kann man auch immer sagen, geht nicht weit genug, sicherlich. Was ich aber nicht sagen würde, ist, dass man ihnen, nur weil sie Kinder haben, jetzt mehr Stimmen geben sollte. Und man muss ja auch erkennen, du gehst zwar immer auf das Demografische ein, das ist auch richtig, nur ist ja die Entscheidung, ein Kind zu bekommen, davon vollkommen losgelöst. Also niemand bringt ja ein Kind auf die Welt aus demografischen Gründen, sondern Kinder kommen auf die Welt entweder aus Versehen oder aus egoistischen Gründen.
Genau, und das ist ja der Punkt, weshalb wir dieses JD. Vance, Zitat, über das, was in dem Video hinaus zu hören ist, nämlich dieses Investment in Society. Für JD. Vance sind Kinder, die geboren werden, seine Kinder. Er ist der Politiker, der als großer Patriarch da so drüber steht und sagt, und wir hören das gleich an Clips. Also ich will es gar nicht weiter ausführen, sondern an den Clips hört man dann, wie er das meint. Das ist wirklich hochgradig dramatisch. Und ich möchte noch mal einen Begriff vorstellen. Jetzt habe ich schon den Sozialstaat genannt und so. Das sind ja alles keine neuen Begriffe, sondern man muss sie nur mal anders anlegen. Ich will noch mal einen Begriff vorschlagen. Ich war ja auch in Bielefeld jetzt im Monat und habe dort bei Stefan Kühl mal im Kolokvium mein Buch so ein bisschen besprochen. Ich habe mir gedacht, wieso bin ich so selten in Bielefeld? Wieso bin ich nie in Kolokvium? Wo sind die Studenten? Ladet mich ein. Ich halte auch gerne Vorträge oder so einmal im Jahr. Aber Kolokvium, ich komme immer gern. Dort war die Frage, die du gerade aufgeworfen hast. Was ist jetzt mit denen, die keine Kinder haben wollen? Die GD Vance ja dann als childless cat lady und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt, hierfür brauchen wir einen neuen Begriff. Und in Bielefeld kam der Vorschlag, einfach einen alten zu benutzen, aber ernst zu nehmen.
Haushalt.
Das Elementare in der Gesellschaft ist nicht das Individuum, sondern der Haushalt, in dem man lebt. So wie in der Gesellschaft auch nichts hingekriegt wird, solange man nicht Organisationen hat, die gestalten. Familien sind keine Organisation, sie können nicht einfach über Mitgliedschaft und so, da wäre noch keine Boni ausgezahlt und keine Zwecke verhandelt oder was auch immer. Also es ist einfach keine Organisation. Aber der Haushaltsbegriff, den kann man dafür wirklich noch mal, das werde ich im Buch richtig betonen. Das Elementare in der Gesellschaft ist der Haushalt. Nicht ohne Grund kommt der Dona Hayali und sagt, jeder, der einen Haushalt führt, weiß, Christa Lindner hat es schwer. Und dann machen wir uns darüber lustig, weil da eine Verwechslung stattfindet. Aber der Haushalt ist ein sehr wichtiger Begriff. So, ich möchte jetzt diesen Haushaltsbegriff so benutzen, dass egal ist, ob da Kinder leben oder nicht, wenn ein Haushalt aus zwei Menschen besteht, zwei Stimmen. Wenn es drei Leute sind, weil sich Dreierwachsen entscheiden, Haushalte führen, haben die drei Stimmen. Wenn jetzt zwei Leute sich entscheiden, zwei Kinder zu haben, ist das ein vierköpfiger Haushalt. Und meine Frage ist dann, warum hat er nur zwei Stimmen? Aber wie wird konkret wer wählt? Dem nähern wir uns jetzt. So, erstmal müssen wir diesen Haushalt, wie ich ihn jetzt vorgestellt habe, gegen das Familienbild von JD. Vance abgrenzen. Denn hier droht wirklich Gefährliches, wenn Jens Spahn jetzt beim Parteitag rumsteht und sagt, wir halten mal mit denen Kontakt. Und die haben ja auch ganz gute Ideen, wie zum Beispiel das Familienwahlrecht oder sowas. Ich will jetzt mal spielen, diese Clips sind auf Empfehlungen von Humann. Die habe ich auch erst die Tage jetzt. Ich bin wirklich aus allen Wolken gefallen. Die Sendung, die wir jetzt hören, heisst USA Extrem und wurde vom CDF produziert. Man hat Idaho, Oklahoma und den ganzen wilden Westendammer besucht. wir hören jetzt hier, wie extrem JD. Vance Familienideologie auf die Spitze getrieben werden kann. Und zwar als faktische Politik.
Reale gelebte Gesellschaft.
Es geht um die Frage, wann sitzen Frauen, warum im Gefängnis hier Oklahoma?
Viele der Frauen sitzen wegen Drogendelikten ein. Andere für ein Vergehen, das in Oklahoma härter bestraft wird als anderswo. Mütterliche Vernachlässigung. Verkürzt heißt das, wenn ein Vater sein Kind schlägt, kann die Mutter dafür härter bestraft werden als der Vater, weil sie die Schläge nicht verhindert hat.
So, wie weit kann man es treiben? Hier Einzelfall.
2021 sind 342 Frauen in Oklahoma wegen mütterlicher Vernachlässigung in Haft. Jede sechste Insassin. Auch die 19-jährige Tondaleo Hall wird dafür 2004 eingesperrt. Ihr damaliger Partner schlägt ihre beiden drei Monate und zwei Jahre alten Kinder. Sie erleiden Knochenbrüche. Er wird zu zehn Jahren Haft verurteilt, sitzt aber nur zwei ab. Tondaleo Hall bekommt 30 Jahre, weil sie ihre Kinder nicht beschützt hat.
So, der Vater schlägt das Kind und JD. Vance aus seiner Sicht sagt dann, das geht nicht. Du darfst Kinder nicht schlagen, sie sind ja meine Kinder. Du ziehst die ja nur für mich groß. Es geht ja um mein demografisches Heil. Und dann fragt er sich, wen bestraf ich denn jetzt, um auch ein Exempel zu statuieren. Dann kriegt der Vater zehn Jahre für die Schläge und die Mutter bekommt 30 Jahre, weil sie diese Schläge nicht verhindert hat. Wahnsinn. Und während der Vater nach zwei Jahren wieder raus ist, sitzt sie nach 20 Jahren. 2004 wurde sie verurteilt, immer noch im Gefängnis. Erst medialer Druck hat sie dann sozusagen ein bisschen früher geholt, aber das Strafmaß war 30 Jahre und wäre auf juristischen Wegen nicht zu verkürzen gewesen. Das ist das Familienmodell von JD Vance. Ja, also darauf läuft das hinaus.
Also das ist auch genau das, wo Kamala Harris, glaube ich, sehr viele noch mal erreichen kann. Also ich will das und das stört mich so, dass man so wenig über diese konkreten Dinge redet. Ich bin ja froh, die Amerikaner werden es wahrscheinlich intuitiv wissen, was gemeint ist, wenn Kamala Harris da einige Projekte anschiebt. Also worum es aber hier im deutschen Diskurs so geht, ja über irgendwas mit Testosteron und wir machen jetzt ein bisschen Female Empowerment. Nee, es geht um ganz, ganz konkrete Situationen, wo einfach eine Trump-Regierung natürlich diese ohnehin desaströsen Zustände verschlechtern würde.
Und nicht nur wird dir Lebenszeit genommen als Mutter, wenn du nicht für Trumps Nachwuchs sorgst für den nächsten Jahrgang, sondern es kostet auch.
In Oklahoma müssen die Insassen einen Teil der Gefängniskosten selbst tragen. Das heißt, je länger die Strafe, desto höher die Kosten.
Ich schulde den Behörden 107.000 Dollar für sieben Jahre.
Die Frauen kommen aus dem Gefängnis und kriegen für ihre Haft eine Rechnung vorgelegt. Wegen mütterlicher Vernachlässigung, das ist jetzt noch der Kostenfaktor dazu. Hier noch ein Beispiel.
Brandy hat ihr halbes Leben hinter Gittern verbracht. Auch ihr Vergehen lautet mütterliche Vernachlässigung. Heute wird sie entlassen.
Kannst du das fassen?
21,5 Jahre, auf den Tag genau.
Ja, auf den Tag.
Du siehst fantastisch aus.
Der Eyeliner passt zur Bluse.
Passt perfekt.
Ja, sehr hübsch.
Brandys Sohn stirbt mit einem Jahr an Meningitis. Das Gericht spricht Brandy wegen Misshandlung schuldig.
20 Jahre Haft. Also diese alte Ronald Reagan Idee, wir dürfen keine Familienpolitik machen, weil wir uns nicht in den heiligen Bund zwischen Mutter und Tochter oder Sohn und Mutter einmischen dürfen. Ja, das wurde hier wirklich auf die Spitze getrieben, die letzten Jahre. Und das droht, das sind ja dann auch diese Bundesstaaten, die sagen, ach so, der Supreme Court erlaubt uns jetzt wieder Abtreibung. Keine Abtreibung mehr. Egal in welchem Fall. Jedes Kind wird geboren, weil es ist nicht das Kind der Mutter oder des Vergewaltigers oder was auch immer, sondern es ist unser Nachwuchs. Also wir haben da eine staatliche Hoheit drüber. Jetzt ist es so, als das jetzt diskutiert wurde, was JD Vance da gesagt hat, es geht um Verantwortung und Investment in die Gesellschaft. Die Kinder sind nicht deine eigenen Kinder. Du bist nur sozusagen von Gott aus erwählt, das Kind auszutragen. Es ist dann deine weltliche Aufgabe dafür zu sorgen. Und wenn du der widersprichst, dann gibt es von uns keine Gnade, sondern einfach so da direkt. Jetzt hat Pete Budichich bei John Stewart folgende Anmerkung zu diesem JD Vance Spruch gemacht.
Er hat diese Idee, dass du extra Votes bekommen sollst, wenn du Kinder hast. Ja, er hat suggeriert, dass du extra Votes haben sollst, wenn du ein Kind bist.
Ich denke, es gibt viele Dinge...
So, jetzt sagt also ein ehemaliger Soldat. Naja, wenn der JD Vance sagt, Menschen ohne Kinder sind ja nicht so physisch involviert in die Gesellschaft und ihre Zukunft, weil sie werden nicht überlebt von der nächsten Generation, dann sagt er, naja, aber ich hab mich auch ziemlich physisch committed gefühlt, als ich im Afghanistan einsatz- dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, lebensbedrohlich da bedroht wurde. Wenn man jetzt diesen Weg weitergeht, würde das ja wirklich bedeuten, also er macht das ja nur als, ich will es ihm jetzt nicht unterstellen, es ist ja nur ein Kontrapunkt. Aber wenn man jetzt diese Diskussion mit JD Vance und wie Pete das hier vorgestellt hat, weitergeht, müsste man ja irgendwie eine Argumentation machen und die liegt ja den Silicon Valley-Leuten wieder nah. Ich habe ja 100 Angestellte, für die ich Verantwortung übernehme. Warum ist, warum habe ich nur eine Wahlstimme? Ich habe mein Leben für das Land riskiert. Wolfgang möchte flüchten im Kriegseinfang. Warum bin ich nicht mehr wert sozusagen? Und da ist ja völlig klar, das machen wir ja nicht. One person, one vote. Und jetzt ist ja nur die Frage, sind Kinder jetzt einfach so eine Minderheit, die wir so ein bisschen mitschützen, bis sie irgendwann mündig werden? Oder sagen wir einfach, ne, das ist auch one person.
Ja, dazu ist ja Folgendes zu sagen. Kinder haben oder jeder Mensch hat ja das Potenzial, in der Lage zu sein, also grundsätzlich gibt es, wir müssen nochmal anders sagen, also anthropologische Sporn ist einfach der Mensch als Person, vernunftbegabt, etc. Das ist aber nicht immer aktuell der Fall. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel schlafe, bin ich nicht gerade der aufgeklärte Bürger. So. Und trotzdem darf man mich dann zum Beispiel nicht totschlagen.
Außer Linnemann weckt dich und fragt dich, was sind die drei Kernpunkte der CDU?
Dann würde ich sagen, irgendwas mit Bürgergeld.
Sonst würde ich Stimmrecht entzogen.
So.
Das ist so. Jetzt ist es bei Kindern ein besonderer Fall. Es gibt sehr begabte Kinder, clever Kinder. wir können aber sagen, ja, ab einem gewissen Alter kann man größere Zusammenhänge verstehen. Man kann wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen, dass Kinder, die ein paar Jahre zur Schule gehen, gerade kognitiv sogar weiter sind als manche Erwachsene, die einfach gar nichts mehr lesen oder so. Diese ganzen Sachen kann man verstehen. Was man aber sagen kann, ist ja, dass aktuell Dreijährige nicht in der Lage sind, irgendeinen politischen Zusammenhang zu verstehen.
Weshalb wir ja gleich noch über das delegatete Thema der Delegation sprechen.
Das können wir ja grundsätzlich für alle Kinder sagen. Man kann nicht sagen, ja doch, aber manche schon. wir können bei Erwachsenen sagen, grundsätzlich ist das möglich. Dann werden uns Fälle einfallen, wo das dann doch nicht aktuell der Fall ist. Aber wir können da so eine kategoriale Unterscheidung machen. So funktioniert ja auch z.B. Strafrecht, dass wir sagen, also grundsätzlich kann man mit sieben Jahren nicht mündig sein. Kann das nicht wirklich gewollt haben, diese Tat. Mit 18 oder 19 sieht das schon anders aus. Und hier ist die Frage, kommt man also da, kann man diesen Sprung machen, darüber hinwegzugehen, also nicht mehr Potenzialität und Aktualität von Kompetenz oder Vernunft oder irgendetwas zu sehen, spielt es grundsätzlich keine Rolle. Sagen wir einfach nur jeder Mensch eine Stimme. Und dann stellt sich eine ganz praktische Frage, wie sollen jene wählen, die noch nicht auf eigenen Beinen dorthin kommen und noch nicht wissen, dass sie wählen können, nämlich z.B. Zweijährige. Das heißt, wir müssten also, wenn wir es nicht anderen übergeben wollen, das wäre dann das JD Vans Ding.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Müssen wir sagen, erst ab, sagen wir, sieben Jahren ist es möglich.
Ja, also eigentlich war mein Plan schon darauf hinzuweisen, dass nur weil jemand anders wählt, ist noch nicht der JD Vans Plan ist, sondern Lukas Dietrich z.B., Vater und Lehrer, schreibt ja, wir tragen die Verantwortung über fünf Personen, die von allen politischen Entscheidungen sicher betroffen sein werden. Also der Haushalt ist auf jeden Fall betroffen. So, und dürfen nur zwei Stimmen abgeben. Ich sehe absolut kein Argument auf Wolfgangs Seite. Jeder sollte die Möglichkeit haben, über die eigene Zukunft entscheiden. Und das hast du ja schon eingewendet. Aber wie denn? Ein Zweijähriger, wie soll das nicht funktionieren?
Nicht für jemanden kann man entscheiden.
Und jetzt werde ich diese Diskussion mal öffnen mit einer meiner Lieblingsargumentationen. Martin Kroska schrieb nämlich zustimmend zu meinem Anliegen und dann allerdings sehe ich einen Knackpunkt dabei, wer genau die Stimme der Kinder bekommt. Die Mutter, der Vater, wird das durch das Sorgenrecht bestimmt. So und wir haben ja schon festgestellt, wir haben alle ökonomischen Fragen irgendwie so modernisiert. Also wir wissen so, was Profit ist. wir müssen nicht mehr am Erlaubnis fragen. wir haben einfach so ein, ja und dann ist halt klar, okay, machen wir jetzt so. Politisch ist das ja so ein bisschen anders. wir sind immer noch so in normativen Zwängen. Also dieses Verhältnis aus Politik und Ökonomie ist ja sehr merkwürdig, wie zum Beispiel dann wieder umgedreht. wir haben die Politik dadurch, dass sie in normativen Zwängen ist, modernisiert. wir haben die normativen Zwänge modernisiert. Es ist nicht mehr das Gottesgnadentum und dann ist so eine Urkunde, wo steht, das ist Gottesgnade, sondern du musst schon Wahlergebnis vorweisen können. Am Ende wird ein Stimmen ausgezählt. In der Politik, damit geregelt, in der Ökonomie wieder völlig verworren, da sagt man einfach, das ist das Geld deiner Eltern, klar, das ist deins. Das muss jetzt nicht demokratisiert werden. Da haben wir so eine Ungleichgewichtung. Und jetzt, in diesem Kontext, wenn wir im Restaurant sitzen und neben uns sitzen zwei Erwachsene mit einem Kind, streiten sich diese beiden Erwachsenen darüber, wer für das Kind bezahlt. Oder ist das auf modernem Wege implizit einfach organisiert? Geht man in einem Supermarkt einkaufen und sagt, ja, also das ist hier für das Kind, ich will das nicht bezahlen, das ist ja nicht meins, ich kaufe ja nicht für mich. Da kriegt man auch keine Rechtfertigungspflichten umgedreht. Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber ich stelle mir das durchaus vor, dass es diese Streitigkeiten gibt. Nee, an wen zahlen wir Kindergeld? Es gibt keine, also in Deutschland ist völlig klar.
Aber es gibt auch unglaublich viele Menschen, die nicht mehr verheiratet sind und Kinder haben und die voneinander getrennt sind. Genau, dann kommen doch schon diese Fragen rein. Aber ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob die Frage, also ich glaube, dass diese Frage lässt sich lösen.
Die lässt sich nicht nur lösen, sondern die ist flächendeckend für 14 Millionen Kinder in Deutschland gelöst. Das Kindergeld wird ausgezahlt, ohne dass diejenigen, die das Kindergeld bekommen, dem Staat antworten. Also da haben sie das denn dem Ehemann ausgezahlt, ich will das Kindergeld haben.
Also da, wo das Kind im Haushalt lebt, könnte man sagen, wird gewählt. Nur ist es immer noch eine Übertragung einer Stimme und macht damit nicht die Kinder wählen beim Familienwahlrecht, sondern man sagt nur, wir übervorteilen die Eltern, nur weil sie Kinder haben, sollen sie mehr Stimmen haben. Die Eltern, weil das hier so argumentiert wird, dass die Eltern da Entscheidungen jetzt treffen auf Kosten der Kinder oder im Sinne der Kinder, das geschieht die ganze Zeit. Also ob die jetzt mit einer Stimme wählen oder mit fünf Stimmen wählen, sie wählen immer nur ihre Sache. Sie wählen nicht für die Kinder. Das bedeutet nur, dass alle Kinderlosen schlechter dastehen. Und deswegen sollte es kein Familienwahlrecht geben, weil das tatsächlich einfach nur Leute bevorteilt. Dann kann man auch sagen, alle Leute, die mehr als 5.000 Netto im Monat haben, sollten drei Stimmen bekommen. Das wäre genau so eine sinnlose Argumentation.
Guck mal, ist ja genau nicht so. Ich habe ja eben, wenn jemand kommt wie Elon Musk und sagt, ich habe aber 300.000 Mitarbeiter, ich hätte gerne mehr Stimmrecht, der argumentiert ja so.
Ja, du machst aber Tür und Tor für so Sachen auf. Warum?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, stopp, stopp, stopp. Guck mal, ein Kind ist eine Person, die noch ein Mitarbeiter ist auch eine Person, aber die hat ein Stimmrecht.
Die hat ein Stimmrecht. Okay, dann gehen wir noch mal einen Schritt zurück und sagen, ein Kind soll wählen können. Aber dann soll es auch wählen können. Aber nicht der Vater, der gerne seine Sache noch mal...
Gehen wir mal von dem zweijährigen Kind aus. Das zweijährige Kind trifft keine Entscheidung selbst. Es muss aber Entscheidungen getroffen werden für das Kind, ansonsten bleibt es nämlich nur zwei Jahre und stirbt. Irgendwer muss für ein Kind entscheiden, in allen Lebenslagen. Und sonderbarerweise nehmen wir eine, von der ich dann wieder sage, es ist eine sehr wichtige, nehmen wir dann raus. Wie ernähren wir ein Kind? Das entscheiden auch einfach die Eltern. Da kommt auch keiner um die Ecke und mischt sich irgendwie ein. Da wird mal eine Kinderarztuntersuchung angehend.
Ja, weil wir sagen, dass Kinder noch nicht mündig sind.
Und deswegen ist die Frage, weil das Kind muss ja trotzdem ernährt werden. Es ist ja trotzdem eine biologische Person.
Ja, natürlich.
Aber es ist ja auch eine politische Person. Nein, in dem Sinne nicht.
Also wenn man jetzt Bürgerschaft, das Cetouan auffasst, der aufgeklärte Bürger, dann würde man genau sagen nicht. Also es liegt halt einfach da und schreit und kann deshalb keinen politischen Willen bekunden.
Aber es ist ja trotzdem eine Person.
Es ist eine Person, ja, aber es wird ja auch mit abgedeckt von der Wahl. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass wir eine Politik haben.
Es wird ja nicht mit abgedeckt.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass wir wählen ja für das Ganze. Das heißt, ich wähle ja auch mit meiner Stimme zum Beispiel für Anliegen, die mich gar nicht betreffen. Ich zum Beispiel wähle, also für ausschlaggebend für meine Wähler, für meine Wahlentscheidungen ist schon, macht man gute Politik für Kinder und für die Bildung. Ich selbst bin kein Kind mehr. Ich habe keine Kinder. mir könnte es also auch scheißegal sein. Aber ich mache das so, weil ich das als wichtig empfinde.
Also wir lesen im Salon diesen vierseitigen Text von Aladin Malafalani, in dem steht einfach drin, das Bildungssystem in Deutschland ist gerade nicht der Rede wert. Es ist einfach quasi nicht existent.
Aber daran würde ja ein Vier in Wahlrecht 0.0 ändern.
wir haben sehr lange, also was heißt ja lange, wir haben jetzt bei Corona festgestellt, Homeschooling gibt es nicht. Und jetzt stellen wir so fest, Schulschooling gibt es auch nicht so richtig. Es hängt doch sehr viel von der Motivation der Eltern ab, ob die die Lehrer kümmern, also die können das gar nicht. Ein Kind, das von seinem Haushalt nicht dabei unterstützt wird, in der Schule gut zu sein, kann die Schule nicht bewältigen. Das Bildungssystem ist so...
Aber Stefan, das ist doch alles nicht zu leugnen, natürlich. Aber du sag mir, was das Familienwahlrecht daran ändert.
Jetzt warte auf mein Argument. Das ist ja erst mal nur eine These, ja? Also die Argumentation folgt jetzt. So, meine Arbeitshypothese ist, wenn in Deutschland 14 Millionen Menschen, die vom Schulsystem betroffen sind und die sich zuletzt ein Recht auf Schule beim Bundesverfassungsgericht als neues Grundrecht erklagt haben, unzugesprochen bekommen haben.
Das war aber nicht 14 Millionen, das war irgendeine kleine Gruppe, die geklagt hat.
Ja, so ist das. Das ist Repräsentation. Es gibt Leute, die sich für das Recht auf Schule, nachdem sie das Defizit durch Corona feststellen. So, 14 Millionen Menschen, die von diesem Bildungssystem betroffen wären. Meine Arbeitshypothese ist einfach nur, es würde in der Bildungspolitik einen Unterschied machen.
Ich glaube es gar nicht. Also es wird eine andere Bildungspolitik geben.
wir haben 18 Millionen Rentner, die dürfen wählen und deswegen sieht die Rentenpolitik aus, wie sie aussieht. In den Schulen ist nichts los und die höchste Rentenerhöhung seit 30 Jahren.
Ja, ich gehe fest davon aus.
Einfach nur, weil die Rentner wählen dürfen.
Ich gehe fest davon aus.
Das liegt nur daran, dass die Rentner alle wählen. Wenn die 18 Millionen Rentner nicht wählen dürften, würden sie behandeln wie die Hochaltrigen während der Corona-Pandemie. Die würden in irgendwelchen Häusern liegen, niemand würde sich darum kümmern. Und Bartsch würde im Bundestag sagen, es ist das dunkelste Kapitel der deutschen Nachkriegsgeschichte.
Natürlich.
Und das dunkelste Kapitel der deutschen Nachkriegsgeschichte ist derzeit das Bildungssystem.
Ja, aber daran würde sich durch ein Familienwahlrecht nichts ändern. wir bekämen mehr Polizei, irgendwelche verrückten Migrationsquoten in Klassen und und und. Es würde sich am Bildungssystem an sich nichts ändern. Hier hören uns jetzt fast nur progressive Eltern zu, die genau dir zustimmen, mir zustimmen. Ich will mir Falani zustimmen, alles so sehen. Aber das ist nicht die Mehrheit und genau deshalb findet Jens Spahn das ja toll. Und ich will nochmal deutlich machen, ich will nicht, dass Stimmen übertragen werden können, dass jemand anders mit seiner Idiosynchrosie plötzlich doppelt ausgestattet wählen gehen kann. Da bin ich dagegen.
Dann sage ich, die Kinder müssen selbst wählen.
Ich bin dafür, die Kinder sollen wählen. Wählen mir ab sieben oder sechs Jahren, die Pädagogen sollen es wegen mir entscheiden. Ich habe kein Problem damit, das können wir gerne machen.
Das ist, finde ich, noch die verrücktere Idee als ein Familienwahlrecht.
Nein, das finde ich.
Sechsjährige, siebenjährige Kinder, die wählen.
Wieso? Kinder sind gar nicht blöd, ne?
Kinder wissen, Kinder sitzen nämlich in dieser Schule.
Ich war, ich hatte ja, ich habe es glaube ich schon erzählt, ich war ja vor einigen Wochen in Trier bei einer Freundin, die zwei Kinder hatte und der eine kam aus der Kita und sagte, und wie alt ist er, knapp fünf, und sagte dann, ja das ist alles ganz schlimm im Sommer, alles ist kaputt, wir müssen in die Turnhalle, weil es da kühler ist. Ich würde sagen, den kann man adressieren als Wähler. Bei diesem Familienwahlrecht, glaube ich, macht man einen fundamentalen Fehler, man überträgt nämlich ein Wahlrecht und entmündigt eigentlich die Kinder noch nur in einer anderen Weise. Also Kinder sind nicht mündig, und das hat ja sehr viele gute Gründe, gerade was strafrechtliche Dinge anbelangt. Und wenn ich jetzt sage, ja dann müssten die aber doch eine Stimme haben, und ich wähle für die, die werden aber nicht gefragt, weil man Zweijährige nicht fragen kann, dann entmündige ich sie nur in einer anderen Weise, weil ich nicht weiß, was dieses Kind will. Vielleicht wird dieses Kind am Ende bittere Vorwürfe machen, warum, liebe Eltern, habt ihr jahrelang noch meine Stimme verwendet, um Partei XY zu wählen. Und das ist keine gute Geschichte. Deswegen bleibt die Demokratie ein unerreichtes, unvollendetes Ideal.
Na gut.
Aber ich finde, man sollte das Wahlalter herunter setzen. Also wir gehen auf sieben. Okay.
Also sieben Jahre heißt ja Zweitklässler, Erstklässler, Zweitklässler. In dem machen die eh schon Demokratie. Die wählen Klassensprecher, die entscheiden mit, wenn die Lehrerin fit ist.
Die können in Vereine gehen, Fußballvereine und so was.
Ja, ich finde auch, man sollte erst mal relativ zügig Kinder in der Schule ermächtigen, selbstwirksamkeit zu erfahren.
Da stelle ich mir echt, ich habe das eben so schlimm ausgemalt mit die AfD verteilt Lutscher vor der Schule. Aber da kann man sich ja auch mal Positives ausmalen. Was braucht ihr für euren Sportverein? Ich brauche die Kinder als Wähler.
Also sind sie doch plötzlich Wahlkampf, inhaltlich verändernde Subjekte, endlich statt nur Objekte in einem politischen Prozess.
Dann sind sie nicht mehr Objekte, dann kann man sie direkt ansprechen. Und ich will hier nicht das verklären und sagen, wie Kinder sind die besseren Menschen oder so. Kinder können auch ungerecht böse und alles Mögliche sein. Aber da kann man natürlich ein Wahlkampf mitmachen.
Absolut.
Und ich glaube, dass zum Beispiel auch Neunjährige nicht sagen werden, dass Migration ihr großes Problem ist.
Das Neunjährige, es gibt ganz herrliche Videos, wie Kinder zu zweit aus Klassen übereinander ausgefragt werden. Dann hast du Kinder im Rollstuhl, Kinder mit afrikanischem Migrationshintergrund, der nun wirklich sehr sichtbar ist und so. Und niemand redet darüber, dass da jemand im Rollstuhl sitzt oder einen afrikanischen Migrationshintergrund hat. Das kommt wirklich erst später. Das sind wirklich ganz konstruierte Debatten. Und da, würde ich sagen, braucht man auch diesen feministischen, emanzipatorischen, aus allen Richtungen Diversität fördernden, also die Anerkennung fördernden Diskurse. Denn während die eine Seite jetzt immer sagt, die treiben es zu weit und wie auch immer, sage ich, nee, das ist viel zu zackhafen. Viel zu zackhafen. Also der Vokismus in diesen wichtigen Sparten wurde wirklich noch nicht weit genug getrieben. Denn die meisten Argumentationen, die man so hört, sind einfach strunzdorf. Also das, was JD. Vance so erzählt die ganze Zeit. Ich glaube, die Leute kriegen einfach mit, es macht keinen Sinn, darauf inhaltlich zu reagieren. Deswegen ist dieser Wahlkampf im Internet jetzt auch so, wie er ist, der mobilisiert nicht über diese Inhalte, weil diese Inhalte sind aber witzig. Angefangen, und das finde ich wirklich hervorragend, dass das Familienbild jetzt so zentral steht. Scott Galloway hat schon dazu aufgerufen, dass die Demokraten jetzt all in gehen beim Thema Family Well-Use und einfach sagen, drei Kinder oder fünf Kinder mit drei Frauen, wie bei Donald Trump, begrüßen wir, finden wir gut. wir mögen es nicht ganz so sehr, dass unsere neunjährigen Kinder vom Fernseher sitzen und wir dann erklären müssen, wer Stormy Daniels ist. Na ja, die prostituierte Porno-Darstellerin, wie auch immer, mit der Trump-Wistheit-Bär und so weiter. Das ist dann so ein bisschen heikel, aber warum man nicht mit drei Frauen fünf Kinder haben sollte, um dann auch die Milliarden, die man hat, da einfach zu investieren in das Lebensglück nachziehender Generation, ja, und da muss man halt richtig reingehen. Und das finde ich auch. Da sollten die Demokraten einfach sagen, ich bin kinderlos, kein Problem, Donald Trump hat fünf Kinder mit drei Frauen, kein Problem, wenn dann habt ihr denn mit sowas ein Problem, wir nicht, fangt nicht an, mit Family Values zu reden und so. Und da finde ich, ja, da sollte man wirklich jetzt diese, wir sind halt eine sehr träge alten Republik, aber das sind für mich die Themen, ja, und nicht, also taggeistig im Kommentar, ob Kamala Harris lacht, ja. Nee, das sind ja, es gibt doch so tolle Themen zum Kommentieren, also es ist wirklich dramatisch.
Es gibt auch sehr viele ernste Themen. wir hören jetzt einen kompletten Beitrag aus dem Heute-Journal. Ich will den noch gerade kontextualisieren. Ich habe an der Uni Tübingen einen Vortrag gehalten. Da gibt es auch so neue ökonomische Denkweisen, also studentisch organisiert. Die laden dann Leute ein und es ging um Schuldenbremse, etc. Ich fahre also von Tübingen nach Stuttgart, weil ich da auch dann am nächsten Tag noch einen Vortrag hatte. Bin im Motel One in der Bar, trinke noch einen und dort wird aber Fußball noch übertragen. Dann kommt ja in der Halbzeit das verkürzte Heute-Journal. Knapp fünf Minuten, nur NATO-Gipfel, große Paraden. Und sie haben jetzt mal so ein Manöver geflogen und und und. Also diese ganze Pistorius, ein Soldat.
Lass mich kurz sagen, Pistorius stand in diesen Nachrichten auf dem Flugfeld und meinte, was hier aufgebaut ist, das wird natürlich auch in Russland gesehen, ist schon beeindruckend.
Genau, es kam natürlich diese diese Aussage, es wird natürlich auch in Russland gesehen. Danach, also knapp fünf Minuten das Ganze, kommt Christian Sievers dann auf das nächste zu sprechen. Also wir bleiben dann im Thema und wir hören uns jetzt mal diesen gesamten Beitrag an...
.NATO-Gipfel in Washington. Als gezielten Einschüchterungsversuch kurz vor diesem NATO-Treffen werten manche den russischen Großangriff gestern auf verschiedene Städte in der Ukraine. Aber im Grunde ist komplett egal, was das Kalkül dahinter gewesen sein mag. Die Folgen jedenfalls sind klar und schwer zu fassen. Kleine Patienten, die vor den Trümmern ihrer Kinderklinik in Kiew im Freien sitzen und nicht begreifen können, was da passiert ist. Der Ort, an dem sie gesund werden wollten, ist zerstört. Diese Bilder werden nachwirken, rund um die Welt und natürlich in der Ukraine selbst. Dort ist meine Kollegin Alisa Jung.
Solomija Fominuk wartet seit zwei Jahren auf eine neue Niere. Seit Kriegsbeginn wurde sie im Kinderkrankenhaus von Kiew behandelt. Sie war gerade zur Dialyse angeschlossen, als die Stadt mit russischen Raketen beschossen wird.
Ich sah, dass der gesamte Flur, wo Solomija ist, von Trümmern bedeckt ist.
Und dann lag da ein toter Körper eines Arztes. Ich dachte, keines der Kinder hat überlebt. Sie kämpft sich durch das Trümmerfeld und findet ihre Tochter.
Solomija hielt die Decke über ihr mit ihren Armen fest, die noch an Schläuchen angeschlossen waren, durch die das Blut floss.
Sie konnte kaum atmen und dachte, sie erstickt. In seinen Armen trägt ein Arzt Solomija nach draußen. Nun wird sie im Krankenhaus 1 weiter behandelt. Die ersten beiden Stunden waren so traumatisch für die Kinder, dass sie nicht einmal mit ihren Eltern gesprochen haben. Nun arbeiten Psychologen mit den Kindern. Am Angriffsort ist viel Schutt bereits weggeräumt. Wie schon so oft kann man nur staunen, mit welcher Kraft und Geschwindigkeit sie hier weitermachen. Dr. Oleg Godik zeigt uns, wo sie bis zum Moment des Angriffs noch behandelt haben. Eine Kollegin aus meinem Team ist gestorben. Sie hat sich um die Vor- und Nachbereitung von Patienten gekümmert, denen eine Niere transplantiert wird. Ihr Name war Svetlana Lukyanchik. Die Gebäude wird man reparieren können. Dr. Godiks Kollegin werden sie morgen begraben.
Also eine grausame Angelegenheit. Es ging dann noch weiter, also wie die internationalen Reaktionen sind, auch diese Attacke auf das Krankenhaus. Dann ging es noch darum, dass Putin und Modi zusammengekommen sind. Und dann wird noch gerade Folgendes so wegvermeldet, bevor man schon wieder fast bei der EM ist.
Im Gazastreifen breitet sich nach Einschätzung von mehreren UNO-Menschenrechtsexperten eine Hungersnot aus. Die unabhängigen Fachleute verwiesen auf den Tod mehrerer Kinder durch Unterernährung trotz medizinischer Behandlung. Sie warfen Israel eine Hungerkampagne vor. Die israelische Armee griff derweil nach eigenen Angaben erneut Ziele in mehreren Gebieten des Gazastreifens an. Schwerpunkt der Kämpfe ist dem nach Gaza statt. Tausende Bewohner wurden aufgerufen, ihre Häuser zu verlassen.
Ich sehe in den sozialen Medien unglaublich viele schreckliche Bilder und Videos. So nicht von Aktivisten oder so, sondern von Journalisten aus anderer Welt, von Experten. Ich sehe aber im deutschen Diskurs ganz, ganz wenig davon. Man will eigentlich deutlich machen, ja, es gibt zwar da durchaus ein Leiden, aber es muss halt irgendwie so weitergehen. Und wir sehen ja auch bei diesen Argumentationen, die dann zum Beispiel von Baerbock kommen, dass sie ja erst so eine Präambel wieder macht, erst erst zehn Minuten über den 7. Oktober, sprich, bevor sie dann sagt, ja, es gibt schon auch ein Problem mit der medizinischen Versorgung in Gaza, aber mehr kommt nicht. Und das ist wirklich so interessant. Und wenn man es jetzt noch mal so zusammen sieht, also es gibt da Putins Angriff auf dieses Krankenhaus, bei dem auch nicht ganz klar ist, warum haben da die schutzschirme nicht gehalten, warum konnte es nicht abgefangen werden. Man weiß auch, diese Waffen von Russland sind sehr unpräzise. Es gibt auch militärisches Gebäude. Das ist im Prinzip eine ähnliche Argumentation, natürlich wie dann bei Israel, dass man auch sagt, naja, die wollten ja eigentlich nur die Hamas treffen und es sind dann leider auch wieder ein paar Kinder umgekommen. Und wenn wir das jetzt mal so vergleichen, wir wissen, das Elend in Gaza ist groß. Ich will gleich ein paar Texte vorlesen. Wie ist es denn mit der Hilfe, die von Deutschland geleistet werden könnte? wir haben hier in dem Fall von einem Krankenhaus in Kiew sofort von Lauterbach die Zusage bekommen, wir machen hier Plätze frei, wir werden die Kinder versorgen, es soll reibungslos alles laufen und so fort.
Also die Kinder aus Kiew, denen Deutschland helfen konnte, die durften ja sofort kommen.
Die sind ja auch in Deutschland.
Nur so wie wir hier unterstellen müssen, dass dieser Angriff schon relativ gezielt ist. Also so ein Krankenhaus trifft man ja vielleicht mit einer Rakete mal aus Versehen, wie auch immer so ein Krieg dann irgendwie gestaltet wird. Aber das scheint mir ein gezielter Angriff gewesen zu sein. So wie die Angriffe auf die Krankenhäuser in Gaza ja auch gezielte Angriffe der israelischen, also von der Regierung beauftragt, von Militär durchgesetzt, weil es dann immer hieß, da sind irgendwelche Keller drunter oder so. Und dann haben die ehemaligen Premierminister selber noch betont, ja klar sind da Keller drunter, wir haben die Keller doch gebaut. Also es war ja unsere Verantwortung da in Gaza. Falls du darauf anspielst, also ich habe diesen einen Clip, ich hatte ihn auch schon wieder im Fernsehpodcast nicht unterbekommen, aber zu dieser Unterscheidung. Wie gehen wir, unabhängig davon, wer hat da was bewusst zerstört und was ist passiert? Deutschland ist in der Lage zu helfen, indem wir diese Kinder aufnehmen können. Und es gibt hier einen zwei Minuten langen Bericht zum Thema Gaza, Kinder, die betroffen sind von solchen Angriffen, in dem Falle dann der israelischen Regierung. Und wie Deutschland damit umgeht. Und jetzt hört man mal den großen Widersatz zwischen deutsche Bundesregierung und zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement. Und gleich am Anfang wird die Anzahl der Kliniken in Deutschland genannt, die sich hier organisieren. Jeder, der Kliniken kennt, weiß, da irgendwas zu organisieren, ist schwer. Der Alltag drückt alles weg. Hier in Frankfurt, die Uniklinik ist seit Oktober von einem bis heute nicht behobenen Cyberangriff betroffen. Niemand hat Internet. Es finden kaum Operationen statt. Interessiert niemanden. Kein Journalist hat das jemals irgendwie aufgeschrieben. Von daher, liebe Journalisten des Rhein-Main-Gebiets, ruft mal in der Uniklinik Frankfurt an und fragt, was ist gerade ihr Problem? Der Erste, der den Hörer abnimmt, kann euch schon eine Stunde dazu erzählen. Wie die Labore keine Gewebe mehr bekommen, weil ja gar keine Operationen mehr stattfinden. Der ganze Forschungsbetrieb gerade an der Uniklinik Frankfurt vorbeigeht, weil da niemand mal eine E-Mail schreiben kann. Das ist wirklich dramatisch. Man kann eigentlich nichts organisieren. Dennoch dieses große Engagement und dann mit der Antwort im Text, wer es ausgebremst hat.
Etwa 30 Kindern wie Karin sollte geholfen werden. Rund 40 Kliniken in Deutschland waren bereit dazu, auch die Uniklinik Bonn. Die Kliniken haben sich schriftlich bereit erklärt, die gesamten Kosten für solche Behandlungen zu übernehmen. Für Dr. Jan Wienans ist es wichtig, dass die Kinder bei der Reise und der Behandlung nicht alleine sind.
wir wollen die Kinder mit all ihren Leiden, die sie mittragen, nicht dann noch mal zusätzlich traumatisieren, in einem völlig fremden Kulturkreis zu sein. Insofern ist das eine unserer grundsätzlichen Notwendigkeiten, eine Begleitperson zumindest dabei zu haben, die das Kind auch emotional abholt und auch wichtige und zum Teil lebenswichtige Entscheidungen mit trifft.
Doch die Einreise von Begleitpersonen lehnt die Bundesregierung bisher ab. Kinder dürfen nur alleine oder höchstens mit medizinischem Begleitpersonal zur Behandlung nach Deutschland reisen. wir fragen beim Bundesinnenministerium und dem Auswärtigen Amt an. Aus Regierungskreisen heißt es, in den letzten Monaten haben Sicherheitsprüfungen im Gaza-Kontext deutlich gemacht, dass extremistische Einstellungen etwa unter dem Gesichtspunkt der Hamas-Mitgliedschaft oder als deren möglicher Sympathisant vorkommen können. Ein mögliches Risiko stellen dabei auch Personen dar, die zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt einen Anspruch auf Familiennachzug geltend machen könnten. Monatelang hatte die Deutsche Gesellschaft für plastische chirurgie und Hilfsorganisationen wie die Kölner Refugees Foundation versucht, die Kinder nach Deutschland zu bringen, Betten organisiert und spenden. Einige der Kinder, die ursprünglich auf ihrer Liste standen, seien mittlerweile verstorben.
Die Kinder sind ein Jahr alt, die da auf unserer Liste stehen. Und ich finde das ganz, ganz, ganz bitter, dass hier Politik gemacht wird auf dem Rücken dieser Kinder.
Noch bleibt die Hoffnung, dass die Hilfsaktion nicht final gescheitert ist. Denn die Ministerien stimmen sich noch ab, ob doch in Ausnahmefällen eine Einreise von Begleitpersonen realisiert werden könnte. Ich hoffe, dass die deutschen Behörden mich aus dem Gaza-Streifen evakuieren, damit mir eine Beinprothese eingesetzt werden kann für ein normales Leben. Auch das Krankenhaus, in dem Karim behandelt wurde, wurde diese Woche evakuiert. Sicherheit in Gaza gibt es nicht.
Liebe Bundesregierung, also das ist doch absurd. Das kann man niemandem erklären.
Nein, es ist eine Katastrophe. Es ist ein politischer Totalschaden. Und es gibt da keine Proteste interessanterweise in den bürgerlichen Lagern. Das wird wirklich tot geschwiegen. Man kann es nicht anders sagen. Es sind ja hier rar Berichte, die wir hier rausklamüsern. Es gibt in Neuen Deutschland einen Aufsatz dazu, ein Artikel dazu von Matthias Monroy. Der geht genau darauf ein und hat auch die Zahl. Also sieben Kinder ist schon sicher, sind gestorben. Also denen, denen man helfen wollte. Hinzu kommt auch, dass deutsche Asylbehörden schreibt, der entscheiden von den meisten Flüchtlingen aus Palästina derzeit keine Asylanträge. Das heißt, man schiebt das einfach, beschäftigt sich jetzt gar nicht, damit das hat eine Anfrage von Clara Bünger ergeben. Es ist katastrophal und wie katastrophal, empfehle ich, kann man nachlesen in Politico. Und zwar ist dort etwas sehr interessantes erschienen, nämlich der Erfahrungsbericht von zwei Medizinern. Einmal Mark Perlmutter, der ist Orthopäde und handchirurg aus North Carolina und dann Ferozi Sitvar, auch aus den USA, aus Nordkalifornien. Der ist Intensivmediziner und chirurg. Und die beiden kennen sich nicht, haben sich aber verabredet oder über so Vereinigungen, die es da gibt, dass man dort hilft. Der Text beginnt einfach so. In den Vereinigten Staaten würden wir nicht im Traum daran denken, jemanden ohne Einwilligung zu operieren. Schon gar nicht ein unterernährtes und kaum bei Bewusstsein befindliches neunjähriges Mädchen im septischen Schock. Doch als wir Yuri sahen, haben wir genau das getan. wir haben keine Ahnung, wie Yuri in den präoperativen Bereich des Gaza European Hospital gelangt ist. Alles, was wir sehen konnten, war, dass sie einen extrem externen Fixateur, ein Gerüst aus Metallstiften und Stäben an ihren linken Beinen und nekrotischer Haut im Gesicht und an den Armen hatte, die von der Explosion herrührte, die ihren kleinen Körper in Stücke gerissen hatte. Schon die Berührung ihrer Decken löste Schmerzensschreie aus. Sie lag langsam im Sterben, als wir beschlossen, das Risiko einer Narkose einzugehen, ohne genau zu wissen, was wir vorfinden würden. Im Operationssaal untersuchten wir Juri von Kopf bis Fuß. Diesem schönen, sanflütigen kleinen Mädchen fehlten zwei Zentimeter ihres linken Oberschenkels sowie der größte Teil des Muskels und der Haut auf der Rückseite ihres Oberschenkels. Ihr beiden Gesäßbacken waren aufgeschlitzt und so tief in das Fleisch geschnitten, dass die untersten Knochen ihres Beckens freilagen. Als wir mit unseren Händen durch diese Topographie der Grausamkeit strichen, fielen Maden in Klumpen auf den OP-Tisch. Und es sind nur solche Berichte. Ich will das jetzt hier nicht immer weiter vorlesen, aber ich will deutlich machen, es gibt diese Berichte. Es gibt die Aussage von UNICEF, die hier zitiert wird, dass der Gazastreifen für ein Kind der gefährlichste Ort der Welt ist. Hier heißt es, dass sie sich vorher nicht kannten, sich durch diese Ärztevereinigung kennengelernt haben. Sie sind dann in diesem European Hospital am südlichen Rand von Cannes UNICEF. Und ihnen fällt die Überbelegung auf. In einem 220-Betten-Krankenhaus wurden 1500 Menschen aufgenommen. In den Zimmern, die für vier Patienten vorgesehen waren, befanden sich in der Regel zehn bis zwölf. Und die Patienten waren in allen möglichen Räumen untergebracht. Dann auf dem Krankenhausgelände vegetieren, muss man sagen, 15.000 Menschen, die irgendwie Zuflucht suchen, irgendwie hoffen, dass sie vielleicht doch mal ein Schmerzmittel oder irgendetwas bekommen. Weiter heißt es, wir begannen, eine Reihe von Kindern, meist Jugendliche, zu sehen, denen in den Kopf geschossen worden war. Sie starben langsam, um dann von neuen Opfern abgelöst zu werden, denen ebenfalls in den Kopf geschossen wurde und die dann ebenfalls langsam starben. Ihre Familien erzählten uns eine von zwei Geschichten. Die Kinder spielten drinnen, als sie von israelischen Streitkräften erschossen wurden, oder sie spielten auf der Straße, als sie von israelischen Streitkräften erschossen wurden. Dann hier gibt es eine Anfrage an die Armee, ob das sein könne. Und IDF sagt aber nur, dass man versucht, den Schaden für die zivilbevölkerung zu minimieren. Gut, das lassen wir mal so stehen. Mehrere Mitarbeiter sagten uns, also jetzt die Mitarbeiter im Krankenhaus, dass sie einfach nur warten darauf, zu sterben. Und dass sie hoffen, dass Israel das bald hinter sich bringen wird. Also dass sie einfach erlöst werden durch Tod. Soweit ist es da. Es gibt weitere Schreckensberichte, die ich jetzt nicht alle vortragen will. Ich würde noch mal sehr empfehlen, das nachzulesen. Immer wieder also wirklich Wunden, die voll sind von Maden. Hier heißt es, in den nächsten zehn Tagen setzten vier chirurgen, Jury in einer Reihe von Operationen, so gut es ging, wieder zusammen, indem sie ihre Wunden entfernten. Die beiden Enden ihres Oberschenkels zusammenführten. Also es wird dann sehr genau beschrieben, was dann da ist. Es gibt ein Geschwisterpaar, Rafif und Rafik, die haben ihre Mutter verloren und zehn weitere Familienmitgliedern. Die laufen jetzt darum, also 13-jähriges Mädchen. Das hat chronische Geschwüre am jetzt amportierten Unterschenkel. Die Wundversorgung ist schlecht. Ihr Bruder, der 15-jährige Rafik, war so stark unterernährt, dass er kaum sprechen konnte. Also das ist die Realität hier und nochmal auf Zahlen gebracht. Zu Beginn des Krieges gab es in Gaza 3412 Akutkrankenhausbetten. Das sind 1,5 Betten pro 1000 Menschen, verglichen mit 7,3 pro 1000 Menschen in der Ukraine. Also das war schon zu Beginn schlecht. Nach der weitgehenden Zerstörung der Krankenhäuser am Gaza-Streifen gibt es nur noch rund 1.400 Akutkrankenhausbetten für 2,2 Millionen Menschen. 1.400 Betten für 2,2 Millionen Menschen, von denen mehr als 88.000 in den letzten acht Monaten durch militärische Waffen schwer verletzt wurden. Sie reisen nach zwei Wochen wieder ab. Und es haben dann noch einen Patienten, Isra. Da heißt es dann, es ist unmöglich, Gazan Würde zu verlassen, als wir Isras Pfleger an ein Team kanadischer Orthopäden übergeben. Fleht sie ihre amerikanischen Ärzte an, sie nicht im Stich zu lassen. wir betäuben sie mit Ketamin, um einen letzten Verbandswechsel vorzulesen und schlichen uns dann davon.
So, und jetzt gibt es ein Engagement von 40 Unis in Deutschland, um hier einzugreifen und zu helfen. Und die Bundesregierung, Annalena Baerbock, sagt, ne, dieses Risiko gehe ich jetzt nicht ein. Es könnten Terroristen unter den Eltern sein. Das ist einfach absurd. Das ist wirklich absurd, das ist nicht zu verstehen. Und ich will es mal wie folgt sagen, in 70 Jahren wird es auch hier in Deutschland Publizisten geben, die sagen, ich habe damals in Gaza 50 Mitglieder meiner Familie verloren. Ja, so wie Michel Friedmann das heute über den Holocaust sagt.
Ja, das sind so diese Ereignisse.
Klar kann man es immer noch größer denken und so, aber der Dramatik des Einzelfalls und in der Häufung ist das hier wirklich schlimm.
Und das ist dann eine völlig verquere Debatte, wenn man jetzt sagt, was kann man mit was vergleichen und so weiter. Ich finde auch, ehrlich gesagt, diese Debatte mit Genozid oder so, das mag vielleicht auf der völkerrechtlichen Ebene relevant sein. Ich finde, hier muss es nur um eine konkrete Frage gehen, wie kann man das Leiden der Menschen in Gaza verhindern? Oder beziehungsweise, wie kann man es stoppen? Verhindern ist ja jetzt schon gar nicht mehr möglich. Was kann man also tun? Wie kann man helfen? Das ist die humanitäre Angelegenheit, vor der sich niemand drücken darf. Da kann auch niemand sagen, ja, aber da waren pro Hamas Demos an irgendeiner Berliner Uni. Das interessiert in dem Zusammenhang nicht. Das ist ein völlig anderes Tarrah. Das kann man nicht irgendwie zusammenbringen. Das wird aber die ganze Zeit so gemacht. Dass man sagt, oh, jetzt aber nicht so mal. Dann würde ich sagen, nein, das ist ein ganz konkretes Leid. Und da würde ich sagen, weil wir immer hier bei diesen ganzen Militärgipfeln jetzt sagen, und Putin sieht das, das hier sieht die Weltöffentlichkeit. Und die sieht ganz genau, was Deutschland da jetzt nämlich gerade macht. Nichts.
Dieser globale Süden, der uns in Anführungszeichen in der Ukraine so im Stich lässt mit seiner Sympathiebekundungen und was auch immer. Ja, kein Wunder. Also wirklich kein Wunder.
Wo es auch keine Debatte gibt, ist eigentlich noch verrückter. Mittelstreckenraketen. wir bekommen sie mal aufbereitet von Tagesschau 24. Oberst Wolfgang Richter ist zu Gast und schätzt die Lage ein.
Darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit Wolfgang Richter, ehemaliger Oberst.
Ja, also natürlich sehen wir schon seit einiger Zeit eine Entwicklung, die zurückführt in die Konfrontation und dieses Anzeichen dieser bilateralen Vereinbarung, die wir gestern gesehen haben, deutet darauf hin, dass die Konfrontation tiefer wird, dass sie auch länger andauern wird. Trotzdem gibt es einige Unterschiedlichkeiten, wenn man das jetzt vergleicht, etwa mit der Debatte, die während des Nachrüstungsbeschlusses 1979 geführt wurde. wir haben erstens gar keine innenpolitische Debatte gehabt bisher, was natürlich erstaunlich ist. Das ist also ein bis jetzt zumindest eine Exekutiventscheidung. Das zweite ist, es geht nicht um Nuklearwaffen, es geht um konventionelle Waffen und das dritte ist, es geht hier um eine bilaterale Vereinbarung und nicht, bis jetzt zumindest, nicht um eine Bündnisentscheidung und das ist schon erstaunlich.
Eine Exekutiventscheidung halt.
Ja, haben die irgendwie ausgemacht, haben wir alle nichts vermittelt.
Niemand weiß wer, ne?
Noch nicht mal im NATO-Bündnis ist es kommuniziert worden, was die Franzosen nicht sonderlich freut. Mit dieser Bewaffnung ist es zwar aktuell so vorgesehen, dass es nicht mit Atomwaffen geht, aber dann sagen manche, na ja, so grundsätzlich könnte man es schon machen. Also da spricht nichts dagegen. wir hören mal, warum das vielleicht jetzt noch so schnell passiert ist.
Aber es gibt einen Satz in der Vereinbarung, die auch darauf hindeutet, dass es einen anderen Zweck gibt, nämlich die Verpflichtung der USA gegenüber Europa deutlich zu machen. Und das in einer Zeit, in der zumindest die Möglichkeit besteht, dass ein neuer Präsident Trump ans Ruder kommt und möglicherweise dann solche Entscheidungen nicht mehr treffen würde.
Das sind die absurdesten Sachen, die ich höre hier in Europa, vor allem in Deutschland. Ja, das wird so ein bisschen Trump-sicher gemacht, wo man sich denkt, ne, ihr habt die Dimension nicht verstanden. Nichts ist hier Trump-sicher. Als ob das nicht alles, das sind doch alles nur organisatorische Abläufe, da wird halt ein Verfahren geändert.
Naja, die Sache ist, man kann ja sagen, es ist insofern Trump-sicher, wenn dies erstmal stationiert ist.
Nichts ist Trump-sicher.
Naja, gut, Trump kann, es ist bis 26, also bis dahin kann natürlich, wenn Trump dann Präsident wäre, das wieder zurückdrehen.
Erstens das, wenn er es geliefert, wenn, und selbst wenn sie schon geliefert wären, wenn er mit Putin Vereinbarungen trifft über was auch immer, dann sind die Raketen dann nicht mehr da. Also es ist einfach, wie auch immer. Nichts ist Trump-sicher.
Das ist eine interessante Sache, dass du jetzt schon die Raketen, wir kommen nämlich darauf gleich, wir hören noch gleich Norbert Walter-Borjans dazu. Nochmal Richter, was bedeutet das denn eigentlich, wenn jetzt hier diese US-Raketen stationiert sind?
Na ja, ich erwarte schon, dass es hier noch einmal Rückfragen gibt, dass es möglicherweise eine größere parlamentarische Diskussion zu der Frage gibt. Denn es gibt ja strategische Konsequenzen, die sich daraus ergeben. Das erste ist einmal, dass damit Waffen in Deutschland stationiert werden. Zum ersten Mal, muss ich sagen, seit 1992, mit denen man tief in das russische Territorium hineinwirken kann. Man kann sehr präzise, zwar nicht nukleare, aber heute eben sehr präzise, auch strategische Ziele in Russland treffen. Die Reichweite reicht bis über Moskau hinaus. Das hat natürlich einen Einfluss auf die Frage des strategischen Gleichgewichtes zwischen den USA und Russland. So wird es Russland sehen. Deswegen wird Russland wahrscheinlich auch Gegenmaßnahmen ergreifen.
Also der Sweat-Rusten läuft, es nimmt an Fahrt auf. Und wir wissen von dir, Stefan, dass du immer wieder darauf verwiesen hast, die Atombombe wird sie dann geworfen, könnte Stuttgart treffen.
Ja.
Vielleicht ist es nicht Stuttgart, aber relativ nah dran.
Erklären Sie uns vielleicht mal ganz nüchtern, welches Risiko geht Deutschland konkret mit dieser Verhandlungsposition oder dieser Stationierung der Waffen ein?
Ja, das erste Risiko ist rein militärisch. Wenn es zu einem Konflikt mit Russland kommt, wird man natürlich versuchen, aus russischer Sicht diese Waffen zunächst mal als Ziele auszuschalten. Nun sind es bewegliche Waffen, die wahrscheinlich in einem Konfliktfall oder noch im Vorfeld dann eben auch zerstreut werden. Also man versucht sie dann auch zu tarnen, zu decken oder irgendwo beweglich zu positionieren, sodass sie nicht leicht getroffen werden. Gleichwohl, es gibt ja Kommandobehörden, die sogenannte Multidomain Task Force hat ihren Sitz bereits in Wiesbaden. Das ist natürlich dann ein erstrangiges Ziel.
Also wissen, dass die Wiesbadener.
Ja, Wiesbaden ist uncool, das ist nämlich relativ nah hier.
Ja, also muss man den Wiesbadener sagen, ihr seid übrigens jetzt erstrangiges Ziel. Es gibt keine gesellschaftliche Debatte, es gibt nichts im Bundestag dazu.
wir wissen auch nicht, wer nach Putin regiert oder wie das da weitergeht, wer da Entscheidungen trifft.
Ja, können wir auch noch überreden, wer da regieren könnte. Also das ist wirklich absurd, dass man das selbst mal so steht.
Die Vorherscheinung dazu ist von Farin Urlaub, von den Ärzten, der ja Farin Urlaub heißt, weil er die ganze Zeit in der Welt unterwegs ist. Und der auf die Frage, ja, und hast du denn eine Pistole dabei? Und er so, nein, Stahl zieht Stahl an. So lange ich keine habe, haben die anderen auch keine.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und es ist auch strategisch vielleicht nicht besonders klug.
Das andere ist, dass man hier eingreift in die strategische Balance. Und das wird natürlich auch die Gespräche, die ja zwischen den USA und Russland immer noch geführt werden, wie das strategische Gleichgewicht aufrechterhalten werden kann, beeinflussen. Und ich befürchte sehr negativ beeinflussen. Und das dritte ist, dass alle Gespräche, die bisher noch von einem Moratorium für die Stationierung von Mittelstreckenwaffen ausgingen, damit auch tot sind. Das heißt, das ist wirklich der letzte Sargnagel auf den ANF-Vertrag.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch an alle Beteiligten. Solche Turbulenzen sind genau das Richtige.
Das braucht man.
Wenn wir nicht wissen, wer wo wann wie regiert.
Ja, ja. Also es gibt ja solche Szenarien. Das wurde ja auch von, das war Christopher McCallion und Benjamin H. Freedman auch in Politico erschienen, wo sie mal sagen, wo eigentlich eine Gefahr steht. Also mit, wenn Putin wirklich schwankt, wenn da jemand ein neuer Machthaber kommt, dann könnte das jemand sein, der so irre ist, wie die und die da werden zum Beispiel genannt. Und dann ist es wirklich, dann brauchen wir nicht mehr über, naja, werden die uns nuklear weiter erpressen oder so, sondern da wird man auch einfach mal gucken, wenn es knallt. Also es ist Wahnsinn, dass man einfach diesen Schritt geht. wir keine große Debatte haben, sondern nur jetzt irgendwie so Jusus bei Twitter einem noch mal erklären, dass nun mal Russland die Bedrohung ist. Und dann denke ich, ja danke, das habe ich jetzt inzwischen verstanden. Nur ist das eine kluge Strategie und Norbert Walter-Beuerns, der dagegen ist, war im Deutschlandfunk zu Gast und hat auf eigentlich etwas sehr Gutes hingewiesen, nämlich darauf.
Erstmal, weil es dieses Junktim der Androhung im Falle des Nichtverhandelns gar nicht gibt, sondern es gibt nur die Feststellung, ab 2026 wird nachgerüstet und Verhandeln ist eigentlich im Moment aussichtslos. Das ist ein Unterschied.
Denn das hätte man ja mit in die Waagschale werfen können. Also man kann ja gut hin sagen, wir würden durchaus mal darüber nachdenken, es sei denn, du setzt dich jetzt mal mit Zelensky ins Benehmen und ja, du gehst mal von deinen Maximalforderungen ab. Denn sonst könnten wir auch mal US-Raketen stationieren. Das heißt, man könnte ja wirklich damit arbeiten.
Im besten Falle wird das gerade in die Waagschale reingelegt, damit man es dann nach wieder rausnehmen kann, wenn man ein Gespräch führt. Nur, wie er jetzt darauf hinweist, es werden gar keine Gespräche führen. Nicht nur reden wir nicht mit dem Feind, sondern wir reden auch nicht mit uns. Hier wird auch niemand Bescheid sagen.
Also mit Macron wurde ja auch darüber nicht geredet. Was ja auch wieder interessant ist.
Diese Bundesregierung ist, was das angeht, sowohl bis Thores, wir haben ja diese Clips gehört, ja, Trump, der ist ja noch nicht mal Kandidat und so, das wird schon. So und jetzt hier mit Macron darüber reden, keine Ahnung, ne, können wir später.
Das ist nicht gut.
Und wir müssen auch noch mal geografisch darüber nachdenken. Ja, sagen ja viele, aber Russland hat ja auch solche Raketen stationiert. Ja, aber wo? wir haben jetzt eben gehört, Wiesbaden, relativ dicht bevölkert. Stephanie an Frankfurt überlegt auch schon, wie das so weitergeht.
Wie ist das zu nah?
In Russland sind die ja woanders.
Vielleicht senkt das die Mietpreise in Wiesbaden.
Möglich.
Und der zweite Punkt, der eben im Kalten Krieg auch nicht funktioniert hat und Anfang der 80er Jahre viele Menschen auf die Straße getrieben hat, ist, dass Abschreckung zwischen den beiden damaligen Supermächten, solange sie damit verbunden war, dass jeder rechnen musste, selbst Ziel zu werden, vielleicht funktioniert hat, aber dass damals der Schritt gegangen wurde, dass die Interessen der USA ein Stück auf das Schlachtfeld Europa ausgelagert werden und dass jetzt von Russland mit der Einbeziehung dieses extraterritorialen Gebietskalinen gerade genauso gehandhabt wird. Das heißt, wir haben eine Minderung in dieser abschreckungswirkung, weil in wirklichkeit diejenigen, die da im Streit miteinander liegen, gar nicht die Ziele sind eines möglichen Entgleisens.
Und das bedeutet auch, dieses Kaliningrad ist über 1000 Kilometer von Moskau entfernt. Das heißt, da etwas auszuschalten, dünn besiedelt, ist das eine. Also das Tropotenzial funktioniert gar nicht. Also es ist nicht symmetrisch. Man kann nicht sagen, die stehen sich jetzt so genau gegenüber, sondern da ist einmal das dicht bevölkerte Wiesbaden und Deutschland generell. Ja, und dann ist da irgendwo in Russland noch mal so extra territorial, hat der die Raketen stationiert. Das sind zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe.
So wie ich ihn jetzt verstanden habe, ist sein Szenario irgendwann, sagen wir mal Trump regiert 2027, kriegt so einen Anruf, macht das und das und wir machen Wiesbaden platt. Und er fragt, was? Wiesbaden kenne ich nicht, keine Ahnung, ciao. Punktszenario ist leider nicht gegeben, weil sich der amerikanische Präsident nicht für Wiesbaden interessiert. Die Idee, da Waffen zu installieren, war ein Fehler.
wir haben ja beide den Oppenheimer-Filmen gesehen. Du weißt doch, dass da darüber gesprochen wird, wo kann man die Atombomben abwerfen? Und dann ist das, glaube ich, der Verteidigungsminister oder sogar der Präsident. Also es geht um die Frage, ob man es in Tokio nehmen sollte.
Nee, da habe ich eine Hochzeitsreise gemacht. Das war so schön.
Und das ist das Argument dafür, dass man die nicht auf Tokio abwirft, sagt man. Da war es immer schön. Und Trump war vielleicht nicht in Wiesbaden. Sonst wäre ich echt auf Kyoto war es, glaube ich.
Das wäre auf Kyoto gefallen.
Auf Kyoto, ja. Ich habe jetzt, wo ja ein bisschen Podcast-Pause ist, bei vielen, gedacht, ich würde mal in andere Sachen rein. Paul Ronzheimer.
Ist dir langweilig. Hast du zu wenig Podcasts gerade? Fehlen dir Podcasts?
Nein, ein bisschen. Also Paul Ronzheimer, Bildzeitung. Also wir haben uns ja auch schon mehrmals geäußert, ich will jetzt auch nicht hier eine Lanze fehlenbrechen. Ich will aber sagen, dass nachdem wir mal dieses Talkshow-Debakel vorgeführt haben, wie Fragen gestellt werden und der ganze Umgang mit den Gästen ist, würde ich sagen, dass man bei Paul Ronzheimer natürlich immer die Stoßrichtung weiß. Ja, es ist Springer und wir wissen auch, Paul Ronzheimer ist für Waffentieferungen und und und und und und und. Aber Paul Ronzheimer ist auch Erkenntnis interessiert. Das ist ja etwas...
Und er reist.
Ja, und er kennt Leute.
Er sitzt nicht nur an seinem Schreibtisch.
Und ich habe es einfach mal so einige Folgen runter gelernt und dann war dort ein Wall Street Journalist zu Gast. Wall Street Journalist zu Gast, nämlich Bojan Panczewski. Ronzheimer und er kennen sich seit über zehn Jahren, haben sich wo kennengelernt? Natürlich in der Ukraine. Sind also ganz tief beide in der Materie drin. Und ich dachte, jetzt kommt bestimmt so ein übliches Gespräch. Wann kommen denn die Taurus-Lieferungen oder so? Natürlich das komplette Gegenteil passiert dann. Und deswegen habe ich diese Clips jetzt mal mitgebrannt. Also aufhorchen.
Wenn du mit den Kontakten, die du auch gesammelt hast, in der Ukraine sprichst, was ist dein Eindruck? Was ist der ukrainische Plan momentan? Gibt es überhaupt einen Plan?
Das ist natürlich schwierig. Die Bereitschaft bei der Bevölkerung, Verhandlungen zu akzeptieren, war relativ niedrig eine sehr, sehr lange Zeit. Jetzt anscheinend ändert sich das. Es gibt eine unveröffentliche Studie, die nach der so fast 60 Prozent der Befragten Verhandlungen akzeptieren würden.
Jetzt sagen aber viele, Selensky will halt nicht.
Ukraine, der ukrainischen Führung. Ich glaube, denen ist es ganz klar bewusst, dass sie bald verhandeln werden müssen oder zumindest anfangen. Der Selensky hat selber gesagt, neulich in einem Interview mit Bloomberg, dass man jetzt direkt mit den Russen verhandeln könnte.
Und wir hören.
Ich denke mir gerade vor, wie wir in Deutschland so eine Diskussion hätten, wenn nach zweieinhalb Jahren Krieg es hieße, die Lausitz muss jetzt an Polen, sonst haben wir hier nie wieder Frieden. Wie viele Leute in Baden-Württemberg, NRW und Niedersachsen würden sagen, Lausitz, ich dachte, es ist Polen. Ist doch egal. Klar wollen wir verhandeln. Was heißt verhandeln?
wir kapitulieren.
Lausitz, weg damit. Also diese Ost-Ukraine ist, wird, so wie ich das verstanden habe, auch so ein bisschen unter diesem, wir haben ja der Osten. Es läuft so unter dem Label Osten.
Natürlich, natürlich. Und es ist interessant, dass hier unterhaltsicher Leute...
Das ist bestimmt sehr fiese Kommentare. Ich sitze hier so lässig mit verschränkten Armen und sage das so.
Die Lausitz.
Aber die Lausitzer.
Ja, also ich mache mir das hier nicht so eigentlich. Ich will das deutlich unterstreichen. Ich trete hier auch hin und wieder noch...
Das ist ja nicht nur Szenario Planung. Ich habe nur für den Fall das und so weiter. Würden wir akzeptieren, den Einbruchungsbefehl um die Lausitz zu verteidigen?
Also nein, ich würde die Lausitz auch nicht mit Leib und Leben verteidigen, aber auch Koblenz nicht. Aber du bist natürlich hier immer auf deinem Trip. Ich sitze in meinem Frankfurt. Einmal im Jahr fahre ich noch nach Bielefeld rüber, besuche...
Wiesbaden wäre schon schlecht.
Die Lehmann, die Luhmann, Apologeten und das war es dann. Naja, ich bin ja ein bisschen mehr auch in Deutschland in der Breite unterwegs. wir hören jetzt noch mal, wie ist das mit Zelensky? Also ich finde das so erstaunlich, wenn wir jetzt zwei Leute, denen man nicht in irgendeiner Weise unterstellen kann, dass die kremmelnah sind oder so. Das ist ja hier immer der erste Verdacht, der kommt, wenn jemand solche Sätze von sich gibt. wir hören mal weiter.
Da ging es um den Schweizer Gipfel, wo ja keine russischen Vertreter dabei waren. Und Silensky wurde in diesem Interview danach gefragt. Und er hat, glaube ich, angedeutet, dass bei einem weiteren Format dann russische Vertreter dabei sein können.
Eben. Und so ein weiterer Format soll anscheinend in Saudi-Arabien stattfinden. Und so wie ich höre, der Silensky hat die Saudis gebeten, das zu organisieren und eventuell auch russische Vertreter dahin einzuladen.
Silensky bittet die Saudis, das mal zu organisieren, dass dann auch Russland daran teilnimmt. Das heißt, das geht nicht über eine Demokratie, die das jetzt organisiert. Du weißt, wenn Deutschland das jetzt organisieren würde, würde Baerbock sagen, man kann mit einem Kriegsverbrecher wie Putin nicht verhandeln, aus. Und deswegen machen wir einfach noch mal so eine große Show. Das heißt, Silensky wendet sich jetzt bewusst nicht an die Demokraten der westlichen Welt. wir wenden das nachher noch steigern, aber wir behalten das schon mal im Hinterkopf. wir reden ja morgen über ein Buch von Ingolf Fuhr Blüthorn, Unhaltbarkeit. Wie unhaltbar ist denn eigentlich die Demokratie? Und wir sehen jetzt ja gerade, dass ganz viel gemacht wird, wo die Demokratien zwar irgendwelche Werte artikulieren, ihnen dann oft selbst gar nicht treu bleiben. In Bezug auf Gaza ist das deutlich geworden. Aber wir sehen auch, Ich glaube auch, dass einfach die Demokratie da gar nicht gefragt wird, sondern man fragt die Saudis. Nun, wie geht es dann gerade an der Front voran?
Also es ist nicht so, dass die Ukraine momentan an der Front selbst Fortschritte machen würden. Also sie verlieren zwar nicht Massivgebiete, aber sie verlieren ja Dörfer.
Stück für Stück verlieren sie natürlich, aber diese Tendenz gibt es schon seit über einem Jahr. Das Problem ist, dass es nicht so richtig berichtet worden in der westlichen Presse, weil man halt, man wünscht sich vielleicht was anderes.
Erstaunlich, ne? Es wird jetzt einfach mal gesagt, ja, da wurde gar nicht so gerne drüber berichtet. Man hat sich was anderes gewünscht.
Ehrlicherweise gibt es ja gerade so gar keinen Diskurs, oder?
Irgendwo.
Es scheint so ein...
Nee, nur noch so abstrakt, aber gar nicht mehr. Also Frontverläufe, ja, das wird hin und wieder noch ausgeführt.
Mit dem Podcast, mit dem General, aber ansonsten...
Hin und wieder ist Obers Reisner irgendwo eingeladen.
Zum Beispiel in diesem MDR-Podcast.
Ja, und der schildert das ja dann auch sehr klar, wie es verläuft. Ja, und es wird nicht besser.
Die Analyse ist ja überall, dass es nur noch schlimmer werden könnte. Ich habe noch so keinen richtigen... Ich habe mit vielen Militäroffizieren hier gesprochen und auch aber im Westen, ich war in Washington neulich. Ich habe ja mit keinen so richtig gesprochen, der oder die meinte, dass die Ukraine wieder eine Chance hätten, im großen Stil Territorium zu eroben. Das glaubt kaum ein Mensch mehr.
Und das ist doch eine ungeheure Aussage, die sich auch damit deckt, was auch widerspringer in der Welt zu lesen war. Christoph B. Schilds hat einen Artikel verfasst, da heißt es, Militärs und Diplomaten von EU und NATO beobachten die Entwicklung auf dem Kriegsschauplatz in der Ukraine schon seit Monaten mit zunehmender Sorge. Öffentlich wird darüber nicht gesprochen. Um die Unterstützung in der Bevölkerung des Westens nicht zu schwächen und die ukrainischen Soldaten in ihrem Verteidigungskampf gegen Russland nicht zu demotivieren. Das heißt, man macht sich Illusionen und macht denen etwas vor. Hier, Welt hat zahlreiche Gespräche über die weitere Entwicklung in der Ukraine geführt. Die Gesprächspartner wollten namentlich nicht genannt werden. Nicht ein einziger Diplomat oder Militärvertreter erwartet, dass die Ukraine ihr selbst gestecktes Ziel erreichen wird, die seit 2014 durch Russland völkerrechtswidrig annektierte Halbinsel Krim zurückzuerobern. Biden und Scholz haben Angst vor einer Eskalation. Das wird auch nochmal von diesen Leuten bestätigt. Man hat vor nuklearen Schlägen Angst, und zwar in zweifacher Hinsicht. Einmal Putin könnte taktische Atomwaffen einsetzen. Das wäre ein Horrorszenario.
Oder Atomwaffen taktisch einsetzen.
Ja.
Zweites Szenario, noch schlimmer. Die russische Föderation könnte zerfallen. Dann steht hier 6.000 russische Atomspreinköpfe, geraten damit in die Hände von Terroristen und blutrünstigen Diktatoren, wie dem Tschechenen-Anführer Ramsan kadirov. Da fährt man quasi noch mehr Angst, dass so etwas passieren könnte. Und ich denke, zu Recht. Und deswegen, weil ich ebenso sagte, vielleicht werden wir beide noch mal vermissen oder so. wir wissen noch nicht, wie Kamala Harris so drauf ist. Ich finde diese Geprächtlichkeit, die aber auch mit einer Besonnenheit einhergeht von beiden, ganz gut und hat ja auch funktioniert mit Scholz zusammen. wir hören jetzt von Schöfsky auch zu diesem Krankenhaus, das angegriffen wurde. Nur um das kurz zu machen, das habe ich jetzt nicht alles geklippt. Seine These ist, dass die Waffen nicht besonders präzise sind der Russen. Das durchaus sein könnte, dass sie militärisches Gebäude treffen wollten. Aber generell sei es natürlich so, dass Putin auf diese Weise auch die Zivilbevölkerung tyrannisiert. Und Vance hat folgende Überlegungen dazu.
Er sendet auch keine Zeichen, dass er irgendwie verhandeln will. Denn ich meine, wir haben jetzt erlebt, dieser Angriff auf das Kinderkrankenhaus, gewollt oder ungewollt. Aber dieser Einsatz, der sagt ja auch etwas aus. Also wenn jetzt Putin tatsächlich gedacht hätte, nach dem Gespräch mit Orbán, Mensch, ja irgendwie, ich will diesen Krieg auch beenden, dann wäre das sicherlich nicht das Zeichen gewesen, das man sendet, oder?
Oder doch. Also wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, glaube ich schon, dass er Angst und Schrecken verbreiten will, damit die Bevölkerung halt irgendwie mal einen politischen Druck ausübt auf die Führung, damit die überhaupt verhandeln wollen. Weil lange Zeit war ja die Sache, dass die Ukrainer und vor allem der Präsident nicht verhandeln wollten.
Ja, es geht ein bisschen so in diese Richtung in die USAs, dass sie sagen, ja, jetzt also bevor hier noch weiter.
Laos ist okay, aber nicht Wiesbaden.
Ja, ganz genau. Also das ist diese Überlegung hier. Er spricht auch von den Geheimdiensten. Es ist wirklich interessant, weil man hier zwei Journalisten hat, die ja richtig tief drin sind. Das ist ja nicht so wie bei, bei manchen haben wir mal so den Eindruck, die fahren schon mal nach Kiev, interviewen die Baerbock oder den Steinmeier und fahren wieder zurück und sagen dann, ich habe die Ukraine gesehen. Aber hier sind ja Leute wirklich ganz, ganz dicht dran.
Ich wollte auch sagen, ich höre ja was anderes. Also ich habe schon gehört in Washington, dass über gewissen geheimdienstlichen Kanälen, zum Beispiel, und das sind die üblichen Kanälen, mit denen man kommuniziert mit den Russen heutzutage, dass die schon Signale abgesendet haben und vermehrt und regelmäßig, dass sie doch auch verhandeln wollen.
Und wir erinnern uns, das ist jetzt lange, lange her, ich glaube, über anderthalb Jahre her, haben wir über Mark Milley gesprochen. Ich glaube, das war dann Herbst 2022.
wir haben ja häufiger über ihn gesprochen.
Also, wenn wir ausführlich mal Clips, wo er auf so einem Dinner eigentlich zu Gast war und da so ein längeres Interview gab, dass jetzt eigentlich das Fenster für Verhandlungen wäre. Und das hat man...
Ah ja, also ich rekapituliere, was ich noch weiß. Er hatte damals darüber gesprochen, dass es diese alten und die neuen Kriege gibt. Und wir haben immer die Idee, dass es jetzt neue Kriege sind. Aber nein, es ist alles wie Vardong oder so. Wenn der Krieg einmal läuft, liegt man in seinem Schützengraben und verteidige ich den Kameraden.
Und jetzt hören wir Bojan Paschewski.
Am Anfang hatten sie natürlich eine relativ positive Entwicklung an der Front, am Schlachtfeld. Und dann gab es diese, die haben kulminiert, sozusagen mit der Zurückeroberung, mit der Befreiung von Kherson, die Stadt im Süden. Und da, wenn du dich erinnerst, der damalige Oberbefehlshaber der Vereinigten Staaten, General Mark Milley, hat öffentlich gesagt, jetzt ist die Zeit zu verhandeln, weil besser wird es nicht mehr. Das ist halt ihr Höhepunkt. Und es stellt sich jetzt heraus, fast zwei Jahre später, dass er Recht hatte. Das war der Höhepunkt. Und seitdem so ist es halt mal.
Ja, und zwei Jahre ist weiter gestorben worden auf beiden Seiten. Und eigentlich hätte man auf Milley hören sollen. Wie ist das denn jetzt mit der NATO? Können wir die erweitern für die Ukraine? Mac Callion und Friedman haben in Politico gesagt, dass man der Ukraine falsche Hoffnung macht, dass man so tut, als würde man die Ukraine aufnehmen. Sie sagen ganz gern, das wird niemals passieren. Sie sehen auch eine große Gefahr der Eskalation jetzt, gerade weil es so vertrakt alles ist. Sie schreiben, in den letzten Wochen hat die Ukraine bereits ihre eigenen einheimischen Fähigkeiten eingesetzt, um russische Radarstationen zu treffen, die im Falle eines amerikanischen Atomenangriffs eine Frühwarnung geben sollen. Und im vergangenen Monat schlug die Submunition einer von den USA gelieferten Rakete, die von ukrainischen Streitkräften abgefeuert wurde, auf zivile Strandbesucher in Sevastopol auf der Krim ein, nachdem sie wahrscheinlich von der russischen Luftabwehr abgefangen worden war. Diese Ereignisse geben Anlass zu großer Besorgnis, ein Angriff auf die Frühwarnsysteme untergräbt, das Vertrauen Russlands in seine Fähigkeit im Falle eines nuklearen Erstschlags der USA zu reagieren und erhöht damit das Risiko eines russischen Nuklearschlags. Wahrscheinlicher ist jedoch, dass Moskau auf die Angriffe auf seinem Boden, bei denen von den USA bereitgestellte Waffen zum Einsatz kommen, mit der Suche nach Möglichkeiten reagieren wird, die USA oder ihre Helfer direkt anzugreifen. Und sie sagen auch, Analysten, die sich als Befürworter der Ukraine verstehen, betonen oft, dass der Westen einer nuklearen Erpressung nicht nachgeben dürfe, weil eine Eskalation zu einem Atomkrieg unwahrscheinlich sei. Die korrekte Bezeichnung für nukleare Erpressung lautet jedoch nukleare Abschreckung. Und dazu muss man nicht sicher sein, dass es zu einer Katastrophe kommt, sondern nur befürchten, dass sie eintreten könnte. Diese Kommentatoren scheinen zu glauben, dass unsere Fähigkeit rostland abzuschrecken, uns von der Last befreit, von ihnen abgeschreckt zu werden. Also so funktioniert es natürlich.
Ich frage mich auch, wenn jetzt tatsächlich irgendwo mal so eine Atombombe explodiert, ob dann einfach nur 9 Monate ins Land gehen und dann irgendwer kommentiert, naja, so schlimm war es jetzt auch nicht. Der Radius ist alles 50 Kilometer, aber nicht 500, irgendwie so. Das ist wirklich brenzlig.
Na ja, wir haben jetzt ja eben wirklich sehr anschaulich beschrieben, wie man einfach bei Gaza wegguckt und sagt, das muss aber jetzt sein, wegen des 7. Oktober. Und dann kann natürlich auch sein, dass man sagt, ja, aber das ist natürlich schade um das Städtchen da, das da getroffen wurde. Und von dort sollte man auch lieber kein Gemüse importieren.
Solange wir diese Stadt dann zum allerersten Mal hören, dass sie existiert hat.
Ja. Ja, ja. Also Wiesbaden soll es dann nicht sein. Ja, ich denke, das wäre schlecht. Ich gehe da auch zu gerne in die Oper. Wie sieht er das jetzt mit der NATO?
Der NATO-Gipfel ist ja auch kein Denk für die Ukraine, weil die Ukraine kommt nicht in die Allianz, die wird nicht so richtig eingeladen. Der Biden hat selber gesagt, neulich vor einem Monat oder zwei Monaten, dass er Ukraine in NATO nicht haben will. Der hat das irgendwie auch komisch formuliert. Der meinte, keine NATOisierung von Ukraine werde er je akzeptieren. Im Grunde genommen, das sagt der Trump auch. Also die Aussichten sind da klar. wir wissen ja auch, wie der Bundeskanzler denkt. Der will ja Ukraine auch nicht in die Allianz als Mitglied.
Ja, und der Westen hat eigentlich keinen Plan, meint er.
Wie gesagt, die haben keinen Plan. Die haben negative Aussagen von der Zukunft. Also die beiden Regierungen und die westlichen Regierungen insgesamt sagen, wir werden nicht zulassen, dass Putin gewinnt. wir werden so lange Ukraine unterstützen, wie es nötig. wir werden halt Ukraine nicht drängen, zu verhandeln. Aber wenn sie zur Verhandlung bereit sind, dann gut ist.
Ohje, das klingt aber wirklich.
Und wie sieht es mit Trump aus?
Alleine durch die Tatsache, dass das eine neue Regierung sein würde, wenn sie dann mal die Wahl gewinnen, haben sie ein kleines Bonus, dass die vielleicht mehr exekutive Macht haben. Und es ist fast kaum vorzustellen, dass eine amerikanische Regierung weniger exekutive Macht haben könnte, als die beiden Regierungen momentan. Also insofern, vielleicht kann man nur erhoffen, dass in der Zukunft ein neuer D-Inhalt hineinkommen in diesem System von westlicher Unterstützung der Ukraine.
Ich habe es ja schon ein paar Mal beschrieben, das Szenario. Trump, die haben sich so lustig gemacht darüber, wie Biden aus Afghanistan abgezogen ist. Dass Trump genau einen Plan hat, wenn ich hier gewählt werde, werde ich meinen Wählern, die absolut nirgendwo Kriege wollen, anbieten, dass es eine Feierstunde gibt. Ich und Putin, Handschlag, Ausverkauf von allem. Hauptsache Weltfrieden. Er wird sich als den großen Weltfrieden-Präsident erinnern.
Aber das Ausverkauf ist ja ein Business, man. wir müssen schon verstehen, dass Trump...
Die werden Putin schon noch ausquetschen und so.
Ja, ja. Also Trump hat keine NATO-Liebe vielleicht oder keine besondere Liebe zur Deutschland. Aber er weiß ja auch schon, dass die NATO durchaus den USA hilft. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die NATO einfach nur ein Gottesgeschenk ist an die Europäer, sondern dieses Bündnis hat ja seinen Sinn für die Amerikaner auch.
Aber es ist für die Europäer noch viel alternativloser als für die, für die es eigentlich gestaltet wurde. Amerika. In der Hinsicht würde es so eine Friss oder Stöp an uns sagen sein.
Ich glaube, dass man, Ronzheimer argumentiert in eine ähnliche Richtung und fragt das aber auch nach.
Du teilst nicht die Sorge, die ja viele haben momentan, wenn sie auf den Wahlkampf schauen und wenn sie in der Ukraine sind oder auch Leute, die mit der Ukraine zu tun haben, dass sie sagen, dass Trump einfach eiskalt die Ukraine verkaufen könnte und zur Silenz gesagt hat, du musst das jetzt akzeptieren mit diesen vier Regionen und hier ist die Grenze. Und entweder machst du das, dann unterstützen wir dich weiter.
Also du, meine Meinung ist irrelevant, aber ich glaube nicht mal, dass Zelensky das glaubt. Im Gegenteil, ich glaube, Zelensky glaubt langsam, dass Trump bessere Karten hätten. Das höre ich eben hier in Kiew. Das kam Trump viel besser.
Was hörst du da?
Ich höre schon, dass in der obersten Etage der Regierung beim Zelensky und seinem Berater langsam sich die Meinung durchsetzt, dass Trump die besseren Karten haben könnte.
Obama war die Ukraine ziemlich egal.
Was ist das für eine komische Hoffnung?
An Trump.
Warum?
Man muss ja halt nicht vergessen, dass Trump ja der allererste amerikanische Präsident, der Waffen in die Ukraine geschickt hat. Ich glaube, das war im Jahre 2019, wenn ich mich nicht irre. Das hat der Obama nicht gemacht und nicht machen wollen. Obama hat gesagt, Ukraine ist nicht wichtig für die nationale Sicherheit Amerikas. Das hat er öffentlich gesagt. Trump hat anders agiert. Also, dem ist vieles zuzutrauen, ja. Ein schlechter Deal ist, wenn er dem Putin sagen würde, du kannst die Ukraine umsonst haben. Das ist, was die meisten Menschen befürchten. Aber das wäre nicht so, in der Historie von Trump als Politiker, wäre das nicht unbedingt, was er will. Oder? Ich meine, der will ja keine schlechten Deals machen. Der redet ja die ganze Zeit, dass er gute Deals machen will.
Also er wird gute Deals machen, dass er 2019 als erster amerikanische Präsident Waffen geliefert hat. Also ich weiß noch sehr genau, wie 2016 es damals hieß, Obama hat noch schnell beauftragt und Clinton wird das dann vollziehen. 8000 Tonnen Militärmaterial ist verpackt und steht bereit verschifft zu werden. Dann hat Trump gewonnen. Diese Pläne sind mit dem Personal einfach sozusagen in Luft aufgelöst worden. 2019, ja der Kongress hat der Ukraine 400 Millionen zugestanden. Trump sagte, hier Zelensky, mach aber für mich diese und jene Schoße. Sag bei CNN das jetzt hier und so weiter. Und es hat ihm ein Amtsenthebungsverfahren eingebracht, dass er Zelensky dann noch erpresst hat und so. Also, dass Trump da irgendwie auf der ukrainischen Seite steht und ihn das irgendwie interessiert, nee.
Das ist, also.
Das glaube ich auch nicht, dass er eigentlich ein Ukraine-Fan ist, das ist uns nur noch nicht gesagt.
Trump wird es vor allem um dieses Signal an seine Wähler gehen, ich habe für Weltfrieden gesorgt.
Möglicherweise bedeutet das aber für die Europäer, dass er denen sagt, ihr kümmert euch darum.
Genau, wenn ihr weiter kämpfen wollt, macht das. Ich bin der Präsident des Weltfriedens. Das wird die Ansage sein. Und dann kann man ja mal gucken, wie gut Pistorius und Macron sich verständigt haben darauf, wie das jetzt weitergeht in der Ukraine. Oder ob man das dann einfach akzeptiert.
Manzie werden es mitbekommen haben, Viktor Orbán, der...
Lassen wir es kurz nur in einem Platz. Als wir diesen Podcast begonnen haben, Januar 2020, wurde Ursula von der Leyengrad gewählt. Sie war damit neue EU-Kommissionspräsidentin, hatte große Vorschläge und so weiter und so fort. Damals war es aber schon ziemlich knapp. In diesem ganzen Wahlkampfstress, den wir jetzt hatten, dieses ganze politische Drama, ist sie mit mehr Stimmen aus dem Parlament als damals jetzt gewählt worden. Also das Drama war relativ klein und ich würde sagen, ja man hat sich dann doch mal so die Sachlage angeschaut und gefragt, wollen wir jetzt echt einen neuen Kandidaturprozess starten oder nicht? Also hat man sie gewählt, aber Drama gibt es trotzdem, denn die erste Amtshandlung von Ursula von der Leyen als jetzt neue Kommissionspräsidentin war ein Boykott gegen Ungarn, die gerade die Ratspräsidentschaft haben, wegen diesen Reisen. Das ist wirklich bescheuert.
wir werden ja mit Blütern darüber sprechen, wie weit die Demokratie handlungsfähig ist. Und wir können uns jetzt alle mal schön ausmalen, wie hätten wir es dann gerne auf der Welt und wie hätten wir es gerne in Bezug auf den Ukraine-Krieg.
Welchen EU-Kommissionspräsidenten hätten wir denn gerne, wenn wir von den Leyen nicht trauen? Und diese Frage, niemand auf der Straße kann gerade irgendwelche Namen nennen. Niemand, noch die politisch interessiertesten Leute haben irgendeine Idee, was jetzt anders gemacht hätte werden können. Wenn die bisherige sagt, ich kandidiere noch mal, aber in einer Position, bei der selbst die CDU sagt, ja, das ist schon schwierig, eine schwierige Kandidatin, kommt so aus unserer Partei, aber ist schwierig, und die FDP im Parlament geschlossen gegen sie stimmt. Da muss man sagen, das sind halt einfach vertragte Zustände, aber Ursula von der Leyen ist nun mal jetzt Kommissionspräsidentin.
Und die anderen Präsidenten sind die anderen Präsidenten. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt mir einen Demokratisierungsprozess in Russland wünschen, der wird aber jetzt morgen nicht eintreten. Mit China ist es ähnlich, mit anderen Ländern sowieso. Das heißt, ich kann, wenn ich über die Geopolitik nachdenke, immer nur mit dem umgehen, das vorhanden ist. Und das ist auch Viktor Orbán. Und jetzt kann ich sagen, ich brauche einen ganz großen Disclaimer. Aber wir brauchen das hier nicht. wir haben ein aufgeklärtes Publikum. wir müssen jetzt nicht 15 Minuten über antisemitische Wahlkämpfe, homophobe Politik und all das sprechen.
wir sagen nur kurz, dass Ungarn an diesem Punkt ist, wo er ist, hat er auch dem zu verdanken, dass er das Wahlsystem so ein bisschen hingebogen hat. Sobald da jemand eine gewisse Schwelle von eigentlich nicht Mehrheit überschreitet, kriegt er gleich mal 60 Parlamentare extra oder sowas und regiert dann einfach durch. Aber das sind die demokratischen Abläufe, wie sie in Ungarn eben stattfanden, unter dieser medialen Öffentlichkeit, die wir haben. Da kann man halt, sieht man ja bei Trump auch, die Leute in das Licht führen.
Und deshalb ist es so gut, jetzt Orban einfach mal zuzuhören. Ich kenne überhaupt keine längeren Orban-Interviews im deutschen Fernsehen. Ich weiß, dass da schon mal irgendwo dann gefragt wird, und dann geht das meistens immer um diese Sache Migrationspolitik oder so. Und da muss ich aber auch, oder ich will es mal anders sagen, ich glaube...
Es gibt durchaus Festreden bei der CSU von von Palland.
Das gibt es natürlich, ja. Aber mein Problem ist, glaube ich, mit diesen ganzen Talkshows, dass die Leute, dass wenn immer jemand kommt aus, also man hat den Eindruck, die Journalisten müssen ihrer Peer-Group beweisen, dass sie jemanden dekonstruieren können. Ronzheimer muss niemandem beweisen, ob er jemanden dekonstruieren kann. Er muss jetzt nicht Orbán einladen und gucken, ob ich es zum Eklat schaffe. Mache ich den jetzt wütend? Konfrontiere ich den damit?
Entzaubern.
Entzaubere ich ihn. Sollen wir jetzt über homophobische Politik reden? Nein, er will einfach mal was wissen.
Also, Orbán ist im Ronzheimer Podcast sogar.
Ist im Ronzheimer Podcast. Nachdem er Zelensky und Putin getroffen hat. Erstmal ganz kurz, das nehme ich jetzt vorweg. Das kommt eigentlich am Ende erst des Podcasts. Wie ist das Trump? Wie ist das? Ah nee, das machen wir da auch erst später. wir gehen eine Reihenfolge durch. Also erstmal die Einschätzung von Orbán zum Krieg.
Und dann weiter alles blockieren und dann in einem Podcast zu sagen, dass die Russen aber ganz schön stark auf dem Schlachtfeld sind, ist natürlich auch ein bisschen...
Ja, natürlich. Der spricht natürlich mit zwei Zungen.
Mit gespaltener Zunge, sagt man ja.
Das Argument von EU-Politikerinnen ist, dass ein Reisen, wie du in Moskau gingen, die Position innerhalb Europas teilen würde und Putin zeigen würde, dass Europa nicht mit einer Stimme reden würde.
Sehr primitiv, sehr primitiv. Was ich tue, ist nicht das. Es gibt fünf Hauptaktoren in dieser sehr komplizierten Situation. Und jetzt habe ich zwei von fünf getroffen. Ukrainische, Russische, dann die USA, dann China, dann die Europäische Union. Und ich werde weiter mit den Opinionen, den Positionen, den Gesprächen.
Mit dem Ratspräsident der Europäischen Union, Viktor Orban. So. Dann haben alle zurückgemeldet. Nicht nur spricht er nicht mit uns, sondern der kennt auch unsere Positionen nicht oder Sonstiges, weil wir nicht mit ihm sprechen.
Aber Orban war vorher bei Scholz. Er war erst bei Scholz, ist dann zu Zelensky und ist dann zu Putin.
Ich finde auch nicht, dass Scholz diese Termine absagen oder Einladung nicht aussprechen sollte. Ich finde es gut, wenn alle miteinander reden, aber...
Ja, die Sache ist doch die. wir können ja jetzt noch 50 Mal unterstreichen, wie furchtbar Orban ist. Und ich würde mir auch wünschen, dass Ungarn einen völlig anderen Ministerpräsidenten hätte. Nur muss ich ja mit den Gegebenheiten umgehen und muss ja einfach erkennen, diese EU wird nicht einem demokratischen und liberalen Ansatz entsprechen, den sich beispielsweise Ursula von der Leyen erträumt. Und Ursula von der Leyen ist ja auch da selbst mal so, mal so. Mit Meloni kann sie ja wahnsinnig gut, wo es genauso viele Gründe wäre, gegen Meloni zu sein, genauso viele Gründe gäbe, wie gegen Orbans zu sein.
Ja, aber in diesem Falle des Ukraine-Kriegs ist doch Europa auf einer Seite. Die können eh nicht in eine neutrale Verhandlungsposition.
Ja, aber Ihnen geht es ja darum. Also wir versuchen uns jetzt mal das vorzunehmen. Also wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt hier nicht angetreten, um zu sagen, eigentlich ist der Orban doch ein prächtiger Kerl. wir haben es nur nie erkannt.
Ich finde ja auch, wir sollten ihm zuhören.
Ich finde, dass die Idee ist ja folgende. wir haben es ja mit fünf Mächten zu tun oder sagen wir es so, fünf sind involviert, das USA, EU, wenn man es mal so als Ganzes sieht, und Ukraine, also demokratisch. Dann haben wir autokratische Daten mit Russland und China. Das heißt also, es gibt nicht irgendeine gemeinsame Wertebasis in Bezug auf Demokratie und wie sollte man die Bevölkerung regieren.
Der Weltkriegskarakter ist schon ganz gut abgebildet in dieser Konzellation.
Und da ist jetzt doch für mich die interessante Frage, wenn Zelensky sagt, ich würde doch vielleicht mal darüber nachdenken, mit Russland zu verhandeln, aber das sollen bitte die Saudis organisieren, also nicht Demokraten. Das soll nicht Ursula von der Leyen mal organisieren, dann könnte er sie auch bitten.
Oder Orban.
Naja, das würde wahrscheinlich schon eher funktionieren, dass der Zelensky Orban bittet.
Ja, für mich sind das jetzt so Medien-Spiele.
Nein, was ich hier doch ganz klar machen will, ist wir haben eine Unter-, wir unterscheiden, wir teilen gerne auf, da ist die demokratische Welt und die wird das regeln. wir sehen die ganze Zeit jetzt, dass die demokratischen Staaten es nicht geregelt bekommen, aus verschiedenen Gründen. Und das Schlimme ist jetzt, dass wir gerade mit so einer Orbane-Reise, die wahrscheinlich gar nicht so unerfolgreich war, wie das gerne dargestellt wird, sehen, wie sich das im Allgemeinen verschiebt. Und das ist ja auch eine These von Blüthorn, dass wir sehen können, dass wir eigentlich diese Idee, die mit Demokratie von autonomem Subjekt und all dem verbunden ist, von einer freiheitlichen Erfahrung und so etwas, dass das zwar noch als wichtiger Wert die ganze Zeit da ist, aber dass das auch die ganze Zeit unterminiert wird. Und wir sehen, wie das unterminiert wird, ja gerade auf einer weltpolitischen Arena, wo man einfach nicht mehr mit unseren demokratischen Maßstäben irgendeinen Blumentopf gewinnen kann. Das mag man bedauern und ich bedauere es auch ganz offen. Aber ich würde sagen, dass wir eine Verschiebung haben dahin, dass immer mehr Weltpolitik auch gemacht wird, wie ein Orban oder ein Trump es machen.
Na gut, spielen wir die Clips.
Wie geht man damit um? Das ist auch eine große Frage. wir können natürlich jetzt sagen, wie Ursula von der Leyen jetzt wieder irgendwas sanktioniert oder so. Aber das sind ja doch alles sehr hilflose Aktionen, die da in Gang gesetzt werden. Das ist ja sehr erstaunlich. Dass Putin aufhört, weiter diesen Krieg zu führen.
Aber das Szenario ist ja wie folgt, also dieser Krieg beginnt durch einen Angriff Russlands.
Ja.
Und eigentlich könnte Europa und Amerika das locker abwehren, wenn sie nicht Widerstände bei sich hätten, die immer wieder da rein torpedieren, Waffenlieferungen, finanzielle Hilfe, was auch immer. Das ist dann in Europa urban, weil da schon die Hinwendung zur autokratischen Seite auf der anderen Seite des Krieges maßt. Und der amerikanische Kongress, der auch schon, ne, wir haben hier schon mal eine Mehrheit und tun schon mal so, als wären wir schon eine Trump-Peske Autokratie. Und dann verweigern die da auch monatelang das Geld. Was bedeutet, wir haben jetzt einen Zustand, der aus Blockade und Boykott, durch autokratische Kräfte auch auf der anderen Seite des Krieges, nicht nur auf Russland und Chinesischer. So, aber diesen Zustand von einem Vertreter dieser autokratischen Seite jetzt plötzlich zu verkaufen, als ich bin der Vernünftige, der jetzt diese Blockade, die sich hier eingestellt hat, die ich selber hergestellt habe, nutzt, um, ach, da sterben so viele Menschen, das ist ja gar nicht gut. wir sollten der autokratischen Seite mal Zugeständnisse machen und hier jetzt verhandeln und so weiter. Das finde ich schon wirklich problematisch.
Jaja, definitiv ist das problematisch, aber du bist ja auch der Ansicht, dass jetzt der Ukraine-Krieg nicht zu gewinnen wäre. Das lag ja jetzt nicht daran, dass Orbán irgendwelche Gelder nicht genehmigt hat oder die...
Auf meine Ansicht gefragt, würde ich sagen, ja, wir haben gesehen, wir schaffen es nicht. wir haben nicht genug Kraft, auch wenn wir uns das anders wünschen, mit demokratischen und progressiven Kräften Russland der Einhalt gebieten. Deshalb, wir uns jetzt auf uns konzentriert sollten, was zum einen bedeutet, Abkopplung von Amerika. Europa muss wehrtechnisch und wehrorganisatorisch und wehrpolitisch auf eigenen Füßen stehen. Plus, wenn die EU es nicht schafft, sich so zu organisieren, dann muss sie manche Länder da wieder ausschließen. Dann muss sie sich wieder verkleinern. Also Ungarn raus aus der Europäischen Union und dafür aber wieder Europäische Union. Das sind natürlich jetzt Szenarien, die sind nun gar nicht.
Orbán ist auch dafür, dass Europa aufrostet und sich unabhängig macht von den USA. Interessant, ne?
Ja, aber trotzdem würde ich jetzt Orbán ausschließen und sagen, hör mal zu, du hast uns hier so berkottiert, du musst jetzt dich um deine Verteidigung selber kümmern. Du kommst nicht in unseren europäischen abwehrschirm, denn hier sind nur Länder, die sich erstens verstehen, zweitens wohlwollend miteinander umgehen. Und da ist dann auch die große Frage, wie geht eigentlich Deutschland mit Frankreich um? Also dieses ganze Modell scheitert ja gerade auf ganzer Linie. Dass Orbán jetzt auch sagt, wir sollten uns mal europäisch auf eigene Füße stellen. Orbán möchte mit Brüssel gerade Wehrpolitik organisieren. Er hat doch die letzten drei Jahre gezeigt, dass er dazu nicht in der Lage ist, dass er nicht bereit dazu ist und dass er nur lügt. Also lasse ich ihm das nicht durchgehen, wenn er jetzt sagt, ich will ja auch, dass Europa auf eigenen Füßen steht.
Nein, will er nicht. Die Frage, die ich mir nur stelle ist, was ist, wenn wir es mit einem geopolitischen Parkett zu tun haben, auf dem lauter Orbans unterwegs sind, die ständig lügen, möglicherweise haben diese Orbans irgendwann die Möglichkeit, irgendwelche Verhandlungen zu machen. Du hast auch eben das Trump-Szenario geschildert. Trump klärt das mit Putin. Und das ist doch genau diese Idee, jetzt hier von Orbans zu sagen, wir Autokraten, wir klären das jetzt mal unter uns, die Idealisten und Bürokraten in Brüssel kann man vergessen. Das ist ja das, was wir jetzt hier erleben. Und das liegt natürlich auch daran, dass er das nur so kann, weil, wie Cevski ja vorher gesagt hat, Europa überhaupt keine Strategie hat, außer solche Lippenbekenntnisse wie, die Ukraine muss gewinnen. Und man denkt so, ja, wie denn?
Ja, meine Kritik an Orbans ist ja auch nicht an Orbans gerichtet, sondern an Pistorius.
Im Prinzip, ja.
Pistorius reagiert nicht darauf.
So, jetzt müssen wir aber auch einmal bereit sein, diese sicherlich sehr verquere Perspektive von Orbans einzunehmen.
Ich bin gespannt.
Ich möchte nicht in Details über die ukrainische Minoritätspolitik gehen. Du hast jetzt eine Gespräche mit dem hungarischen Prime Minister.
Ja, aber du hast Putin und Zelensky getroffen und du hast...
Aber ich weiß, aber ich weiß, wie die Situation der hungarischen Minoritäten war, die in Zakarpattia leben, die heute Teil der Ukraine ist, behandelt wurde von der ukrainischen Regierung über die Bildung, die hungarischen Bücher usw.
die jetzt Russland den Ukrainern aufzwängt. Aber er stellt das sofort in ein Verhältnis dar. Und das ist sehr ehrlich, wir wussten gar nichts von ungarischen Minoritäten in der Ukraine.
Ja, aber diese ganze Art der Antwort. Sie als Autokrat muss ich jetzt mal fragen, sagt der Ronsheimer, wie gehen Sie denn mit der Problemlage um, dass wir ein Land haben, das eigentlich, wenn auch ärmlich, aber dann doch irgendwie demokratisch zuletzt regiert wurde, dann politisch unterjocht wird von einem dann wieder autokratischem System. Und dann sagt er, sie reden ja gerade mit mir und nicht mit denen. Ich kann für die nichts sagen. So, das Szenario ist doch, wir richten dazu eine DDR ein. Ja, alle kriegen wieder ein Besen in die Hand. Es gibt keine Arbeitslosigkeit, es gibt ja keine Nazis und so. Und dann erklärt man irgendwas für 40 Jahre und dann stellt man fest, ach so krass, jetzt 50 Jahre später haben wir aber mal die Renten angeglichen und so weiter. Also man baut innerhalb von 40 Jahren so eine gigantische Asymmetrie zwischen zwei Ungarns auf. Diese ganzen Kosten, über die muss man doch, das ist doch die Verhandlungsmasse. Da kann er doch nicht jetzt da sitzen und sagen, ich sorge erstmal nur für Frieden, dass niemand mehr stirbt. Und der Rest müssen dann, das müssen sie mit anderen Leuten.
Kneil, du hast ja eben über die Ost-Ukraine gesprochen. Und die Frage, die sich ja jetzt hier stellt, ist, wird die ukrainische Regierung bereit sein, in Assoziationen mit den westlichen Partnern die Ost-Ukraine in Teilen aufzugeben? Das bedeutet aber für die Bevölkerung, die dort lebt, dass sie unter russischer Herrschaft, unter russischer Knute leben müssen. Und diese Frage bekommt er jetzt so gestellt und verschiebt das natürlich auf, ja wir haben ja auch ukrainische...
Ja, aber ich als Kommentator kann doch ganz zynisch über die Lausitz sprechen. Ich habe ja keine Verantwortung für diese Menschen, aber ich kann die doch jetzt nicht ausverkaufen, nur weil ich meine Autokratie gerne schützen möchte und es cool fände, wenn umso mehr Autokratien um mich herum mich nicht bedrohen, weil ich einer von ihnen bin. Das ist ja Urbans Ansinn.
Ja, ja, also dazu kommen wir gleich noch zu dieser Betrohung durch Russland. Aber du bist doch selbst jemand, der sagt, also es wird Verhandlungen geben müssen und diese sehen natürlich nicht so aus, dass die Maximalforderungen der Ukraine dort bewilligt werden. Also es wird Abstriche werden gemacht werden müssen. Anders wird es nicht gehen.
Ja, aber die will ich doch nicht von Orbán jetzt diktiert haben mit, das liegt jenseits meines Interesses. Ich will nur, dass da keiner stirbt und das hat er ja gerade so gesagt. Orbán ist einfach nicht der richtige Ansprechpartner dafür.
Nein, es ist doch interessant, wenn man jemanden zuhört, der natürlich uneigentlich redet die ganze Zeit. Also das ist ja klar, dass der Orbán jetzt nicht da sitzt und sagt, mir tun die Menschen, die sterben so leid und um die kümmere ich mich.
Für Orbán gilt die Logik von...
Rutger Brechmann.
Mit diesen Leuten stimmt irgendwas nicht. Die stellen sich selber über alle Schicksale im nah und fernen Bereich ihrer sozialen Landkarte.
Und deswegen hören wir das ja hier, weil ich sagen würde, so funktioniert ja leider ein ganz großer Teil der Weltpolitik.
Oder diesen aufklärischen Sichtpunkt.
Also wir müssen es ja erkenntnisinteressengeleitet hören. wir können ja nicht sagen, aber das wäre viel schöner, wenn wir das alles ganz unter guten, rationalen Menschen ausmachen könnten, die nur für alle das Beste wollen. Das wäre ja toll, aber diese...
Ja, du unterstellst, ob man so eine wichtige Rolle hat. Ich glaube das nicht. Das war eine kleine dreitägige Medienreise. Putin, China, Trump.
Wie ist es, mit vladimir Putin, der, in meiner Meinung, ein Kriegskriminal ist, mit den Händen zu schälen?
Das ist ja eine ganz typische Frage jetzt. Also die könnte jetzt auch sonst in Talkshows gestellt werden. Und wir wissen aber natürlich, dass man so überhaupt kein diplomatisches Treffen angehen kann, wenn man sagt, guten Tag, Sie sind ja Kriegsverbrecher oder sowas.
Na ja, also der, wie hieß er, von der Leins Vorgänger, Dingser Wumms, Luxemburg, der hat ja Orban immer mit Herr Diktator begrüßt. Vielleicht hat er das gar nicht so mit uns gemacht.
Ja, aber wir wissen auch bei Jean-Claude Juncker, dass da auch einiges ein bisschen schiefgelaufen war. Und das ist ja unter Freunden quasi. Also das ist ja unter EU-Leuten. Aber das hätte Juncker nicht zu Putin gesagt. Das ganz gewiss nicht. Und hier ist aber auch wieder die Sache, also wir kriegen doch gerade Folgendes mit. Zum einen gibt es da diese Bestrebungen, wie kriegt man Putin nach Den Haag? Das belächeln wir, weil wir sagen, gut, eh aussichtslos. Und was haben die mit dem Völkerrecht zu tun? Die Amerikaner haben auch nur dann was mit dem Völkerrecht zu tun, wenn sie sich da positiv drauf beziehen können für ihre Sache. wir sehen gerade, dass es Bestrebungen gibt, Israel wegen Kriegsverbrechen vor das Gericht zu bekommen. Da weiß man schon, egal wie das ausgeht, Deutschland wird sich da irgendwie so zu verhalten, dass man sagt, ja, ja, wissen wir jetzt gerade nicht. Ist vielleicht gut, wenn wir jetzt mehr Israel besuchen, als wenn die israelische Regierung uns besucht, damit da nicht irgendwelche Schwierigkeiten stehen. Das heißt, wie wir das bei den Realisten um Merscha immer gelernt haben, eigentlich spielt das gar keine Rolle, weil es am Ende die Staaten sind, die sich konfrontativ gegenüberstehen. Und so beschreibt er es jetzt hier auch.
Und wer lebt, wer lebt. Sitt in Brüssel, in Paris oder nahe dem atlantischen Ozean, kannst du eine richtige Distanz in einem mehr theoretischen Weg die Waffe haben. Aber die Wahrheit der Waffe ist nicht das. Die Wahrheit der Waffe ist eine sehr scharfe Realität.
Und das tut ja auch den Russen inzwischen empfindlich weh. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass Putin sagt, na ich hab da meine Gruppe Wagner nur. Und daran kann man doch ganz klar sehen, an dieser Argumentation, die da jetzt gemacht wird. Ja, dem geht es nicht um die Menschen, Orban. Das ist ja völlig klar. Was er aber hier deutlich macht, ist, dass diese Fragen, die bei einer Verhandlung sich als erstes stellen, nicht eine Frage ist, wer hat jetzt welche Kriegsverbrechen verübt, sondern wie kann das Sterben aufhören? Und da würde ich sagen, da hat Orban absolut recht zu gehen, alle die verhandeln da rein.
Ja, aber das ist doch, also wenn er da so dasitzt und sagt, also im Krieg entscheidet sich nicht dieses und jenes, sondern nur wer stirbt. Das ist doch Taschenspieler-Trick-Philosophie.
Naja, aber das stimmt doch.
Ja klar stimmt's, aber er hat doch diesen Krieg selber, wie viele sagen, unnötig verlängert, in dem er die ukrainischen Kämpfern Unterstützung versagt hat. Und das hat er ja nun faktisch. Militärhilfen wurden nicht gezahlt und Sanktionen nicht ausgesprochen für die andere Seite, weil Orbán da Vetos eingelegt hat.
Ja.
Und dann darüber zu sitzen, darüber zu reden, ohne das in diesem Moment mitzureflektieren, sei es von Ronsheimer in Fragen oder von ihm selbst.
Aber das können wir doch selbst reinlegen. Also das finde ich ja gerade die Qualität von Ronsheimer, dass er mir jetzt nicht nochmal…
Ich finde, so etwas sollte explizit angesprochen werden. Die gibt so eine Geschichte, die des Krieges gehört, das Orbán auf der falschen Seite kämpft.
Ja.
Und jetzt uns Verhandlung schönredet.
Wenn Ronsheimer konfrontativ wird, führt das zu gar nichts. Ich bringe dir jetzt nämlich ein Beispiel dafür.
Du findest nicht viele Menschen, die dir sagen, okay, jetzt müssen wir uns jetzt diskutieren. Weil sie sagen, wenn die Russen. Wie die Situation ist und was die Leute mir sagen.
Auch nicht die Brüsseler. Sehr wenige Menschen der Welt können mehr über Russland wissen als die Ungarn.
Das finde ich ganz perfide.
Natürlich ist es perfide. Ich will dir nur damit zeichnen, eine Konfrontation bringt nichts.
Orban braucht die Bedrohung durch Russland, um jetzt das Argument zu machen, ich verstehe am besten, wie es ist, von Russland bedroht sein. wir waren ja schon häufiger besetzt. Und gleichzeitig diesen Punkt zu fahren, aber dann latent unausgesprochen, ich brauche Strongman um mich herum, damit nicht so auffällt, dass ich ein Strongman bin.
Ja, aber ich finde, aber es ist doch eigentlich eine Qualität eines Interviews, wenn genau das rauskommt.
Wenn es rauskommt.
Ja, aber es kommt ja auch raus. Also es ist ja in aller Deutlichkeit.
wir haben es dechiffriert.
Naja, also ich würde sagen, das spricht schon sehr für sich. Also bei Orbán hast du schon es mit einer Figur zu tun, die kannst du sprechen lassen und dann kriegst du die Informationen schon, die du brauchst. Dass der jetzt nicht sagt, ja ich bin homophob und ja ich habe auch ein Problem mit den Juden, das ist ja klar, dass er das nicht sagt. Das ist jetzt tatsächlich ein sehr interessanter Punkt und da würde ich jetzt Orbán auch tatsächlich glauben in der Äußerung, die jetzt kommt. Also das kennen wir ja, wenn jetzt ceasefire ist, dann bewaffnen die sich neu. Ist übrigens auch eine Diskussion ja dann immer, wenn man jetzt ceasefire in Gaza hätte, dann würde die Hamas sich neu aufstellen und so. Und jetzt hat Orbán ja gerade dann mit beiden gesprochen, Zelensky und Putin und sie genau dazu befragt.
Ich habe die Frage an beide Führer gestellt. Ist es möglich, eine limited-time ceasefire zu kreieren, die den Peace Talks schnellstellt und dann die guten Konsequenzen einer schnellsten Peace Talks zu genießen? Jetzt denkt jeder nur das Gegenteil. Erst müssen wir einen Peace Agreement machen. Wenn es einen Peace Agreement gibt, dann können wir eine ceasefire haben. Und sie waren nicht positiv darüber. Keiner von ihnen. Sie haben genau das gleiche als du gesagt. Die Ukraine und die Russen. ceasefire wäre der Interesse der anderen, weil sie während der ceasefire ihre Position organisieren würden, in der Vorbereitung, die Waffen weiter zu verhandeln. Ich verstehe diese Position.
Ja, also dieses Dilemma gibt es ja tatsächlich. Und das wird nicht seine Rolle sein, das natürlich zu verhandeln. Auch nach den Opfern wird gefragt.
Habt ihr mit Putin darüber geredet, wie viele russische Männer so farben gestorben sind?
Ich habe beide Personen über die Verlusten gefragt. Beide waren bereit, das Nummer zu sagen, wenn es um die anderen geht, aber nicht um sich selbst.
Also diese Opferzahlen nach wie vor im Dunkeln. Wie ist es denn jetzt mit dieser Gefahr, Putin greift die NATO an? Und nach wie vor gilt doch, wenn Putin es nicht schafft, Kiev einzunehmen, soll er aber zugleich schon morgen in Berlin stehen. Was ist das immer für eine Argumentation?
Diese Unterscheidung, die er macht zwischen Misskalkulierungen und Irrationalität, finde ich es nicht haltbar. Das kann man so sagen, weil das eine Pointe im Gespräch ist, aber es war irrational, diesen Krieg so zu beginnen für Putin und für Russland, also beidermaßen, denn weder kann diese Biografie daraus wieder zurückkommen, noch das politische Schicksal Russlands, noch irgendwas Positives daraus ziehen. Dafür sind die Einschnitte viel zu groß. Und wenn er dann sagt, ne, die haben sich einfach miss-, also da gab es so andere Kalkulationen, die gingen dann halt nicht auf. Ne, das ist ja der Madness-Anteil daran, dass es trotzdem gemacht hat. Das ist ein bisschen wie bei Oppenheimer. Ich habe das hier nur diese eine Szene nochmal so bei YouTube gesehen, wie sie so diese Berechnung machen. Ja, entzünden wir dann die ganze Atmosphäre. Und dann kriegt er ja diesen Stapel Papier und dann sagt er, verschwinden geringe Wahrscheinlichkeit. Da setzt sich niemand hin und fragt, ist das jetzt Misskalkulation oder Madness? Sondern es ist einfach Madness, es trotzdem mal zu versuchen. Könnte ja sein, dass die Kalkulation richtig ist und wir nicht die ganze Welt in Brand setzen. Und dann haben sie es einfach gemacht. Also hier gilt einfach, es ist dann Madness, es ist Irrationalität. Die Idee, dass man das kalkulieren könnte, gehört schon auf die Seite der Madness. wir kalkulieren jetzt mal einen Krieg durch und dann stellen wir fest, die alten Philosophen hatten doch recht, sobald Planung Realität wird, ist sozusagen die Grenze überschritten. Das ist bescheuert.
Und hier würde ja unser, du musst draufklicken, unser Rutger Brechmann sagen, dass das die Politiker auszeichnen. Die machen das halt.
Das ist deren Auszeichnung, diese Madness einfach zu machen. wir testen jetzt die Atombombe. Ihr habt unseren Befehl. wir setzen sie jetzt ein im Krieg. wir wissen nicht, was dann passiert.
Vielleicht gibt es noch mal graduelle Unterschiede. Ich sage mal so, dass ein gewisser militärischer Erfolg seitens Russlands in der Ukraine zu erzielen war, ist wahrscheinlich, zugleich gibt es diesen grohen Madness-Anteil, den du da eben ausgeführt hast, während wir es jetzt, wenn Russland auf die Idee käme, Berlin zu erobern, nur mit Madness noch zu tun hätten und mit keinerlei sinnvollem militärischen Erfolg, den man erwarten könnte.
Die Unterscheidung von Sieg und Frieden oder Sieg und Niederlage und Gewinnen und Verlieren, die muss man wirklich hinterfragen. Precht hat immer wieder darauf hingewiesen in seinem Podcast, ja, Deutschland hat den Zweiten Weltkrieg verloren, wie noch nie ein Land einen Krieg verloren hat. Und zehn Jahre später war das die Power-Nation Europas. Haben sie wirklich verloren? Sie haben eine Niederlage gehabt, aber haben sie wirklich verloren? Nee, der Erfolg zeigt dann doch irgendwie was anderes. Hier auch, wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, wir geben irgendwie die ukrainische Lausitz Putin. Gleichzeitig ist aber das Land nicht nur durch Corona, sondern dann auch durch diese Sanktionen gegangen, die nun wirklich einschneidend sind. Egal, was ansonsten über irgendwelche Spin-Doktoren uns nochmal erklärt wird, wenn da einfach ganze Märkte, Weltmarktzugänge gestrichen werden. Ja, man kriegt sein Öl schon noch verkauft. Genau, aber Russland war vorher auch schon, naja gut, das Einzige, was sie haben, ist halt Öl. Und dieser Verlust an volkswirtschaftlicher Kraft, Lebenszufriedenheit und so weiter. Ja, wir müssten dann irgendwie sagen, sie haben den Krieg so ein bisschen gewonnen. So, es ist ein Sieg. Aber haben sie wirklich gewonnen?
Nein, nein, nicht in dem Sinne.
Russland ist in einem Zustand, wo man echt sagen muss, nee, das ist, also hier diese Kategorien schon überhaupt anzulegen, sind völlig daneben.
Genau, und wir sehen ja jetzt gerade, wir hatten im letzten Salon ja diesen Text über wie Blackrock und andere Investoren ihre Unterstützung abziehen von der Ukraine. Man kann sich also durchaus eine Situation vorstellen, in der die Ukraine den Krieg doppelt verliert und zwar einmal jetzt militärisch wird man irgendwas dann aus Baldovan mit Trump und Putin und dann hat man aber noch westliche Investoren, hat westliche Staaten, die auch alle sagen, ach, interessiert uns jetzt gerade nicht mehr so der Aufbau und wir wollen unser Geld zurück haben. wir wollen unser Geld zurück haben. wir werfen euch jetzt in die tiefste Schuldenfalle, die ihr euch vorstellen könnt. Das ist ja die große Gefahr, die da ist. Jetzt noch mal auf Orbán und das Ziel seiner Reise.
So, therefore discussion, which was generated my my trips and my future trips will also generate is not a bad thing. Is a good thing. This is the starting point to argue not only in favor of the war, but now there are more and more person who would like to argue in favor of peace, which was not the case even one week ago. So it's a fermentation, may I say what we need. And I think it's already started to happen.
Fermentation, also eine Gehrung findet statt. wir haben den Blüthorn schon gelesen. wir werden morgen über ihn, nicht morgen, aber im Salon dann über ihn diskutieren. Blüthorn hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Unhaltbarkeit. Unhaltbar sind ja auch militärische Posten. Ja, da kann man nicht mehr weiter. Man muss also irgendetwas sehen. wir müssen einen anderen Weg einschlagen. Er will ja zeigen, welcher Weg da gerade so läuft, in welche Moderne man kommt. Nicht in eine zweite Moderne, sondern in eine andere Moderne kommt man dann. Und er sagt, unhaltbar wird zunehmend dieses demokratische Projekt. Nicht weil er die Demokratie scheiße findet, sondern er sieht das als sehr dramatisch an. Und wir sehen jetzt, wir haben nur wenige Staaten eigentlich, die demokratisch regiert sind in der Welt. Das sind gar nicht so viele wirklich demokratisch regiert.
Was heißt denn wirklich demokratisch?
Na ja, also China, da gibt es auch irgendwas, wird da rumgewählt. Oder in Russland wird da auch ein bisschen gewählt. Aber jetzt sagen wir, die sich mit unseren Maßstaben messen. Die sich mit Maßstaben von Deutschland zum Beispiel messen könnten. Da fallen einem nicht so viel ein. Wenn man sich anguckt, wie groß die Weltbevölkerung ist und wie viele Menschen dort demokratisch regiert werden, dann ist das eine ganz deutliche Minderheit.
Die wohlhabende Minderheit.
Ja, aber wir sprechen hier von einer Minderheitenposition aus. Und zu dieser Gruppe gehört Orban nicht. Gehört China nicht, gehört Putin nicht. Aber die haben irgendwie ein Draht zueinander. Nun ist Ungarn nicht so wahnsinnig wichtig, aber irgendwas passiert da. Das heißt, wir sehen doch jetzt gerade, wie in China Klimapolitik gemacht wird, die uns betrifft. Adam Tewes hat einen riesen Essay geschrieben der Zeit darüber. Er sagt, konzentriert euch nicht nur auf die US-Wahl. Noch wichtiger ist die Entscheidung 2025, wie wird die Klimapolitik organisiert sein in China. Das wird uns alle betreffen. Da stellt sich am Ende heraus, ob wir wenigstens das 2-Grad-Ziel erreichen. Und jetzt sehen wir hier Autokraten unterwegs, führen miteinander Gespräche und die versuchen jetzt irgendwas herzustellen, was sie dann Frieden nennen oder wie auch immer. Das heißt, auch das ist wieder etwas, wo wir sehr stark ausgeklammert sind. Die Frage ist jetzt, wie verhält man sich zu so einem Orban? Man kann den nochmal bestrafen, wie von der Leyen das getan hat. Das ist aber vielleicht nicht besonders effektiv, sondern die Frage ist also jetzt, wie kann man selbst zum aktiven Part werden? Also müsste man nicht eigentlich sagen, Macron und Scholz reisen jetzt erst zu Zelensky, dann zu Putin. Also um selbst wieder Teil des Spiels zu werden, damit das nicht nur eine Strongman-Politik ist, wie Orbán und Co. sich das vorstellen. Und ich glaube, diese Herausforderung ist da. Und wir haben Patrzewski gehört, der sagt, der Westen hat ja gar keinen Plan. Also ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass der Trump-Anhänger ist, der Mann, der kommt da aus Großbritannien. Aber wenn er selbst die Hoffnung hat, dass wenigstens mit einem Regierungswechsel, dass Trump da etwas Positives für die Ukraine rausholen könnte und er sagt, ich weiß, dass die im Zelensky-Kreis schon ähnlich denken, dann muss uns das doch in erheblichem Maße zu denken geben. Da kann es doch nicht sein, dass wir nur da stehen und wie so ein Roboter wiederholen. Das ist ein völkerrechtswidriger Angriffskrieg.
Darf ich aber jetzt nicht unterschätzen, wie sehr diese Regierungsleute sowie alle Investoren, egal, worin sie investieren, auf Stabilität und Perspektive aus sind. Und so schlimm es für die Menschen an der Front gerade ist, im geopolitischen Maßstab Turbulenz oder Nicht-Turbulenz ist der Kriegszustand gerade ziemlich viel Nicht-Turbulenz. Also da sitzen zwei Leute im Podcast und sagen, ja, seit einem Jahr ist eigentlich nicht sehr viel passiert. Und man hat so eine Ahnung davon, dass man nur in kleinen Milliarden Beträgen feiern steuern kann, ob da jetzt noch was passiert oder nicht. So, also bald eine Offensive angekündigt ist, kommt ein Medientheater, da ist eine Offensive angekündigt, wir müssen auch, da wird die Offensive so ein bisschen abgewogen, ausgewogen, ausgeglichenen Zustände hergestellt. Und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob erstens China gerade wirklich daran interessiert ist, dass sich in Russland groß was ändert und es würde sich einiges ändern, wenn es diesen Krieg nicht mehr gäbe. Und zum anderen, ja für uns sieht es so aus, als gäbe es da eine autokratische Allianz. Für Russland sieht es so aus, als gäbe es da gerade eine ganz andere Allianz. Denn Obama, Biden und Macron und Scholz, sie sind ja durchaus im Gespräch. Also es ist ja klar, dass die da reden und als Scharnierstelle da von der Leyen usw. Die sind viel mehr im Gespräch als jetzt Putin und Xi. Und aus deren Richtung betrachtet, sind wir halt die Verlangs. Also zwischen Sieg und Niederlage, Gewinnen und Verlieren, gibt es halt einfach noch so jetzt mal nichts auf.
Nur es sind ja die Menschen, die sterben, du hast sie angesprochen.
Genau, die sind Xi ganz egal. Also der sperrt auch eine Million Uiguren an.
Genau, aber wer am Ende den Krieg beendet, ist ja, also wer das Sterben beendet, beendet das Sterben. Da kann man jetzt nicht sagen, die Intention war eine andere.
Ja, das macht es ja so interessant, dass Trump...
Ich sage mal so, die Intention bei der Bundesregierung ist ja offensichtlich auch nicht das Sterben der Menschen.
Der einzige, der aus dem Ende des Krieges etwas ziehen kann, ist Donald Trump. Weil er seinen Wählern erklären kann, seiner Base, ich bin der Weltfriedenspräsident. Und das, würde ich sagen, ist auch einer der größten Antriebe zum Frieden gerade. Diese Hoffnung der Autokraten, dass Trump den Weltfrieden herstellt und über das Weltfriedensargument eine sozusagen latent mitlaufende Argumentation für autokratische Politik. Nur diese Art der Politik kann das gestalten. So und deswegen ist diese amerikanische Wahl auch nochmal besonders interessant.
Und Orban, den man ja als einen kleinen Trump bezeichnen kann oder der schon viel erfolgreicher war.
Großer Trump im kleinen Land.
Ja, großer Trump im kleinen Land. Ist da ein Beispiel für. Und neben der ganzen Sache um die Soldaten, die sterben, ist es ja auch so, dass wir zwar sagen, ja, das ist kommt einem fast wie Ruhe vor. Aber es gibt ja dann doch, wenn man so ein bisschen tiefer sich reinliest, zum Beispiel diesen Artikel von McCallion und Friedman in Politico liest, dann sieht man schon, dass es große Ängste gibt, dass so etwas eskalieren kann. Dass also solche Grenzübertritte die ganze Zeit stattfinden, dass es das keineswegs so ruhig verläuft. Insofern ist es also eigentlich eben im Sinne aller, dass das passiert. Die Intention ist doch am Ende völlig egal. Also Orban geht es nicht um die Menschen, das wissen wir. Die Frage ist, kann so eine Gärung tatsächlich in irgendeiner Weise funktionieren, wo er sich sicher ist, dass Trump nicht derjenige ist, der die Ukraine ausliefert? Und dafür ist er ja auch bekannt. Jetzt ganz zum Abschluss noch wird er zu Merkel befragt. Und daher kennen wir ja Orban vor allem dieser permanente Streit mit Merkel über die Migration. Es ist ja wirklich absurd gewesen, wie Orban da Politik gegen Brüssel und gegen Merkel ganz speziell gemacht hat. Und jetzt fragt Ronzheimer.
Do you miss Angela Merkel?
Always.
Man denkt so, und dann erklärt er ein bisschen, ja ich bin, wie sie ja wissen, gegen Migration. Und Ronzheimer sagt noch, ja ich hab davon gehört, aber in Sachen Diplomatie sei sie einsame Spitze gewesen.
If Angela Merkel was still Chancellor of Germany.
Ich denk, es hing wirklich mehr von Trump und Trumps Wahlniederlage zusammen, als jetzt mit Merkel ist nicht mehr im Arm. Auch wenn es näher dran liegt.
Aber wer weiß.
Gut, die amerikanische Wahl. wir wollen alle wissen, was ist im Juli in Amerika passiert und worauf sollte man den Fokus insbesondere legen?
Im Juli?
Achso, was ist passiert?
Was ist passiert? Oder was jetzt im August passiert?
Ich dachte, du prediktest doch bestimmt jetzt gleich schon, wie es sein wird.
Nein, wir machen jetzt eine Timeline des Juli in Amerika. Was ist passiert, seit wir zuletzt darüber sprachen, seit der Debatte. wir haben alle mitbekommen, es läuft eine Wahl. Sie ist wichtig, wird uns gesagt. wir wissen nicht so genau warum. Aber sie ist auf jeden Fall mega unterhaltsam. wir haben zuletzt die Debatte gesehen und dachten, so wird das nichts. Dieser Wahlkampf wird sich wohl verändern und er hat sich jetzt im Juli verändert. Nur um an den Tenor der Debatte anzuschließen, hier aus dem direkten Nachbesprechungsreigen bei CNN, diese kleine beliebige Wortmeldung. So, also wenn sich nichts verändert wird, amerikanischer Präsident Donald Trump und irgendwie ist die democracy on the line oder was auch immer. Es bleibt alles so ein bisschen unscharf, ist es ja geblieben und auch zu der Frage, was kann sich denn jetzt verändern, war ja bis dahin noch die Frage, ja müssen wir jetzt den Kandidaten austauschen. Und es ist ja, wie wir heute wissen, Kamala Harris geworden und nicht Gavin Newsom oder irgendwer anders, weil diese Idee von, wir rollen das nochmal ganz auf, ging gar nicht, auch wenn Harris ja sofort erklärt hat, ich will mir die Kandidatur erarbeiten und verdienen, statt einfach nur ernannt zu werden. Hier kann man das mal raushören. Die soziologische Dramatik wird darüber nicht richtig deutlich, aber man kann sie danach zumindest mal umreißen. Also auch an diesem Abend in dieser Halle war dann auch Gavin Newsom anwesend und man fragt ihn, was ist jetzt vor dieser Debatte damals zu halten?
Da gibt es Panik.
Bist du glaubt, es ist unfauniert?
Ich glaube, es ist unnötig.
Und ich glaube, es ist unnötig. wir müssen rein, wir müssen unsere Hände hochhalten.
Und wie ich sage, wir müssen den Rücken dieses Präsidenten haben.
Du wirst nicht den Rücken wechseln, weil es eine Performance ist.
Was für ein Partei tut das?
Es ist eine Masterklasse.
15,6 Millionen Jobs.
Das ist achtmal mehr als die letzten drei Republikan-Präsidenten.
Das einzige, was die letzten drei Republikan-Präsidenten.
Haben, ist der Kanzler, Olaf Scholz. Der Kanzler kann ein bisschen nachhelfen, wenn Nancy Pelosi als doch sehr, sehr wichtige Stimme auftritt, wenn Geldgeber sagen, wir sind raus.
Also medialer Druck kann alles Mögliche. Aber formal gesehen kann auch...
Obama im Hintergrund. Also da haben schon einige mitgespielt.
Alles richtig.
Aber am Ende ist es der Präsident.
Der Formalier ist das egal. Die Formalier kennt keinen medialen Druck. Sondern Olaf Scholz ist der Kanzler. Egal, was diskutiert wird. Er ist der Kanzler. Bis er sagt, ich stelle ein Misstraumsvotum. Es gibt sonst keine Möglichkeit, da irgendwas zu tun. So, und die besondere Dramatik und Panik bei ihm, der Stimme, die hier wirklich hörbar ist, bedeutet ja auch, es braucht Königsmörder. Es gibt aber keinen formalen Weg. Der informale Weg wäre medialer Druck. Kann an dem Moment nur hoffen, dass das passiert. Der Tenor war ja schon, das wird er nicht überleben. Der mediale Druck wird entsprechend groß sein. Aber man braucht ja dann auch einen Ersatz. Ersatz bedeutet alternative Kampagnen. Wenn man eine Vorwahl hat, stehen die Teams angeführt von ihrem Personal und dahinter die Wahlkampftruppen. Was hier in dem Falle bedeutet, Joe Biden hat an Kamala Harris eine 1.300 Vollzeitstellen mannstarke Mannschaft übergeben. Gavin Newsom in dem Moment, wo er das sagt, null. Und er dürfte nicht mal eine Person anrufen, um sie zu fragen, ob sie für einen Wahlkampf bereit stünde, wenn es zu einem Wahlkampf käme, weil das sofort gemeldet würde als, er glaubt nicht mehr dran, er ist der Königsmörder, das wird nichts. Also inwieweit diesen Leuten die Hände gebunden waren, und sie einfach nur als in dem Falle dann wirklich Person des Interesses in der Öffentlichkeit zu stehen und zu sagen, wir wenden uns nicht von ihm ab, wir unterstützen ihn, er hat Delivered, Masterclass. Es ist wirklich erstaunlich im Rückblick, finde ich, das nochmal so zu sehen. Wieder einfach in dem Falle dann wirklich einfach einzelne Personen dastehen und sagen, ich kann leider gar nichts machen. So und dann gab es ja die erste große Wendung, weil er jetzt schon hiermit, wir können keinen Königsmord organisieren. Ja, Königsmord ist es jetzt ein König eigentlich, stellt sich raus. Die Debatte war am Freitag, am Montag drauf, 1. Juli kam dann diese Supreme Court-Urteil, von dem ich mal kurz durchgehe, wie das in den deutschen Medien verhandelt wurde. Die ARD fragt also in der Überschrift am Tage, die ARD fragt oder schreibt, Trump erringt in Immunitätsfrage Teilsieg vor Supreme Court. Kann man sagen, nee, das war also den amerikanischen Journalisten, wir hören es gleich am Tage der Verkündung klar, hier geht es nicht um Trump, der irgendwas erringt, hier geht es nicht um Teilsiege, sondern hier geht es einfach all in um alles und überhaupt. Hier geht es um das Verfassungsgefüge von Amerika. Zwei Tage später, kleine Besinnung, Urteil zur Immunität, Zitat, Supreme Court hat Trump freie Hand gegeben. In dem Falle das Zitat eines Experten. Man hat nämlich dann, so steht es in der Überzeile, nach zwei Tagen, also zwei Tage nach dem Urteil des obersten US-Gerichts, zur Immunität von Ex-Präsidenten, ich würde sagen Präsidenten halt, meinen Beobachter, die Entscheidung wird die amerikanische Demokratie verändern, von einem Dammbruch spricht US-Experte Finch, der ist dann hier im Gespräch und sagt in einer Antwort, in diesem Urteil kommt das Prinzip zum Einsatz, dass der König nicht falsch handeln kann. Das ist eine alte Diskussion aus dem englischen Verfassungsrecht, dass der König wegen Handlung, die er begeht, nicht vor Gericht landen kann. In der amerikanischen Revolution ist dieses Prinzip abgeschafft worden. Der oberste Gerichtshof führt es jetzt durch die Hintertür wieder ein. Also die Tagesschau hat dann eine Person irgendwo gehabt, die meinte, wir sollten das nochmal thematisieren, denn wir haben es im Fernsehen irgendwie ganz anders behandelt als unsere Leute. Wenn ich amerikanisches Fernsehen schaue, könnt ihr nicht mal mit dem und dem reden. Hintergrund ist natürlich dann nochmal Projekt 2025. Da wurde übrigens jetzt der Chef rausgedrängt von Trump, weil er ihm irgendwie, keine Ahnung, zu viele Widerworte oder was auch immer. Aber der Heritage Foundation Chef Kevin Roberts, der das ja maßgeblich mitfinanziert und trägt. Von dem ist ja bekannt, dass er sagte, wir befinden uns im Prozess der zweiten amerikanischen Revolution, die unblutig bleiben wird, wenn die Linke es zulässt. Also wir lernen jetzt hier Tagesschau und dann ZDF. Okay, es gibt da so Zitate, die stehen im Raum. Die haben irgendwas zu tun mit, schon wieder eine amerikanische Revolution. Also es geht jetzt quasi um das Komplettgefüge. Über 200 Jahre, die älteste Demokratie der Welt und so weiter werden hier umrissen. Das ZDF, Supreme Court zur Immunität, ein großer Sieg für Trump. Und dann in der Oberzeile, Teilsieg für Donald Trump, vor dem obersten Gerichtshof. Der Ex-Präsident bleibt vor Strafverfolgung geschützt, zumindest bei offiziellen Amtshandlungen. Und dann wird ewig lang diskutiert, was ja noch zu diskutieren ist. Was heißt denn das jetzt? Gibt es inoffizielle Amtshandlungen? Andere Medien. US Supreme Court gesteht Donald Trump Immunität zu, allerdings nur teilweise. Reif der Spiegel in der ersten Meldung. Erst danach, am 2. Juli, in einem Leitartikel, der bis heute hinter der Paywall ist. Aber immerhin 700 Worte zum Thema. Urteil zur Immunität des US-Präsidenten der Supreme Court hilft, die amerikanische Demokratie zu zerstören. Ich frage mich, warum diese Verzögerung von ein, zwei Tagen, die da drinsteckt, bis man dann so, ach ja, es geht doch um alles irgendwie. Es ist jetzt neuer amerikanische Revolution, es ist jetzt wieder Königreich und so. Kein Niederschlag nirgendwo. In der eigenen Tagesthemenberichterstattung, Heudejournal wird es dann nicht mehr aufgegriffen. So, als wäre gerade das Momentum für diese Nachricht vorbei oder so was. wir hatten da diese Aufschlagnachricht, die ging ein bisschen schief, deswegen haben wir noch mal einen Nachdreher gemacht. Aber muss das jetzt irgendwo diskutiert werden? Vielleicht sogar mal in einer Talkshow oder so? Nein, fand überhaupt nicht statt. Also in deren Sicht sehr schade.
Mich hat es auch gewundert. Ich habe aber dann eine Antwort, glaube ich, darauf gefunden, nämlich diese ganzen Prozesse, die Trump ja seit Jahren hat, werden alle unter sehr bulvardesken Gesichtspunkten gesehen. Nun ist dies aber nichts Bulvardeskes, sondern etwas ganz Grundsätzliches. Und dann muss man auf eine völlig andere Ebene gehen. Dazu ist man aber nicht bereit. Man will eigentlich noch mal wissen, welche E-Mails hat Trump irgendeiner Porno-Dialogin geschrieben. Hier geht es um was anderes. Und man kann es ja nachlesen. Zum Beispiel in den Blättern, jetzt auch übersetzt, Adam Server hatte in Die Atlantic schnell ein Artikel dazu verfasst. Und er spricht davon, dass es jetzt so umgebaut ist, dass man eigentlich von einem, beim obersten Gericht von Trump-Gericht sprechen muss. Und er sagt dann, mit dieser Entscheidung sagt das Trump-Gericht, dass Trump Immunität für Verbrechen genießt, die er bereits begangen hat und für Verbrechen, die er in der Zukunft zu begehen beabsichtigt. Der ganze Zweck der Verfassung war, es eine Regierung zu begründen, die nicht den Launen eines Königs unterworfen ist. Die selbsterklärten Originalisten, wir hatten das ja mal mit Josh Hawley thematisiert, des Gerichts haben in einer perversen Verdrehung der Geschichte und der Verfassung, die sie angeblich verehren, entschieden, eine Krone in Trumps Reichweite zu platzieren, in der Hoffnung, dass er sie sich im November greift.
Genau, das ist genau der Tenor. Und jetzt hören wir das mal in den amerikanischen großen journalistischen Häusern, die das nämlich alle durchweg richtig gemacht haben. wirklich erstaunlich. Vorher noch ein kleiner Snippet. Ich hatte eine Mail bekommen vom Deutschlandfunk, Sascha Wandhöfer macht irgendwie einen Podcast, der heißt Nachredaktionsschluss. Und ein Hörer, Hendrik, hat sich dort gemeldet und gesagt, lieber Deutschlandfunk, ich habe irgendwie so im Aufwarn-Podcast einen Neuen Zwanziger gehört. Da steckt mehr dahinter, hinter diesem Urteil. Warum bei euch nicht? Also haben sie eine Sendung gestaltet und mich dann auch angefragt, ob ich dazu komme, zusammen mit zwei Korrespondenten, der eine Los Angeles Times-Korrespondent in Deutschland jahrelang und noch jemand. Und dann läuft es ungefähr so ab. Man kriegt so eine Mail, erklärt sich bereit, die so, ah gut, wir haben alle eine Gäste in der Tasche, ist ja cool. Es ist 15.40 Uhr, gestern 15.40 Uhr. Ich gehe also 15.35 Uhr online, weil ich denke, ich bin ja höflich. Ich kann ja schon mal mit dem Techniker gucken und so, ob hier und so weiter. Ich stelle dann fest, es war ganz gut, pünktlich online zu gehen, weil die machen das mit Sessionlink. Also erstmal Google Chrome runterladen. Also wir reden jetzt darüber, ob wir die Demokratie retten, indem wir uns erstmal Google-Software runterladen müssen, weil das Gespräch sonst nicht stattfinden kann. Ich habe das schon runtergeladen, war dann 15.40 Uhr online. Hendrik, da höre ich auch. Dings kirschbaum oder wie er heißt, auch. Aber niemand vom Deutschlandfunk. 15.42 Uhr meldet sich dann der Deutschlandfunk, ja, da können wir ja losfangen und so. Und ich so, ja, okay. Dann der Techniker, ich höre noch irgendwo einen Hall. wir so, auf welcher Leitung denn? Leitung drei. Wer ist denn Leitung drei? Keine Ahnung. Dann sagt jeder mal was, damit man rausfindet, wer ist denn Leitung drei? Stellt sich raus, ich war Leitung drei. Ich hatte natürlich alles schon auf Neuen Zwanziger umgebaut in der Podcast-Technik und habe gesagt, kein Problem. Ich habe ja noch ein paar andere Computer und ein paar andere Mikrofone. Ich baue einfach schnell um. Stellt sich raus, dieses Sessionlink-Ding einmal aufgerufen, geht mit gleichem Namen irgendwie nicht unter einer anderen Session auf einem anderen Computer. Also der Link geht dann einfach nicht. Oder irgendwas klappt mit dieser Verbindung nicht. Ich habe einfach nur gesehen, ich bin jetzt verbunden mit dem Deutschlandfunk, aber die haben mich nicht gesehen, wie auch immer. So, ich also zu dem Techniker, ja, ich kann jetzt ein Bild checken. Hier steht, ich bin verbunden, ich sehe auch meine Ausschläge, ich sehe auch ihre. Schalten sie mich einfach in die Sendung. Er so, keine Ahnung, oder so, dann ruft er Wandhöfer an, bei seiner Technik, der stellt das auf laut, sodass ich es dann über Banden mithöre, und er so, nee, wir müssen jetzt anfangen. Und ich so, wie anfangen, ich bin ja nicht in der Sendung. Ja, wir müssen jetzt anfangen.
Und das war keine Live-Sendung?
Nein, das war eine Aufzeichnung für in drei Tagen oder so. Völlig bescheuert, kann ich auch meine Technik, also meine Aufnahme schicken, oder was auch immer, können sie jetzt danach zusammenbauen. Naja, jedenfalls war der dann so im Zeitstress plötzlich, nachdem er selber zu spät in dieser Leitung war und nichts eingeplant hatte für, wir machen hier noch mal kurz einen Technik-Check. Ich hab schon gehört, dass der Köschbaum so per Telefon irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wie er sich da eingeschaltet hatte. Naja, dann sag ich zu dem Techniker, ja, geben sie bitte weiter, ich komm nicht mittendrin in die Sendung. Entweder wir warten, bis das hier hinklappt oder nicht. Kann ja nicht in einer Sendung teilnehmen, die alle Hörer schon gehört haben bis Minute 17. Und dann komm ich plötzlich rein und frage, worüber haben sie jetzt geredet die ganze Zeit? Ist ja totaler Quatsch. Woraufhin ich nur noch höre, dass der Redakteur dem Techniker sagte, wir fangen jetzt an. Und der Techniker zu mir, haben sie das jetzt gehört? Und ich so, ja, die fangen jetzt an. Und das war's. Ach ja. Da hab ich gedacht, hm, okay. Dann fangt ihr mal an. Dann hab ich mich aufgelegt und hab aufgelegt. Und hab weiter unseren Podcast vorbereitet. Und es könnte auch sein.
So machen wir das hier.
Ja, es könnte auch sein, dass die deutschen Journalisten mit diesen Themen einfach nicht richtig klarkommen, weil ihre Gesprächspartner von ihrer Technik nicht ordentlich betreut werden oder weil man die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Google Silicon Valley Technik runterladen muss, damit es überhaupt erstmal funktioniert. Und ich halte das für nicht akzeptabel. Und ich reagiere jetzt auch, also ich höre jetzt anders, wenn im Deutschlandfunk Politik Podcast Stefan Dettin dann sagt, ja, dann finden wir hier auch mal ein Ende, weil du Grundelado, musst ja jetzt noch schnell einen Beitrag machen und wie auch immer. Und ich sag, nee, Leute, kommt mal alle runter, nehmt euch mal Zeit. Ein Podcast kann auch mal über 30 Minuten gehen, verhandelt die Themen ordentlich, lest vielleicht noch mal eine Zeitung, nehmt das mit der Technik nicht so ernst. Wenn eure Deutschlandfunk Technik richtig funktioniert, nehmt einfach Zoom. Da kann jeder Channel einzeln aufgenommen werden. Das kriegt man danach als Download. Dann kann man den Podcast zusammenbauen, wie auch immer. Aber dieser Stress, nee, wir müssen jetzt anfangen. wir müssen jetzt anfangen. Der Techniker macht das schon. Also es war sehr augenöffnend, würde ich mal so sagen. Das ist kein, also so kriegt man keine Inhalte auf die Spur. Selbst wenn das danach geklappt hätte irgendwie, hätten sich erstmal alle wieder fünf Minuten beruhigen müssen. Du hast dann einen Hörer, der Deutschlandfunk, sagt dann, ja hier, dann kommen sie doch zu uns in die Sendung. Diese Leute sind üblicherweise auch den ganzen Tag vorher aufgeregt, bevor sie dann das erste Mal mit Deutschlandfunk und so und so weiter quatschen. Und da ist es sich so von dieser Technik da irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Nee, also wenn das in dem Google-Bruise-Altern nicht läuft und so, dann ist das irgendwie total bescheuert. Also wirklich super nervig, es war ärgerlich, es ärgert mich ohne Ende. Ich will nicht Objekt in so einer Medienarbeit sein. Ich möchte dir gerne sagen, was ich sagen möchte, ich möchte dir gerne, dass wir die Zeit dafür haben.
Ja, ich dachte sonst immer, du warst beim Radio ja unkompliziert.
wir haben jetzt hier drei Stunden 30 schon aufgenommen und fangen jetzt an, geruhsam über den amerikanischen Wahlkampf zu reden. Und zwar, liebe deutsche Journalisten, nehmt euch ein Beispiel an den amerikanischen Kollegen.
Ja, also ich komme natürlich immer gerne ins Radio oder zu anderen Sachen. Aber natürlich, du weißt, was jetzt kommt, nur gegen Honorar.
Glaubst du, irgendwer hätte mir da einen Honorar angeboten?
Also ich frage nach.
Danke, dass Sie bereit sind. 15.40 Uhr geht es los. Ach so, es geht später los und es wird auch nicht klappen. Und Honorar, da haben wir nicht mehr drüber geredet.
Nein, nein, also ich bin natürlich immer nur gegen Honorar. Ich arbeite nicht gratis.
Ja, ich arbeite absolut auch nicht mehr gratis.
Also ich muss ja nicht im Öffentlich-Recht, da sind ja Gelder vorhanden, warum soll ich da gratis arbeiten?
Ja, ich fand es halt einfach so, die Gelegenheit war gut, weil ich bin ja eh jetzt vorbereitet durch die Clips, die wir jetzt heute hören. Und wenn den Hörer, und das finde ich ja wirklich, also Applaus dafür, beim Deutschlandfunk anrufen, sagen, ich habe das im Podcast ein bisschen anders gehört und die wirklich dazu bringen, also wahrscheinlich so ein Hörerkommentar zu schreiben, dass sie motiviert sind, ja, dann sollten wir das mal aufgreifen. Sehr gut, also lieber Hendricks, tut mir sehr leid, dass es dann doch nicht geklappt hat. Gut, wir hatten das Wall Street Journal, nicht unbedingt verdächtig, irgendwie halbgare, handlange Verschwörungstheorien und so zu produzieren, wir steigen sanft ein, danach hören wir The Daily. wir sind hier am Tag des Urteils. Leute haben sich vorbereitet. Sie haben gelesen, um was es geht und reden dann so darüber.
Eine der Dinge, die mir in Justice Sotomayor's Abfall anstehen, ist, dass sie sagt, dass unter der Regelung der Präsident nun die Navis SEAL Team 6 für einen politischen Rival zu assassinieren und noch immun sein kann.
Wenn man die Mehrheit liest, wie sie sich ausgesetzt wird, ja, das scheint die zentralen offiziellen Pflichten des Präsidenten unter der Regelung zu sein. Einer von ihnen ist der Chef der Armwaffen. Also, SEAL Team 6 ist Teil der Armwaffen. Wenn der Präsident SEAL Team 6 bestätigt hat, etwas zu tun, dann ist das ein offizieller Akt.
Ja, so ein kleiner Snippet. Die diskutieren das so in diesem Maße aus, aber sie sprechen es halt an. Ja. Das kann man immer noch, ich bin mir unsicher, aber ja, das klingt irgendwie, also wenn man das zusammenbaut, die Puzzleteile, dann heißt das ja, da ist so ein SEAL Team 6 und das kennen wir ja, das hat ja oder sagen wir mal Melan getötet und das könnte man genauso beauftragen, einen politischen Rivalen im Inland zu beseitigen. Ja, es läuft jetzt ohne Official Contact. Das ist Amtsführung. Und damit ist das doch irgendwie. Und wir haben auch gehört, ahja, das Urteil besteht also aus 6 Richter entscheiden etwas, sind die Mehrheit, dann gibt es aber noch 3 Richter, die haben was zur Einwände. Und die schreiben die dann auch mit in den Urteilstext. Gehört also zu dem Dokument des Urteils. Das ist aber ein Minderheitenvotum. Also lauter solche Sachen kann man ja dann durchaus mal erfahren und hören hier die New York Times. Also ein Podcast, von dem ich einfach unterstelle, alle deutschen Journalisten, die sich mit Politik befassen, hören den, aber irgendwie nicht so richtig zu. Also das war der Tenor, der erste Podcast, der gemacht wurde, natürlich zu diesem Thema.
Ja, und lasst mich super spezifisch sein, denn als dieses Fall bis zum Supreme Court auf der Wege gekommen ist, ist die Hypothetik, die immer wieder von einem Präsidenten, der mit seiner oder seiner öffentlichen Verantwortung vielleicht die Führung einer politischen Rivalkommunikation bestätigt und dann klagt, dass er das politische Recht hat, denn als Präsident habe ich die Macht über die Militärer.
Die Mehrheit hat nicht mit diesem präzisen Szenario zu tun. Aber die Logik ist, dass, wenn es ein Teil der Präsidenten-Offizie ist, dann ist er der Kommandant und der Chef, der Hauptverwaltungsvorsitzende. Und wenn es eine plausibel Applikation seiner öffentlichen Verantwortung ist, dann ja, er wäre immun, sogar für Dinge, die so wild sind, wie eine Versuchung für eine Assassination.
Hm, also diese Immunität ist völlig einzigartig und einzigartig von dem, was die Motivation des Präsidenten ist, in eine offizielle Aktie zu nehmen, die ordinalerweise als kriminal und verabschiedet werden könnte.
Also Michael, Chief Justice Roberts antwortet in so vielen Worten die Frage, die er gefragt hat. Er sagt, in der Beteiligung der Offizie aus unoffiziellen Tätigkeiten.
Gibt es keine politischen Auseinandersetzungen im Sinne von, es findet ja noch eine Wahl statt. Also erschießen wir einfach den Kandidaten der gegnerischen Partei stattfindet. Kommt es nur darauf an, ob er da irgendeinen Handlanger privat bezahlt hat oder ob das ein offizieller Akt der Amtsführung war, er also, soweit die Polizei ihm da untersteht, oder das Militär beauftragt hat. Und dass das so deutlich gesagt wird und nicht hier ankommt in Deutschland, von dem ich immer noch denke, das ist doch eine wahnsinnig interessante, selbst wenn man jetzt nicht mal ein paar Semester oder Seminare Geschichte in der Uni oder irgendwas, allein so ein Interesse für einen Historienfilm oder so, rechtfertigt doch hier zu sagen, Momentchen mal, ich weiß, da findet gerade ein Wahlkampf statt, aber das scheint mir auch ein Thema zu sein. Das finde ich wirklich haarsträubend, das ist wirklich unglaublich. Und ich finde es crazy, wie weit das Wall Street Journal und die New York Times das sofort aufgreifen und so thematisieren, ohne Deutschland einfach gar nichts dazu.
Ja, Sonja Sotomayor, die Richterin mit einem abweichenden Votum, sagt auch Folgendes, dass die von der Mehrheit definierte Trennlinie zwischen offizielem und nichtoffizielem Verhalten, das als nichtoffiziell betrachtete Verhalten, fast so weit verengt, dass nichts übrig bleibt. Das heißt also, diese Trennlinie, die da gemacht wird, die gibt es in dem Sinne überhaupt nicht.
Amtszeit ist Amtszeit und damit ist alles, wie auch in Deutschland gesagt wurde von Hebe Streit, der Kanzler ist immer im Dienst. Gibt keinen privaten Kanzler. Der Kanzler ist im Dienst, er ist gewählt. Aus diesen Minderheitenvoten wird dann hier auch vorgelesen, zum Beispiel bei PBS. Das sind jetzt zugegebenerweise keine Nachrichten, die jetzt ganz Amerika, aber sie sind zumindest flächendeckend, weil das ja auf diese ganzen lokalen Sender da gestreut wird.
Sie sagte hier in ihren eigenen Wörtern, wenn er seine offiziellen Forderungen in irgendeiner Weise unter der Mehrheit herrscht, wird er nun von krimineller Prostitution insoliert, bestätigt, dass die NATO den Team Seel 6 um einen politischen Rival zu assassinieren, immun, organisiert einen militärischen Wettbewerb, um sich an die Macht zu halten.
Wie auch mit Gästen. Das sind alles Sendungen, die ploppen dann alle so auf. Man sieht die so, man kriegt echt so ein bisschen Nervenkitzel, weil man hat ja wirklich noch so, keine Ahnung, die letzten Seminare zum dunklen Mittelalter, das ja gar nicht so dunkel war, sondern da war ja im Grunde politisches Geschehen nur halt ein bisschen anders. Und dann denken wir so, sind wir echt da wieder angekommen? Also wird wieder zu Hofe Intrigen geschmiedet und dann findet eine große Feier statt, einfach nur, um Leute da zu haben, um die dann abmurkseln zu können, während sie wieder abreißen.
Ich bin sehr froh, dass du das sagst. Du warst ja eben etwas abwehrend gegenüber diesen vielen Orban-Clips, die ich euch zugemutet habe. Aber sehen wir nicht genau diese Bewegung dahin?
Ja.
Also ich will das ja auch nur konstatieren. Ich sage ja nicht, Mensch, das ist aber schön, dass wir da wieder angekommen sind.
wir sind da wieder, wo wir schon mal waren. Also es ist tatsächlich nicht...
Ja, in veränderter Form natürlich. Die Geschichte wiederholt sich dann nicht ganz.
Aber heute Atomwaffen.
Es ist ein Interregnum gewesen der liberalen Demokratien. Und jetzt ist die Frage, was ist noch zu retten? Und was muss man dann noch fahren lassen?
Also es geht drunter und drüber.
So, the concern going in was the hypothetical of the Court of Appeals, which was SEAL Team 6. What if the President orders the assassination of his political...
wir haben übrigens, ich erinnere mich noch dran, Clips davon gespielt, weil die New York Times hat das schon mal diskutiert, dass nämlich der Supreme Court bei oder andere Gerichte, die sich damit befasst hatten, schon mal bei Aussprachen, Informationssammelnd für die Richter, das Szenario beschrieben bekamen von den Demokraten-Anwälten, dass dieses Szenario hier mitverhandelt wird. Und wir haben das noch gespielt und haben gedacht, naja, die wollten die nur schocken. Stellt sich heraus, ne, die wollten die nicht nur schocken, sondern das Gericht hat genau in diesem Sinne dann entschieden.
Wie sind sie erhältlich? Kann ich dir noch ein Beispiel geben, das nicht ein Hörer sein wird, ist jemand, der Präsident sagt, der Vizepräsident, ich will, dass du eine bogische Prostitution gegen meinen politischen Gegner bringst. Also nicht Tod, sondern Prostitution. Diese Entscheidung sagt, Kommunikation zwischen dem Präsidenten und dem Vizepräsidenten sind absolut immun.
Du kannst ihn nicht als Zeichen bringen.
Sie sind absolut immun und du kannst es nicht als Zeichen benutzen.
Ja, das ist ja das Szenario, Trump ruft irgendwo in der Bundesstadt an und sagt, findet mir 15.000 Votes. Dann sagt der Typ, der da verantwortlich ist, ne, das widerspricht ja meiner lokalen Gesetzeslage. Dann sagt der amerikanische Präsident, zu seinem Justizminister, finde mir Wege, diesen Typ zu verurteilen, egal was.
Ja.
Denkt dir was aus. So, also es geht ja nicht nur bei dieser Immunitätsfrage darum, ist er jetzt zu Mord ermächtigt, sondern alle möglichen Sachen. Der amerikanische Präsident steht jetzt über der Verfassungsordnung, damit über dem Gesetz. Und mit über ist halt nicht nur jenseits, sondern über gemeint. Er hat Weisungsbefugnis für diese Apparate, die ihm dann unterstehen.
Und ich mein, wenn man sich ein bisschen die Geschichte der republikanischen Partei ansieht, dann gab es ja immer die Bestrebungen, die Machtfülle des Präsidenten zu erweitern. Adam McKay hat ja in seinem Film über Dick Cheney das sehr deutlich gemacht, wie Dick Cheney eigentlich diese Idee, diese Interpretation der Verfassung immer ganz hoch gehalten hat und dann versucht hat, für George W. Bush Junior dies auch immer weiter voranzubringen. Und diese Ausweitung der präsidialen Macht hin, dann bis zu dem letzten Schritt, dass man ihn eigentlich fast zum König krönt, hat also eine gewisse Geschichte, woran es aber immer dann doch scheiterte, war, dass man nicht so die Gerichte besetzt hatte, wie man das jetzt geschafft hat. Und war wahrscheinlich auch, das würde ich doch zumindest einigen Republikanern unterstellen, gewisses Kruppel derart weitzugehen. Also das war ja jetzt nicht die reine Lehre aller Republikaner, diese Machtfülle unendlich zu erweitern. Aber dennoch war es angelegt und nun hat man dort einen ganz, ganz entscheidenden Schritt gemacht.
Genau, wir hören jetzt gleich nochmal aus Donald Trumps eigene Munde, wie er dieses Gefüge dann sieht, wer da auf wessen Seite steht. Die Immunitätsfragen werden hier thematisch noch so ein bisschen eröffnet. Es ist also nicht nur der Konkurrentenmord. Das wird auch zitiert vom obersten Gerichtshof. Die sagen, das liegt jetzt irgendwie um so eine geladene Waffe.
Die USA ist die stärkste Person im Land und möglicherweise der Welt. Wenn er seine offiziellen Forderungen in irgendeinem Fall unter der Mehrheit hervorheben, wird er nun von krimineller Prostitution insoliert, bestätigt den NATO-Siegel Team 6, um einen politischen Rival zu assassinieren, immun, organisiert einen militärischen Kuh, um den Machtzug zu halten, immun.
Und die Diskussion wird hier auch geführt mit wirklich martialischen Worten. wir hören es erst noch ein bisschen sanfter in diesem Gespräch mit Katie Kuh.
Ich habe die ganze Meinung selbst durchgesucht und wie ich am Anfang gesagt habe, fühlte sich kreuzbar in den Argumenten, dass die Konstitution, die die Mehrheit betrifft, beinhaltet, es sagt nicht so in der Konstitution, aber sie betrifft, es beinhaltet, dass ein Präsident die Immunität haben muss, energetisch zu sein und Entscheidungen zu machen, dass er es braucht, um den Job der Präsidentschaft zu machen, und dass du es nicht fragen kannst.
Wie plötzlich 43 Präsidenten konnten sich benehmen und dann einer nicht. Das hat man für ihn jetzt dieses links geschrieben.
Spinnen wir das nochmal ein ganz klein bisschen weiter. Was heißt denn das eigentlich? Es ist naheliegend, das mit einer Monarchie zu vergleichen, mit einem König, der gekrönt wird und der dann diese unendliche Macht hat. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass wir es ja trotzdem mit jemandem zu tun haben, der gewählt wird. Also Könige wurden in der Vergangenheit nie gewählt. Das heißt, das Volk musste sie ertragen. Nun wissen wir auch, dass Trump da durchaus flexibel ist und darüber nachdenkt, die Amtszeiten zu verlängern. Bei ihm wird wahrscheinlich das biologische Ende die Amtszeit dann beenden. Er wird jetzt nicht 20 Jahre im Amt sein können, aber wir erleben ja doch in der Welt immer mehr Staaten, in denen es zwar Wahlen gibt, aber die wir nicht als demokratisch bezeichnen. wir können an Russland denken und Orban tut auch alles um sich. Dem möglichst anzuklassen oder hat er schon sehr weit getrieben, dass er in diese Nähe kommt. Und das ist aber schon interessant. Also es gibt noch so eine Rückbindung an einen Wähler. Da muss mit allen Manipulationen dann versucht werden, diese Wählerstimmen wieder zu bekommen. Aber es muss noch diese Art der Rückkopplung da sein, die ja auch Trump als das ansieht, womit er immer wieder auftrumpfen kann, dass er die Stimme des Volkes spricht. Das heißt, wir haben eine ganz interessante Konstellation eigentlich, dass man jetzt durch die Urteile in eine Richtung geht, die nach Monarchie aussieht. Und sogleich gibt es aber noch diese Illusion von Demokratie und Wahl.
Oder nicht mehr.
Oder nicht mehr?
Putin veranstaltet zumindest noch Wahlen.
Ja.
Mandurro auch.
Ob Trump das noch macht, ist unklar. wir hören gleich Sing-Sang von ihm selbst. Es gab ja einen Clip, der die letzten Tage durch Twitter ging.
Ich will es mal so sagen, wenn ich autoritärer Führer wäre, würde ich auch Wahlen veranstalten, weil das doch sehr gut ist, immer wieder Partizipationen zumindest zu spielen. Das sorgt für nicht allzu große Unruhen. Also sagen wir so, richtige Diktaturen, in denen es gar keine Wahlen mehr gibt, sind sehr fragil. Solange du immer noch so eine Partizipation spielst, funktioniert es eigentlich geschmeidiger.
Ich fand es auch witzig, dass sich nach der Geschichte, in der sich alle darüber lustig machten, dass die sozialistischen Führer immer 99,8 Prozent bekommen und so, Manduru sich jetzt 51 Prozent hat geben lassen von der Wahlkommission. Also sieht man schon, okay, Zugeständnisse. Ja, die autokratischen Führer veranstalten nicht ohne Grund Wahlen. Die Frage ist halt bei Donald Trump, wenn du 78 bist, dann 79, dann mit 82. Warum noch mal eine Wahl veranstalten? Dann doch lieber durchziehen. Sollen doch die anderen das kommentieren. Die Frage in Amerika ist ja auch immer, wer soll sie denn veranstalten? Das ist ja nicht wie in Deutschland, dass du so alle drei Meter ein Wahllokal hast und dann muss man einfach nur sagen, morgen ist Wahl und dann wird das sozusagen aktiviert über die lokalen Behörden, sondern du kannst es ja wirklich abbauen. Du kannst ja wirklich die Infrastruktur zurückfahren und es ist ja alles schon ein Wahlcomputer. Also Personen stehen da, keine große, musst du die Wahlcomputer nicht mehr aus dem Lager holen und schon kannst du keine Wahl veranstalten. Oder halt dir einen Bundesstaat, einen Bundesstaat raussuchen, wo es total strittig ist, was da passiert. Und dann dauert es halt sieben Monate, bis das ausgezählt und geklärt und am Ende sagt der Supreme Court, Bush hat gewonnen. Also in der Hinsicht, da ist alles offen. Aber bevor wir uns dieser Frage noch mal nähern zu dieser Geschichte, die ich so interessant finde, warum jetzt dieses wir brauchen einen energetischen Präsidenten, der juristisch unbekümmert bleibt, weil sie fragt ja schon, Presidenten haben doch das Justizministerium, Anwälte on-site, die können sich doch einfach beratschlagen lassen, was geht denn jetzt hier nicht und was kann ich tun? Und da werden die sagen, sie können ganz schön viel tun. Eine Million Menschen im Irak töten oder was auch immer. Warum jetzt dieser Shift?
Runnig for office again, Donald Trump.
So, you know, at the oral argument, there was a lot of discussion about essentially a policy debate that seemed to be going on, where you had the conservative justices saying they're worried about the Department of Justice and prosecutors and grand jurors going after presidents, one after the other. That that's the thing that they're worried about. And you had Justice Jackson and others saying.
Die Freiheit hatten die Präsidenten eigentlich bisher.
Das ist das wichtige, was ich hier nur lesen möchte. Das ist von der Desenntätung von Katantin Brown Jackson, Justice Jackson. Mit der Erwähnung eines Paradigms, das manchmal den Präsidenten von den Diktaten der Struktur ausbricht, wenn der Struktur so sagt, hat der Struktur effektiv von der Legislatur die Öffentlichkeit, den Präsidenten oder nicht zu den Mandaten der Kanzlerin zu binden.
John Roberts sagte heute, dass er und seine fünf lieben Leonhard-Leo-Appointeure die Präsidenten entscheiden werden.
Ja, kurzer Stopp hier, was auch bedeutet, wenn Kamala Harris gewinnt und irgendein Gericht befindet, da hat sie aber und so weiter, da steht ja keine Immunität zu, dann wird der Supreme Court sagen, ja genau, ihr nicht. Weil die nämlich das letzte Wort darüber haben, haben sie sich halt mit reingeschrieben. Jolie hat dann auch so ein kleines Snippet.
Ist ein Trump-Gerücht.
Absolut. Sie beschreibt es dann auch so in diesem Gespräch, wo sie sagt, Sie haben ja alle Game of Thrones gesehen, da gibt es einen König und ein Hand of the King. Und dieser stellt immer sicher, dass der König diesen freiraum hat. Und dieses Gericht hat nun Trump zum König deklariert und sich selber zum Hand of the King. Das heißt, wenn Trump irgendwas gefährlich wird, wie eine demokratische Präsidentschaft oder so, dann sagen die einfach, nee, hier ist gar nichts immun. wir befinden, Gerichte sollten schon mal vorsortieren, aber wir machen die letzte Entscheidung und sagen dann einfach, was ist hier Amtshandlung und was nicht. Dann wird das alles aussortiert. Bei Trump wird alles unter diesem neuen Diktum lauten. Und jetzt beschreibt sie aber kurz, was konnten amerikanische Präsidenten bisher zeigen an Amtshandlungen, ohne juristisch gefährdet zu sein? Und dann sagt sie, wo ist die MyBrit Innersendung zu so einem Fall? Also das ist doch wirklich unglaublich, was hier gerade vor uns abläuft. So, jetzt zu dieser Frage. Würde es nach der Präsidentschaftswahl 2024 nochmal Wahlen geben? Rachel Maddow hat es in ihren Sendungen gesagt, sie betont sie immer wieder und ist dann auch da wirklich anklagend. In einem Podcast mit Chaoswisher on, sagt sie so einen ganz kurzen Satz, also wenn 2024 Trump gewinnt und er 2028 noch gesund und am Leben ist, wird es keine Präsidentschaftswahlen geben. Und das finde ich für so eine Art Klaus Kleber-Figur, die so über eine Bundestagswahl spricht. Also das ist einfach ein Marker in der Diskussion. Die muss man einfach aufgreifen. Ich verstehe nicht, wo sind die Leitartikel und überhaupt. Gut, wird es also noch mal eine Wahl geben. Trump hat jetzt vor wenigen Tagen beim The Believers Summit vor lauter Christen so Sprüche gemacht mit, geht doch noch einmal wählen. Danach haben wir das alles gefixt und dann ist es fein. Ihr müsst nur noch einmal wählen. Danach müsst ihr nicht mehr wählen, nur noch einmal. Und dann gab es auf Twitter Diskussionen, auch von Niggemeyer und so angeführt. Wie hat er das denn gemeint? Denn ja, der Tino und der Rede ist auch, liebe Christen, sagt dann Trump, ihr geht immer nicht wählen. Eure Wahlbeteiligung ist viel zu gering. Geht doch mal wählen. Geht wenigstens dieses eine Mal wählen. Danach müsst ihr es auch nicht wieder. So, das ist die, sagen wir mal, wohlwollende Auslegung dieser Worte.
Ja, das Versprechen wäre dann, diese Dinge, die für euch geregelt werden müssen, werde ich dann regeln. Und deshalb braucht ihr ein nächstes Mal nicht mehr zu wählen.
Genau. Und ich würde jetzt aber sagen, nachdem sich herausgestellt hatte, dass die Justices des Supreme Court wirkliche Originalisten und Textualisten sind, wir hatten das an Josh Hawley besprochen, also die den Text der Verfassung ernst nehmen, wie wir sagen heute wollen, denn es steht da so nicht drin. Eigentlich hat man den König damit abgeschafft und nicht ermächtigt. Aber solange Originalisten und Textualisten so mit der Verfassung und dem Text umgehen, würde ich sagen, gehen wir mal ganz originalistisch und textualistisch mit Donald Trump um und hören uns an, was er wirklich sagt. Nicht im Kontext von eine wohlwollende Auslegung oder so, sondern was sagt er? Und in dieser Rede beim Believer-Summit, ich habe jetzt vier Ausschnitte in einen Ausschnitt gepackt. Also diese vier Leuchttürme, um die es geht, oder es sind drei Leuchttürme, er sagt zweimal dieses, ihr müsst nur noch einmal wählen. Er bindet jetzt hier das Supreme Court-Urteil mit diesem Spruch, ihr müsst nicht mehr wählen gehen danach zusammen. Und da würde ich mal sagen, das ist der Kontext. Der Kontext ist nicht, dass die Christen immer wenig wählen gehen und Trump sagt, er geht doch noch einmal wählen. Sondern wir hören es jetzt hier eine Minute 40. Ich würde sagen, wir nehmen das mal ernst.
Und zusammen werden wir November 5.
Also.
Also für mich ist die Sache relativ klar oder sagen wir relativ unklar und das ist ja sehr typisch für Trump. Erst mal.
Also für mich ist es total klar.
Zunächst mal stellt sich ja wie bei Orbán die Frage gut, die reden irgendwas, sie reden mit gespaltene Zunge. Was soll gemeint sein? Aber das Trump hier alle Richter noch einmal nennt, ihn gratuliert zu dieser sehr weisen Entscheidung. Ja, er sich mit ihnen aber schon in eins setzt, ist doch eine für ihn beachtlich klare Aussage, worauf es hinaus will. Dann haben wir den Bezug zum Ronald Reagan. Ronald Reagan war ja nicht nur Christ, sondern auch ein sehr eigenartiger Ausleger der Verfassung. Schon deshalb, weil er glaubte, dass die Gründerväter der USA, da diese Verfassung ja auch gar nicht alleine geschrieben haben, sondern ihnen ein Engel begegnet ist. Das hat er auch so gesagt.
Trump ist auch ein Engel begegnet, als die Frane da oben über ihm so verschlungen war.
Da hat er das Buch damals von Bruno Marquez gelegt. Und da geht er sogar darauf ein, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, dass Reagan, also so ein ganz religiöses Verhältnis zu USA hat, im Sinne von da hat sich ein Engel mitgeteilt und dann hat George Washington und weiß nicht, wer noch alles dabei war bei dieser kleinen Epiphanie, gesagt, prima, das schreiben wir alles noch mit rein in die Verfassung. Das heißt, wir haben es hier mit einem klaren Rückbezug dazu zu tun, und damit ist es sehr logisch, dass er zwar hier nicht explizit sagt, ich werde die Wahlen abschaffen, dass er hier aber sehr deutlich macht, na ja, wenn ich der Präsident bin, dann bin ich wieder Heiland. Und so wird er ja sowieso von vielen jetzt verehrt, seitdem er die Satentat überlebt hat. Dass in diese Richtung geht die Argumentation. Also ich glaube nicht, dass, also man kann ja über Kontexte reden, aber ich habe nicht den Eindruck, ich habe mir auch den längeren Ausdruck da angesehen, ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass hier nur die Ansage an die Christen ist, ihr habt da ein paar Probleme, die erledige ich und dann braucht ihr mich nicht mehr mit. Was ja auch keinen Sinn ergibt. Also wenn man ja zum Beispiel, würde er ja, wenn er die Christen adressieren will, diese sehr religiösen Leute, besonders damit abholen können, dass man ein sehr verschärftes Abtreibungsrecht hat, beziehungsweise Abtreibungen grundsätzlich untersagt sind. Das kann er dann fixen in seiner Sicht. Nur muss ja dann der Christ wieder wählen. Denn sollte dann ein demokratischer Präsident kommen nach Trump, würde der ja vermutlich das Abtreibungsrecht wieder stärker liberalisieren. Das heißt, man kann nicht sagen, ich habe einmal gewählt und dann ist es für immer gut. Es sei denn, es gibt keine Wahlen mehr danach.
Ja, also für mich ist diese Gemengelage hier ziemlich deutlich inzwischen. wir müssen nicht auf die Wahl von 2028 warten. Schon 2024 wird hier eine Torpedierung stattfinden. Trump hat eine riesige Apparatur. Es haben dann sogar Leute aus seinem Wahlkampfteam gefragt, sollten wir die Ressourcen nicht lieber anders einsetzen. Und Trump, nein, ich möchte, dass in jedem Wahllokal jemand von uns steht und diese Wahl begutachtet. Das ist schon mal eine ernsthafte Bedrohungslage, weil wir wissen ja nicht, ob da jemand steht, der nur beobachtet oder noch mal drei Freunde mitbringt und ganz genau guckt, wie die Leute da wählen, damit doch alles mit rechten Dingen zugeht. Außerdem, diese Heritage Foundation und das alles da im Hintergrund, das hat jetzt Jahrzehnte Anlauf genommen und sie wissen, dieses ekrale Bild ist jetzt nicht verkehrt, Trump ist ihr Heiland. Niemand funktioniert vor dem Wählerpublikum so wie er. Man sieht ja schon, dass nur eine Schulter weiter steht in JD. Vance, der gar nicht funktioniert. Weder in der Rede, noch im politischen Programm, noch sonst irgendwas. Also Fail auf aller Linie.
Na, noch nicht. Ich halte das durchaus möglich, dass der...
Okay, also du kannst auch Hoffnung haben, aber Trump ist, was seine mediale Rezeptionsfähigkeit angeht. Also, dass da noch was passiert. Trump ist eine Jahrhundertfigur.
Ja.
Den hat man nicht nochmal. Die müssen den jetzt ausbeuten und sie legen alles rein, was sie reinlegen können.
Nur sind diejenigen, die danach kommen, auch nicht auf der Seite von Wahlen. Also wir haben das Buch von Peter Thiel gelesen und wir können uns denken, dass das alles Leute sind aus diesem, ja, wie nennen die sich? Darken, Lightenent und wir hatten auch mal übrigens eine ausführliche Folge über diese ganzen, die dort sich in New York versammeln und die jetzt so diese dunkle Seite verkörpern. Das sind auch alles Leute, die durchaus bereit werden, noch mal darüber nachzudenken, ob die Demokratie eigentlich so eine tolle Sache ist.
Ja, aber wir können in diesem Falle und ich nenne jetzt einen Namen, weil ich wirklich möchte, dass die Dramatik und die Extremität darin verstanden wird. Ja, sehr viele Leute halten öffentliche Reden, sehr viele Leute sind durchgeknallt wie Donald Trump. Man kann auch sagen, sehr viele Leute singen, aber nur Taylor Swift schafft es 70.000 Leute für 1000 Euro am Abend und dann nochmal 50.000, die sich auf diesen Olympiaberg stellen. Trump ist eine Jahrhundertfigur, weil er die Wähler erreicht. Wie alle anderen nicht. Man braucht aber, man muss die Wähler erreichen.
Was ich nur damit sagen wollte, ist, wenn Trump jetzt wirklich keine Wahlen mehr macht, erst seit seiner zweiten Amtszeit, dann sind die, die nach ihm kommen aus der republikanischen Partei, also im Lager JD. Vance, Peter Thiel, durchaus auch bereit, diesen undemokratischen Kurs weiter zu fahren. Das sind keine Leute, die dann sagen, und jetzt erneuern wir hier unsere Demokratie.
Wenn Trump jetzt gewählt wird, ist das ein dynastisches Gefüge. Nur mit dem, ich werbe ja dafür, aus der Geburtenfolge auszubrechen. Er wird dann aus der Geburtenfolge ausbrechen. Er wird dann ernennen, wer als nächstes dies anbricht.
Vielleicht Barron.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Oder halt jenseits der Geburtenfolge. Ja, ja, genau. Nur diese Szenerie, dass man dann irgendwie so ein... Nee, aber die werden ja Widerstand haben, die Leute. Amerika ist ja ein großes, das kann sich ja wehren und so. Ja, klar kann sich das wehren. Aber wenn die ganze Regierung von diesen Leuten besetzt ist, kannst du anrufen, wo du willst. Du erreichst nur Trump-Leute. Da ist niemand mehr, der dann aber da nochmal und so das irgendwie wieder gerade biegt, sondern nein. Das ist glaube ich, es ist immer wieder interessant, wenn man heute über vergangene Zeit spricht, alte Kaiser, Napoleon und so, dann kommt die Frage, aber wieso sind die Leute dem so gefolgt? Und dann kann man sagen, die sind dem nicht gefolgt. Das war einfach der Kaiser, so wie heute der Kanzler. Da wurde gewählt, da hatte der Leute hinter sich, da hatte die Hoheit über dieses Militär und dann wurde er halt regiert.
Aber der Kaiser wurde ja nicht gewählt.
Sehr viele Kaiser, gerade hier in Frankfurt am Main, wir sind ja nun die Kaiserwahlstätte. Man hat einen kleinen Kreis von 200 Fürstenfamilien und die wählen sich halt einen König.
Okay, aber das ist eine sehr elitäre Wahl. Man hat nicht die Bürger wählen lassen.
Jaja, genau. Aber wir sehen das ja auch in China. Dort finden auch aus dem Politbüro heraus nicht nur Intrigen und Mordes statt. Die sagen dann auch mal Hand hoch, wer ist jetzt dafür? Und wählen die halt jemanden. Nicht demokratische Wahl, sondern Wahl im kleinen Kreise. Da wird erstmal der Hof abgeschottet und dann findet da halt irgendeine Zeremonie statt oder so. Und es gibt gar keinen Grund zu glauben, dass wir heute durch irgendetwas geschützt sind von diesen Zuständen. Also man wird sich in 200 Jahren genauso fragen, wieso sind die alle dem Trump gefolgt damals und so? So wie wir uns fragen, wieso war Napoleon so erfolgreich? Na ja, weil das formale Gefüge war halt so. Und dann zogen die halt in Krieg und haben Länder erobert. Und so ist Geschichtsschreibung. Wie wird das jetzt in Deutschland diskutiert?
Ja, aber es ist ja genau das, was ich eben auch demonstrieren wollte mit Orbán. Das ist Geschichtsschreibung, die stattfindet. Also wir können das alles kritisch sehen und sollten es auch tun, aber das ist die Geschichtsschreibung, die stattfindet.
Fällt mir trotzdem schwer, Orbán zuzuhören, wie er sagt, also die Philosophie des Krieges sagt, da geht es um Leben und Tod und nicht um was weiß ich. So, wir hören nun mal einen ganz kleinen Auszug, wie das hier so in Deutschland diskutiert wird.
Du willst eigentlich gar nicht, dass Orbán das Wort Philosophie in den Mund nimmt.
Ja, es ist so. Apokalypse und Filtercafé am 2.
Juli.
Also die erste Sendung, nachdem das passiert ist. wir hören Markus feldenkirchen und Jasmin M. Barek. Clip erschöpft sich relativ zügig.
Gott sei Dank.
Auch pikant in dem Kontext, bevor ich dich frage, wen du da so siehst. Trump errang jetzt gestern einen Teil sich bei der Immunitätsfrage vor dem Supreme Court. Das heißt, für offizielle Amtshandlungen gilt auch bei ihm Immunität. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Anders gefragt. Unser Experte Markus feldenkirchen. Wer sollte Kandidat werden und Demokraten im November retten?
Also da gab es so ein kleines Teilsiegding und er hat jetzt auch Immunität. Also wer soll denn jetzt Kandidat werden?
Ja, aber bei offiziellen Handlungen, sagst du, das ist ja der reine Irrsinn.
Die Frage ist ja, wer soll denn jetzt Kandidat werden? Die deutsche Debatte, wir hören viel den News von Sascha Lobo und seiner Frau.
Es gäbe ja eine Figur, wo du gerade gesagt hast, dann sind alle zerstritten und das ist wirklich ein Szenario. Ja, es gäbe ja eine Figur, wenn man sie aufstellen würde auf dem Parteitag der Demokraten, dann hätte sie eine Riesenchance.
Die einzige eigentlich.
Ja, die einzige.
Ja, where should I start?
Michelle Obama.
Ich habe den Podcast begonnen mit, ich sehe amerikanisches YouTube und freue mich darüber. Ich freue mich damit, ich kriege da positive Emotionen. Es ist geile Unterhaltung, da wird das mal auf der Augenhöhe gemacht, wie das gemacht werden sollte. Dann höre ich deutsche Podcasts. In denen wird noch mal Michelle Obama als der große, das Land einigende Kandidat vorgestellt wird.
Ja und in den Tagesthemen das Lachen der Kamala Harris.
Also wirklich, das ist so jenseits von allem. Das muss man gar nicht kommentieren. Abgesehen davon, Michelle Obama wollte nicht mal, dass Barack Obama zu der zweiten Amtszeit antritt. Wo kann der Glaube herkommen, dass sie das... Ich glaube, dass sie es möchte, dass sie es mit Inbrunst macht, dass das ganze Land dahinter steht. Ich meine, wir haben seit 1978 nur Bushs, Clintons und Obamas auf diesem Zettel, den man wählen kann. Und jetzt nochmal ein Obama, das ist die Hoffnungs-, also das ist wirklich jenseits von einem. Aber gut, das Attentat, was soll man dazu sagen? Es ist irre.
Pass auf, ich hab was Lustiges.
Ich bin halt jetzt zum Attentat. Also Lustiges hab ich auch.
Was habe ich als erstes gedacht, als ich das kam, also ich kam von einem Abend wieder, der, also wir haben eine Flasche geleert und dann kam ich also zurück, hatte noch den Laptop an, wollte ihn nicht ausmachen, sah aber dann gerade bei Twitter, oh was denn da passiert. Und in diesem Moment, nicht ganz nüchtern, erinnerte ich mich, dass Peter Sloterdijk noch mal so ein Szenario skizziert hat. Und dann habe ich gedacht, ja, musst du morgen noch mal dran denken. Dann habe ich es rausgesucht. November 2016 schreibt Peter Sloterdijk in der Zeit. Die wirkliche Frage der kommenden Tage wird also nicht sein, wie man den widerstehlichen Aufstieg eines politischen Ehrliches verhindert, sondern was man ab jetzt tun sollte, um die Zeit danach zu gestalten. Seien wir realistisch. Die Chance von Donald Trump, die ersten zwei Jahre seiner Amtszeit zu überleben, liegt vermutlich bei kaum mehr als zehn Prozent. In einem Land mit einer so ausgeprägten Tradition des Schießens auf Präsidenten wäre ein mehr als zweijähriges Durchhalten eine Anomalie. Sofern der politische Mord eine Kategorie ist, die über das Gegebensein oder Nicht-Gegebensein einer Demokratie entscheidet, so waren die USA nie mehr als eine hypothetische Demokratie. Das Schießen auf Präsidenten blieb in diesem Land immer eine aktive Option. Wenn das Second Amendment von 1791 das Waffentragen zum Bürgerrecht erklärte, aus europäischer Sicht ein Kapitalverbrechen gegen den Geist der Verfassung, so konnte das überdehnte Notwehrrecht auch vor den Trägern der Staatsgewalt nicht Halt machen. Es gibt kein Land in der Welt, in dem die Idee der Legal Defense so breit in den kollektiven Empfindungen verankert ist.
Ja, Jay DeVance steht auf der Bühne und jubelt über seine Oma, die 19 Waffen in ihrem Haus versteckt hatte, damit sie sich immer verzei- diken kann. Alle jubeln zu. mir kommt es auch nicht in den Kopf, wie man hier einfach sagen kann, ja, wir haben dieses Selbstverteidigungsrecht und Waffen, aber wenn auf Trump geschossen wird, geht das nicht. Das ist ganz schlimm, weil das ist doch irgendwie, das liegt doch echt in der Natur der Sache irgendwie.
In gewisser Weise schon. wir müssen jetzt hier deutlich unterstreichen, dass wir nicht aufrufen zum Morde an Trump.
wir sind ja hier nur Zuschauer.
Obwohl wir keinen RWB-Podcast haben, den wir verlieren könnten. Aber das war ja dann die andere große El-Hotso-Debatte. Die machen wir aber jetzt hier nicht auf, oder?
El-Hotso hat geschrieben, ich liebe es, wenn Faschisten sterben.
Ja.
So wie ich das verstehe in diesem deutschen Diskurs, die letzten 75 Jahre, 80, sagen das relativ viele Leute. Niemand würde jetzt sagen, ach, dass der Hitler damals gestorben ist, ist ja echt blöd. So ein guter Faschist. Also diese Todeswünsche, gerade 20. April, nee, nicht 20. April, sondern Staufenberg-Attentat, das war doch auch kürzlich. Genau. So, da wird es hoch und runter diskutiert.
Entschuldigung mal, wir haben in Glorious Busters, wo man sich daran ergötzt, dass die Nazis zur Strecke bringen. Jetzt ist dann die Frage, also ich will mir das auch nicht zu eigen machen, diese Argumentation, das ist doch nicht meine Art von Humor.
Nein, ich will nur sagen, El Hotso hat nicht geschrieben, Trump soll sterben, sondern der Satz, der solitär für sich dann steht, ist einfach, ich liebe es, wenn Faschisten sterben. Dass er vorher auch über Trump gesprochen hat.
Ja, er hat das schon miteinander gekoppelt. Also was er ja gemacht hat, war ja dieser Tweet zu sagen, leider verpasst heute den Bus und Trump und die Kugel ist an Trumps Kopf vorbeigang. Und damit hat er eine poahnte Gesetz, über die man diskutieren kann, ob sie geschmackvoll ist oder nicht. Und hat dann nochmal so gesagt, dass er da sich freut, wenn Faschisten sterben. All das bedeutet natürlich, also fasse ich Trump als Faschisten auf, das tun einige. Ich glaube, dass der Begriff Faschismus da nicht so weit führt. Also es gibt Faschist-Widow-Tendenzen. Ich glaube, der Begriff führt nicht so weit. Was ich aber doch deutlich sagen will, ist, dass er nicht zum Mord aufgerufen hat. Also dass es etwas völlig anderes ist. Und was ich dann beobachtet habe in sehr vielen Podcasts und in Artikeln und Diskussionen darüber, ist, dass wir ganz interessante Verhältnisse haben, wenn wir unterscheiden müssen zwischen subjektiver und objektiver Gewalt. Ich will ein ganz simples Beispiel bringen. Wenn Leute im Podcast sagen, die Ukraine müssen jetzt weiter kämpfen, impliziert das ja natürlich, dass ganz viele weitere Leute sterben.
Sie sollen ja weiter kämpfen im Sinne von andere Menschen töten.
Wenn man sagt, das Leiden in Gaza ist schlimm, aber es hilft nichts, Israel muss weiter so vorgehen. Keine Sanktionierung. Ich gehe noch einen Schritt weiter. Wenn man als konservativer Politiker in einer Talkshow sitzt und sagt, wir müssen Frontex stärker ausbauen und wir müssen mit aller Härte gegen illegale Migration vorgehen, kein Problem. Das bedeutet aber, es ersaufen Menschen im Meer oder werden dahin zurückgebracht, dass sie dort ersaufen. Das ist aber alles nur objektive Gewalt. Wenn ich in einer Talkshow sitze und sage, man müsste Politiker XY-Ohrfeigen, Ohrruf zu Gewalt, da brauche ich noch gar nicht beim Mord zu sein. Und das ist interessant, dass wir, also ich finde gut, dass wir jetzt nicht Leute ständig animieren zum Morden oder was weiß ich. Nur ich will sagen, es gibt eine interessante Differenz zwischen subjektiver und objektiver Arbeit. Und so ist es mir aufgefallen im Podcast, die sagen, weiter muss der Krieg gegen die Ukraine, Gaza, ja, ist halt so. Aber jetzt mit höchster Sensibilität, mit wahnsinnig viel philosophischem Brüstzeug wird darüber gesprochen, warum man jemanden nicht den Tod wünschen sollte, etc. Und das finde ich interessant, dass man jetzt plötzlich das heilige einzelne Leben plötzlich da so sieht. Und ich finde, diese moralische Debatte kann man auch durchaus führen. Nur bei den anderen Sachen sagt man, naja, ist halt Krieg.
Also ich finde es insbesondere verworren, weil wir gerade gelernt haben, dass die schießende Auseinandersetzung in einem amerikanischen Wahlkampf jetzt höchst richterlich erlaubt wurde, dass selbst Beweise, die diese Fälle dann betreffen würden, verboten sind vor Gericht einzusetzen, dass das Motiv des Schießenden nicht hinterfragt werden darf. Und dann darf man keinen Witz darüber machen, dass der, auf den dieses Gesetz abzielt, in einem Land, in dem sich seine Partei seit Jahrhunderten dafür ausspricht, dass wirklich jeder bewaffnet ist.
Also ich finde, dass man immer Witze darüber machen kann. Das will ich auch nochmal hier ganz deutlich machen, dass Witze darüber erlaubt sind und dann ist es auch erlaubt, die geschmacklos zu finden oder nicht. Aber ich will ganz deutlich sagen, das ist ja gerade das Verrückte, dass jemand wie Elon Musk permanent auf Twitter menschenfeindliche Positionen teilt. In ganz aggressiver Weise, dann aber im Falle von El Hotso, getriggert dadurch von irgendeiner rechten Influencerin, den Bundeskanzler anschreibt öffentlich auf Twitter, was ist denn hier eigentlich los? Finanziert ihr mit Steuern Geldern jemanden, der zum Mord an Trump aufruft? Und dann der RBB auch noch einknickt und sagt, den entlassen wir jetzt. Und dann gab es ja noch ein anderes Gespräch im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, das durfte auch nicht mit El Hotso geführt werden, dass man so weit geht. Da muss ich sagen, das ist ja Cancel Culture in reinster Form und zeigt ja auch, dass diese ganzen anderen, die immer von der Wogen-Cancel-Wahl-Culture waren, hier absolut dabei sind, wenn jemand irgendwie seinen Job verlieren könnte.
Finde ich auch, finde ich auch. Das Einzige, was man machen kann, ist Humorkritik, denn es gibt halt bessere Witze zum Thema, JD Vance hat Sex mit einem Sofa und so. Darauf sollte man sich dann beziehen. Apropos Elon Musk. Pete Sousa, also Obamas Haus- und Hoffotograf, der ihn acht Jahre lang im Weißen Haus minütlich begleitet hat, immer, er war immer dabei, egal wo, im Ausland, überall. Der kennt sich sehr gut aus mit Fotos. Deswegen hat ihn Obama ausgewählt und er weiß, ohne erschrocken, man muss hier einfach alles und man kann alle Fotos hinterfragen. Er fragte also auf Twitter, schaut euch mal dieses AP-Foto an, und dann schaut euch genau sein Ohr an, dass Hit, in Anführungszeichen, getroffen wurde. Ach, schreibt er, ja? Ja. Woraufhin er gesperrt wurde. Denn Mr. Free Speech Arena, Elon Musk, deswegen hat er Twitter gekauft, damit dort endlich wieder alles gesagt werden darf, möchte solche Diskussion nicht haben. Selbst die Bild hat jetzt diese Fotos aufgegriffen. Trumps Ohr sieht gut aus, seine Umfragewerte nicht. Selbst die umschiffen das Thema nicht so ganz. Ich finde dieses, auch die Überschrift, alles wieder in Ordnung. Die Frage mit dem Ohr wird bleiben. Und liebe Hörer, keine Angst vor Verschwörungstheorien. Diese Republikaner, die jetzt wissen, dass Trump ihre Jahrhundertfigur ist und damit ihr Vehikel in diese Machtposition, die sie jetzt schon bereitet haben über das Supreme Court-Urteil, sind zu allem bereit. Damit meine ich nicht, dass auf Trump nicht geschossen wurde. Aber zumindest bei diesen Inszenierungsfragen, die stattfanden, bei dem Ausmaß des Schadens, das wir sehen und so weiter, es gibt durchaus ein paar Fragen, die darf man auch stellen. Die Anlaufstelle dafür ist die New York Times. Die kümmert sich rührend um diesen Fall. Sie ist mit Drohnen darüber geflogen, hat alles in 3D nachgebaut. Also die kümmert sich wirklich darum, was da passiert ist. Die Frage ist dann auch organisational, warum ist 100 Meter jenseits des Präsidenten schon Region der lokalen Polizei und nicht mehr des Secret Service? Also da gibt es durchaus ein paar Fragen, die merkwürdig sind. Sehr witzig fand ich Mark Zuckerberg zum Attentat, denn das müssen wir danach auch nochmal. Ich will dieses Thema überall anders beschreiben. Donald Trump kriegt diesen Schuss, merkt, irgendwas ist mit mir, ich gehe mal in Deckung, dann weiß er, es stürzen sich Leute auf ihn, die ihn beschützen. Die warten auf den Zuruf. Okay, das ist ausgeschaltet. wir können Trump evakuieren. Dieses kleine Szenerie-Ding hat ungefähr 40 Sekunden gedauert. Trump weiß also, der Zuruf kam gerade, keine Gefahr mehr. Es geht jetzt nur noch um einen Abtransport. Ich stehe auf und inszeniere mich.
Na, was er immer tut.
So, genau. Zum einen würde ich sagen, es ist jetzt mal ganz wichtig zu verstehen, ob man jetzt auf die Rede drei Tage nach dem Attentat oder auf die Geste 40 Sekunden danach wartet, ist egal. Er ist so durchtrieben.
Nein, aber das ist ja, also ich würde schon sagen, unter rein performativen Gesichtspunkten ist Trump, und du hast ihn ja als Jahrhunderttalent beschrieben, derjenige, der in genau einer solchen Situation bereit ist, alles für die Show zu geben.
Aber jetzt gilt die Frage für deutsche Journalisten. Jemand, der das kann, der dazu bereit ist, das zu machen, zu was ist er noch allem bereit? Ja, und die Antwort lautet, zu allem. wir können uns nicht vorstellen, was Donald Trump bereit ist und seine Hinterleute, um diese Präsidentschaft zu erregen. Umso mehr werbe ich dafür, ja, es ist ein bisschen verdrucks, dass wir das so auf irgendwelche Personen zuschneiden, dieses ganze Ding, diese großen Schicksalsfragen und uns dann die ganze Zeit fragen, ja, ist er dann inhaltlich richtig aufgestellt? Nein, Inhalte spielen jetzt keine Rolle mehr. Auch im Vorgriff auf Unhaltbarkeit, im Rückgriff auf Selk, ja, es gab mal Theorien zur Demokratie und diese Demokratien waren durchseucht mit Moral hier, Inhalte da, Programme da, was auch immer. Demokratie ist das Ringen um Macht. Alles andere ist sekundär. Das Sekundäre heißt sekundär, weil es austauschbar ist. Eins ist nicht austauschbar. Es ist ein Wettkampf um die Macht. Alles, was Macht vergrößert, ist hier in den Blick zu nehmen. Alles, was Macht verringert, ist auch in den Blick zu nehmen, weil es dann sozusagen aufs Minuskonto kann er die Wahl gewinnen oder nicht, wenn er sich im Horserace einzahlt. Aber bei der Frage, wie kann der Weg zur Macht aussehen? Ich weiß, wir haben die letzten Jahrzehnte politische Diskussionen, Debatten, Diskussionen, alles vorbei. Diese Machtfrage, wie Niklas Luhmann sie beschrieben hat, ist jetzt wirklich ernst zu nehmen. wir können jetzt sagen, diese Soziologie hatte Recht. Die Machtfrage, dieser Code, ist primär. Alles andere findet auf der Programmebene statt. Die einen versuchen es mit Debatte und Argument, die anderen versuchen es mit, was weiß ich für Inszenierung. So, und so muss man das jetzt auch betrachten. Man muss jetzt auf der Augenhöhe mit dem Moment, mit dem Augenblick sein. Diese nächsten Monate bis zum November werden, ich will es nicht zu dramatisch sagen, aber das Staufenberg-Attentat hatten wir schon, das Ermächtigungsgesetz hatten wir schon. Was noch fehlt, ist der Reichstagsbrand. Hier gibt es noch große Aktionen. Oktober Surprise hieß das immer, als es noch die üblichen Zeiten waren. Jetzt muss man sich auf alles einstellen. Das wird hier wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr gefährlich, die nächsten vier Monate. Und ja, man wird sich jetzt noch bis 7. August mit der Frage beschäftigen, ist ein Astronaut der richtige Vizepräsidentschaftskandidat und so. Aber hier, finde ich, sollte man die Sachen ernst nehmen und...
Das heißt, du plädierst für Show, für die beste Performance. Darauf muss man sich konzentrieren, um die Macht zu...
Ja, Peter Kümmel hieß er, glaube ich, der ehemalige Zeittheaterkritiker und so weiter. Der hat damals den Wahlkampf von Schröder gegen Stoiber nach seinen Kriterien ausgewertet.
Theater.
Harald Schmidt, genau, hat das gelesen in der Sendung, weil er es herausragend fand. Und ich würde sagen, da steckt auch eine Logik drin. Klar brauchen wir jetzt Theaterkritiken für das, was da stattfindet und kein politischen Journalismus im Alte-Ehr gebracht sind.
Nein, wir brauchen, nein, Moment. Also ich glaube, man muss noch mal unterscheiden zwischen einem analytischen Journalismus, den man braucht. Und wir lesen ja dann hier gern die Journalisten, die uns aufklären darüber, was meint eigentlich dieses Urteil in Bezug auf Trumps Machtfülle. Das heißt, das braucht es ja weiterhin. Was nur jetzt strategisch zu tun ist, von Seiten der Demokraten oder generell, wenn wir über Parteien reden, wir haben ja schon mal über die Linke und deren Keitungsstil gesprochen. Da muss man glaube ich diese Performance-Strategien beherzigen und kann nicht sagen, ja wir wünschen uns aber irgendwas, es wäre doch besser, wenn da so und so jemand wäre. Man muss sich schon die Frage stellen, wer funktioniert. Ich weiß nicht, ob Kamala Harris am Ende funktioniert. Das wird sich dann zeigen. Ich glaube aber schon, dass es, wenn man einen Konkurrenten wie Trump hat, die richtige Frage ist, die man sich zu stellen hat. Im Prinzip ja auch in Bezug zum Beispiel auf die AfD. Wenn man da jemanden hat wie Maximilian Krah, dann kommt man da nicht weiter, indem man einfach nur sagt, wir haben mal Bürgerrat zum bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen gemacht.
Absolut. Zu diesem Trump-Foto will ich außerdem noch eine Anmerkung von Vincent Heiges machen. World Press Photo Award Winner 2024. Er hat im Deutschlandfunk im Media Sres in der Sendung folgendes gesagt.
Ich mein, wer ist Donald Trump? Wer hat in allen letzten Jahren viel, viel Gewalt verherrlicht, den Sturmhofskapitol, Charlotsville, ich mein, das könnte jetzt ewig gehen. Und jetzt schafft er es auf einmal, sich als Opfer dieser Gewalt, die er eigentlich seiner Rhetorik erst sehr, sehr stark angefacht hat, darzustellen. Und deswegen finde ich die Entscheidung vom Time-Magazin sehr, sehr schwierig, es als Cover zu nehmen. Es gibt von diesem Moment auch noch andere Bilder. Zum Beispiel ein Bild von einem Reuters-Kollegen, Brandon McDonough, das ganz kurz nach den Geschüsse gefallen sind, entstanden sind. Und dort sieht man Trump zusammen gesunken, verbrechlich am Rednerpult und der Secret Service ihn stützen. Ja, das erzeugt eine ganz andere wirkung. Da sieht man, wohin Gewalt führt und was eigentlich die Folgen davon sind. Und mit diesem Bild inszeniert man Trump eigentlich als Widerstandskämpfer. Und vor allem, wenn man dann sich überlegt, wie Biden gerade dargestellt wird in der Öffentlichkeit, ist das für Trump jetzt einfach ein hektapu, sich so darzustellen.
Es ist schon so hilfreich und so weiterführend, wenn jetzt Texten der Journalisten, in dem Fall im Radio, sagen, wir fragen jemanden, der sich mit Bildern auskennt, was der jetzt dazu sagt. Der klar diesen Moment zwischen Ereignis und die ersten inszenatorischen Nachwehen markiert. Der nicht darauf reinfällt, dass sich da schon jemand inszeniert und das Bild deswegen natürlich attraktiver aussieht, sondern der sich fragt, was zeigt eigentlich das Bild? Und es gibt Bilder, wie Trump da zusammengesagt und blutend und was auch immer. Und die hätte man genauso zeigen können, sofern man sagt, und es ist ja auch noch eine Frage, die man zu hinterfragen ist, klar haben wir einen Chefredakteur, aber wenn jemand auf den Präsidenten schießt, übernimmt der die Rolle des Chefredakteurs und diktiert uns, was wir Berichterstatten, nämlich, dass es da einen Schützen gab und so weiter und so fort. Das sind ja auch alles Fragen, die man mal, braucht man überhaupt Bilder von solchen Ereignissen? Kann man nicht einfach sozusagen, klar das ist wirklich total irrational, wie ich das sage in diesem Zeitalter 2024, aber können die Journalisten manchmal auf Bilder auch verzichten?
Beziehungsweise kann man nicht auch ein aufgeklärtes Publikum sich heranzüchten. Heranzüchten, das bereit ist, ja, was kann man es ja kaum ausdrücken, das bereit ist, dieses Bild als Komposition zu würdigen, dann aber nicht alles andere noch damit zu verbinden. Also ich würde ja sagen, es ist schon ein ikonisches, geniales Bild. Und man kann jetzt sagen, diese Genialität an sich beeindruckt mich, ohne dass ich daraus Schlussfolgere. Und deshalb wähle ich Donald Trump. Ich empfehle sehr nochmal diesen Film Civil War, der wurde ja sehr verrissen von der Kritik völlig zu unrecht. Das ist ja eigentlich eine Philosophie über Fotografie, den perfekten Moment Kriegsfotografie. Welche Verantwortung hat der Fotograf? Und inwieweit ist der Fotograf immer kompliz? Ich empfehle wirklich, dass sehr sich jetzt mal unter genau diesem, oder sagen wir so, man muss eigentlich sich diesen Film ansehen und erst einmal weggehen davon, dass das irgendwas mit dem heutigen Amerika zu tun hat. Weil sonst kommt man in so einen direkten, ach ja, und das ist schon die Vision, wie das unter Trump werden wird. Das glaube ich jetzt eher nicht. Das ist auch nicht die Intention des Films, sondern es geht wirklich darum zu zeigen, wie Bilder funktionieren, wie die Macht von Bildern funktioniert. Es zeigt aber auch, wie ein Bürgerkrieg aussehen könnte.
Also unser Kumpel Olli ist ja auch Fotograf, Bürgermeister, Fotograf, Landtest, Ministerpräsidentinnen, Kandidaten, Fotograf. Der kennt sich wirklich aus mit Bildern. Und dieses Bild taucht auf. Und Olli meint auch, nee, das ist irgendwie, das ist ein zu perfektes Bild. Sagen wir mal so, nicht zu perfekt, sondern es ist einfach ein perfektes Bild. Und wenn die Fotografen sagen, das ist ein wirklich wahnsinnig perfektes Bild, heißt das, dann ist jetzt besonders intellektuelle Arbeit gefragt, was das bedeutet, wie es passieren kann und wie man damit umgeht. Was man dann sieht, ist ja selbst so ein großes, spontanes, zufälliges Ereignis wie ein Attentatsversuch. Kann innerhalb von wenigen Tagen schon wieder hinausgespielt wurden, obwohl doch die Dramaturgie Attentat, zwei Tage sieht man ihn nicht. Und der erste öffentliche Auftritt ist die Nominierungsrede beim Parteitag. Ist ja erstaunlich, ne? So, bei diesem Parteitag, den wir jetzt nicht groß thematisieren, außer dass wir vielleicht kurz 15 Sekunden Esra Klein hören, wie er einem New York Times-Kollegen nach erzählt, wie das da war.
The Republican Party held its convention in Milwaukee. My colleague Elias Isquith described it as a megachurched service held in a Vegas casino under the ever watchful gaze of a living god. And that felt about right to me.
Auf das Transkript dieses Textes kommen wir im Salon zurück. Nun hat Trump sich dort für JD. Vance entschieden, von dem wir inzwischen alle wissen, der hat Trump schon mal als Hitler bezeichnet.
Na ja, er hat sich die Frage gestellt, ob er der nächste Hitler sein könnte.
Das ist nämlich, von all diesen Zitaten ist dieses Frühe, was wir dann relativ zügig bekommen haben, und der wird ja nun wirklich kreuz und quer in Schuss genommen von seinen ehemaligen Freunden, die New York Times, wirklich Aufmachertexte, wie das da mit seiner damaligen Kommilitonen war und so. Gut, er hat also in dieser Facebook-Nachricht an einen Bekannten damals geschrieben. Ich schwanke zwischen der Ansicht, dass Trump ein zynisches Arschloch wie Nixon ist, das nicht so schlimm wäre, Klammer auf, und vielleicht sogar nützlich, Klammer zu, oder dass er Amerikas Hitler ist. Nun wissen wir, Amerikas Hitler ist er nicht. Weil es gibt nur einen Hitler, also diese Singularität wollen wir mal nicht in Frage stellen. Kann natürlich immer noch irgendwas Krasses passieren, aber Trump ist ja auch alter. Dieser Halbsatz in Klammern, es könnte sein, dass ein zynisches Arschloch und so weiter, vielleicht aber nützlich. Das ist ja der Gedankengang hinter Peter Thiel. Ich brauche hier nützliche Leute. Und in diesem Text von Jeff Kinne über Peter Thiel, das wir gelesen haben im Januar 21 oder Januar 22, in einer Januar-Ausgabe, war es ja so, dass da einige Namen genannt wurde, die Peter Thiel hofiert. Josh Hawley, Cruz aus Texas, das waren aber nur Protégés. JD Vance wird als Erweiterung von Thiel beschrieben in diesem Text.
Ja.
Also es ist wirklich eine eins zu eins Vererbung von Peter Thiels Denken in praktisches politisches Handeln über die Person JD Vance.
Berufliches Venture-Kapitalist, er ist jemand, der ganz eng in dieser Welt drin ist. Dieser Art des CEOs, also das sind ja auch nochmal andere Leute als jetzt Tim Cook.
Und er ist ein sehr guter Freund aus dem Zone-Kreis Trumps. wir wissen von Trump, dass er sich auch auf große Sachen nicht unbedingt vorbereitet. Er lässt sich ja einen Teleprompter hinstellen und weicht darüber mal ab und dann schliert er sich wieder ein. Meine Arbeitsthypothese ist, Trump hat Vance selber erst da kennengelernt, als man ihm eine Woche vorher gesagt hat, es wäre noch cool, den und guck mal hier, auch der Peter ist dafür und so.
Aber dafür ist JD. Vance schon wirklich zu populär. Also der ist ja...
Ja, aber die Auswahl als Vizip-Kandidat hat man Trump, glaube ich, eingedient, bevor Trump das selbst durchdacht hat. Und dann hat er ihn einfach da so hingestellt.
Ich bin mir da unsicher.
Ich glaube, da ist eine riesige Enttäuschung bei Trump drin.
Vance ist aber ein unglaublich berühmter Mann in den USA, dank seiner Hillbilly-Elegie.
Auch Scholz hat geweint, als er das Buch las. Alles, ich weiß. Aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass...
Und die mischen da schon sehr lange mit. Du hast vielleicht auch diesen Artikel in der Vanity fair gelesen.
Den bringe ich im Salon mit.
Ah, okay.
Aber als Zusammenfassung, weil da nämlich programmatisch drin steht. Was ist genau? Diesen Vanity fair-text habe ich dann dabei. Nun gut, also egal wie meine abzüge Bethese ist, Trump ärgert sich gerade sehr, dass er da nicht vorher ein bisschen mehr IQ draufgelegt hat. Also eigenen IQ, nicht Berater IQ. Denn ich glaube, er fühlt sich da ein bisschen ausgeliefert. Und JD. Vance funktioniert vor allem nicht auf der Ebene, auf der Trump weiß, dass man da funktionieren muss. Was bedeutet, dass sich gerade so Enttäuschung aufstaut bei der Frage, warum läuft es in der Kampagne nicht so richtig? Und dann wird Trump, er will niemanden unter den Bus werfen, das ihn mit beschädigt. Aber er will auch nicht, dass er als der Loser dasteht. Also muss ein Loser auserkören und es wird dann JD. Vance sein. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wann das passiert. Aber noch bevor Parteitag, Attentat, JD. Vance und so weiter, sitzt Kevin McCarthy bei Fox News und beschreibt dort im Grunde das Drehbuch, das heute den Demokraten unterstellt wird.
Ich denke, du wirst viele Leute in der demokratischen Partei sehen, die darüber reden. Aber was du wirklich zurücknehmen musst, ist, warum die Medien jetzt auf Präsident Biden wehren, weil sie diese ganze Zeit verliehen wurden. Ich habe vor mehr als einem Jahr von meinen persönlichen Interaktionen mit diesem Präsidenten gesprochen, dass er Probleme hatte. Und sie haben uns getroffen. Die Wall Street Journal hat eine in-depth-Story gemacht und sie haben uns getroffen, aufgrund meiner Reaktionen und.
Da musste ich kurz eine Nahtoderfahrung her, damit das passiert. Jetzt steht aber eine Frau, die ihrerseits als Running Mate nun wirklich all in einen weißen Mann höheren Alters nehmen kann. Was ja in Sachen von dem Vertrauen wir unter der Wählerschaft immer noch am meisten. Und wenn sie jetzt irgendwie Mark Kelly oder sowas nehmen, der ehemalige Astronaut und der ganze Kram, dann stehen die beiden wirklich ein bisschen im luftleeren Raum. Also die ganze Debatte, wie bisher geplant. wir argumentieren hier nicht zu direkt, aber zum Thema Alter. wir gehen hier so auf und so. Also die Vorschläge, wie Esra Klein jetzt diese Chance nutzen möchte, die finde ich wirklich krass klug und gut geschrieben. Das lesen wir dann im Salon. Ich will jetzt sozusagen, wenn wir schon bei Kevin McCarthy waren, bevor das passierte, er hat sozusagen das Playbook schon mal hingelegt. Ja, die lassen die da auflaufen, sich in Sicherheit wiegen. Wer den Parteitag gesehen hat, weiß auch, also das war sieges trunken. Ihr konntet sich gar nicht vorstellen, dass da noch mal was passiert. Und nun nach Parteitag, nach JD. Vance, nach Attentatsversuch hören wir Piers Morgan. wir kennen ihn alle noch. Er ist damals aus England rausgeflogen, weil er mit diesem Abhörskandal, illegales Telefon abhören der königlichen Familie und so weiter. Dann ist er in Amerika bei CNN angelandet, dort auch wieder rausgeflogen. Inzwischen arbeitet er für Murdoch bei irgendeinem dieser Sky News, Australia, irgendwas. Aber es ist natürlich in Amerika, kommentiert dort die Wahl. wir hören jetzt mal zwei Minuten 40, was mittlerweile im republikanisch Murdoch getriebenen Mainstream mit irgendwelchen Leuten, die da zugeschaltet werden und zwar Gästen, die man auch davor und danach immer wieder sieht. Also disqualifiziert sich jetzt niemand über das, was wir hören. Wie man so über die Sachen jetzt redet, aus der anderen Richtung, also nicht aus der euphorischen Richtung, wie dass ich jetzt sage, oh krass, endlich haben die mal einen Wahlkampf, wie es sein muss, sondern aus dieser, oh Gott, wir befürchten eine Niederlagewahlkampf.
Sie haben deliberate Lies gesagt. Sie haben gesagt, schwarz ist weiß. Sie haben gesagt, der Himmel ist blut, wenn er grün ist und so weiter. Sie haben letztendlich geschehen und geschehen. Aber sie sind glücklich, eine konspirationstheorie zu füllen, auch wenn es jemanden wie Two-Face Hypocris macht.
Also das hat Piers Morgan. wir wurden hier verraten. Die haben uns angelogen. Biden ist viel älter. Das war von langer Hand geplant, dass sie den austauschen und dann Kamala Harris, wenn wir nichts mehr dagegen tun können und so. Und jetzt kommt hier so ein Typ, der hat ein Angry patriot-t-shirt an und redet jetzt zu diesem Millionenpublikum, dass er dann Piers Morgan immer noch von Mörder organisiert bekommt.
Piers, nicht überrascht, wenn es um die Demokraten kommt. Lass uns ehrlich sein, Piers. Zumindest leben wir nicht in einem langweiligen Zeitpunkt. In den letzten zwei Wochen haben wir durch einen versuchten Kuh durch das Töten von Donald Trump geleistet. Sie haben versucht und nun einen echten Kuh von Joe Biden. Lass uns nicht entzwungen, Piers. Die Nacht des Debats, der letzte Präsidentialdebat, als die Welt Joe Biden sah, was er wirklich war, wurde ein Plan in Bewegung gelegt. Und das Plan war, Donald Trump zu verbreiten. Einfach und einfach. Das ist keine konpirizierung. Kim Cheadle kam gerade vor dem Parlament, Piers, bevor ich hier war, und sie sagte vor dem Parlament, und ich zähle, die Versuchung der Zerstörung des Ex-Präsidenten Donald Trump auf Juli 13 ist der größte zahlreiche Fehler des Geheimdienstes in den letzten Jahren. Sie sagt, Piers, ich lege mich um die orchestrativen Neugierungen. Du willst uns glauben, dass ein 20-jähriger Kind, kein soziales Medienpräsidenten, kein Kampffluss, auf einem Ruf geflogen ist, mit Kameras überall, dort lag und die Schuhe auf den Präsidenten getroffen hat? Gib mir einen Schnitt. Michelle Obama. Es wird Michelle Obama sein. Kamala hat keine Chance. Als sie 29 Jahre alt war, hatte sie eine Behandlung mit Willie Brown, die 60 Jahre alt war. Sie hat den Weg zu den Topen geschlafen. Sie hat keine Credibilität. All das, was sie tut, ist Lachen und Kacken. Sie ist die Bordesar. Sie ist nie zu der Borde. Es ist ein Scheiß-Show. Und Donald Trump. Gott ist Donald Trumps Worte zu sehen.
Aber das ist Sky Australia oder irgendwas.
Genau.
Und die haben ja nur noch solche Videos. Also die haben ja auch einfach 50 Videos gleich mal angefertigt von Kamala Harris Kackles. So nennen die das ja immer. Also Gackern, nicht Lachen, sondern Gackern.
Ich möchte eine Empfehlung aussprechen für eine Sendung von Piers Morgan. Ich werde sie nicht verlinken. Man muss sie selber so aussuchen, aber das ist nicht so schwer. Ich nenne die Person, die dort im Gespräch teilnimmt. Also Piers Morgan selbst. George Santos und Anthony Vina. Also Piers Morgan, George Santos, Anthony Vina diskutieren die amerikanische Wahl. Das wird noch lange aktuell bleiben. Ich will nur kurz vorstellen, wer das so ist. George Santos. 2022 für New York angetreten, um im Repräsentantenhaus Congressman zu werden. Erfolgreiche Wahl. Wahlkampf war sehr erfolgreich. Er hat nämlich Abschlüsse des Barros College und der New York University vorgewiesen. Außerdem Arbeitgeber Goldman Sachs von Citicoup. Was kann man dagegen haben? 750.000 Euro Jahresgehalt plus Dividenden bis 10 Millionen pro Jahr. Seine Familie Holocaust Überlebende. Seine Mutter am 11. September 2001 im World Trade Center gestorben oder dort mitverletzt und später an den Verletzungen gestorben. Außerdem hat er eine Friends of Pets United Organisation gegründet, die sich um kleine Haustiere kümmert. Er ist Mitproduzent des Spider-Man-Broadways-Musicals, selber Attentatsüberlebender und er hat auch schon mal einen gehirntumor. Sehr interessante Liste. Ist natürlich alles gelogen, weshalb er dann selbst von den Republikanern wieder aus dem Repräsentantenhaus rausgeschmissen wurde. Und heute 23 Anklagepunkte auf sich vereint. Diebstahl öffentlicher Gelder, Betrug, Geldwäsche, die Abgabe falscher Erklärung gegenüber der Wahlkommission. Fälschung von Unterlagen, Behinderung der Wahlkommission, Verschwörung gegen die USA und schwere Identitätsdiebstahl.
Das ist der eine.
Er ist gerade frei, weil sein Onkel ihm 500.000 Dollar, die er nicht hat, trotzdem beim Gericht geltend gemacht hat, im Sinne von ich bürge dafür. Also wenn er flüchtet, bin ich tot, so ungefähr. George Santos findet das natürlich alles eine Witchhand und hofft, dass er freigesprochen wird. Anthony Wiener, auch Congressman für New York, aber schon früher, 1999 bis 2011. Die Wikipedia schreibt, Anfang Juni 2011 wurde bekannt, dass Wiener über seinen Twitter-Account links zu freizügigen Bildern von sich an mehrere Frauen verschickt hatte, darunter am 27. Mai 2011 versehentlich ein Link zu einem Bild an seine 56.000 Follower. Hat natürlich auch für einige Aufmerksamkeit gesorgt, weshalb eine Wikipedia steht. US-Präsident Barack Obama erklärte am 14. Juni 2011 in einem Interview, er würde an Wieners Stelle zurücktreten. Für den Fall geht's weiter. Dass Donald Trump jr. seine Überlegung umsetzen sollte, als Bürgermeister New York City zu kandidieren, erklärte Wiener im Juli 2016, als der Präsidentschaftswahlkampf schon lief, möglicherweise gegen ihn anzutreten. Dazu kam es dann nicht, weil Donald Trump bisher Präsident geworden. Wie ist Donald Trump Präsident geworden? Ah ja, muss man nur weiterlesen. Im Endspurt des Präsidentschaftswahlkampfes im Herbst 2016 geriet ein Laptop Anthony Wieners in die Hände des FBI. Weil dieser auch von seiner Frau benutzt wurde und sich dort auch E-Mails mit Bezug zu Hillary Clinton befand, kündigte FBI-Chef James Corny überraschend an, die Untersuchung in der E-Mail-Affäre wiederzubeleben. Er war also damals verantwortlich dafür, dass dieses ganze Ding wieder hochgekocht ist. So, seine Frau ist Huma Abedin damals. Leute leben natürlich getrennt. Abedin war stellvertretende Stabschefin und persönliche Assistentin Clintons als US-Ausministerin bis 2013 und saß anschließend dem Übergangs-Team bei, also dieser Transition raus aus dem Amt, dann rein in die Kandidatur. Also wirklich haarsträubend. Aber in diesen kleinen Kammerspiel-artigen Gesprächen mit Anthony Wieder, George Santos und Piers Morgan kann man jetzt diesen Wahlkampf verfolgen. Ich würde sagen, ein bisschen weniger Tagesschau und so, ein bisschen mehr Piers Morgan, weil das ist wirklich...
Du willst Action.
Es ist Action. Es ist wirklich ganz, ganz große Action und macht auch viel, viel Spaß.
Dann sind wir eigentlich schon fast am Ende, beziehungsweise könnten wir noch ganz kurz etwas... Ja, lass uns noch einen letzten Clip spielen.
Ja, also meine Emotionen und KI. Super wichtiges Thema. Ich werde übermorgen in den Urlaub fahren. Ich werde nichts vorbereiten. Im August darf nichts passieren in der Weltgeschichte. Ich werde Ende August über dieses KI-Thema reden. Ich werde es nicht weiter verschieben, egal was kommt. Ich hoffe, es kommt einfach nichts. Ich will es nur schon mal ansagen, damit ich es dann nicht wieder verschiebe. Dann habe ich jetzt dieses KI- und Emotionen-Thema. Das ist wirklich wichtig.
Ja, dann bleiben wir doch mal bei dem Thema noch. Hören wir Gesine Lötsch. wir wissen, es gab jetzt eine Entscheidung vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, inwieweit diese Wahlrechtsreform gültig ist. Gesine Lötsch von der Linken freut sich, dass nun diese Grundmandatsregel erst einmal bestehen bleibt.
Als Sie heute Morgen wach geworden sind und die Meldungen gelesen haben, dass das wohl in Ihrem Sinne ausgeht, wie groß war der Stein, der Ihnen vom Herzen gefallen ist?
Also, das ist natürlich ein Teilerfolg für uns und für die Linke und die anderen klagenden Parteien. Aber man muss natürlich jetzt von der Ampel ganz deutliche Worte der Selbstkritik hören. Denn es wird immer gefordert, wir sollen die Demokratie verteidigen. Und dann wurde ein Gesetz durchgedrückt, was genau das Gegenteil als Ergebnis gehabt hätte. Und zwar, dass zwei Parteien, das war ja auch das erklärte Ziel, nämlich die CSU und die Linke, dem Bundestag nicht mehr angehören. Und das ist natürlich etwas, was demokratisch überhaupt nicht akzeptabel ist. Die Linke ist in 21 mit 2,3 Millionen Stimmen gewählt worden. Und die wären umsonst gewesen, hätte es die Grundmandatsregel nicht gegeben.
Nun ist es sicherlich übertrieben zu sagen, dass es das erklärte Ziel der Ampel gewesen sei.
Also war es vielleicht das Ziel, aber nicht das erklärte.
Linke, nicht das erklärte Linke aus dem Bundestag rausgegangen. Aber wir sehen natürlich bei der Problematik, die sich ergibt, wenn man sagt, wir müssen den Bundestag verkleinern. Wenn man dann eine solche Regelung davor nehmen will, dass es also nicht mehr mit direktmandaten gibt, dass man also zum Beispiel dann zwar nicht auf der Bundesebene die 5-Prozent-Hürde schafft, aber direkte Wahlkreise gewinnt, dass man dann trotzdem im Parlament vertreten ist. Davon profitieren die Linken und noch viel mehr die CSU.
Also 5-Prozent-Hürde oder drei Mandate. Ja, oder drei Mandate. Dann geht die Liste.
Und damit wäre möglicherweise auch die CSU rausgefallen. Also uns hätte die CSU quasi in allen Bundesländern antreten müssen, hätte da versuchen müssen, dann entsprechend die Stimmen zu bekommen. Und dass das eine problematische Regelung war, ist klar. Das wurde jetzt kassiert von Karlsruhe. Man kann viel darüber reden. Was man aber festhalten kann, ist, dass hier so eine Politisierung stattfindet, die eigentlich ja, aber eine Politisierung der Wahlordnung in einer Weise, wie wir das eigentlich aus den USA kennen. Weil sie ja jetzt hier sich äußert und ganz ehrlich hat sich auch die CSU geäußert, indem sie sagt, ja, das war eine Strategie der Ampel-Regierung uns zu verhindern und so weiter. Und da würde ich sagen, ist es schon problematisch, wenn man diese Politisierung vorantreibt, weil wir uns dann natürlich US-amerikanischen Verhältnissen annähern. wir hören jetzt noch aus dem Heinrich Böll-Podcast, Märkte, Mächte, Emissionen, Adam Toos, der über die USA spricht.
Es gibt eine Krise der Verfassung in Amerika. Institutionen werden zunehmend, genau wie du es aufgezählt hast, die Gerichte, die Beamten schafft sowieso, die wissenschaftliche Apparatur, also die Wissenschaft wird zunehmend von den Republikanern in Frage gestellt. Aber das als Krise der Demokratie aufzufassen, ist für mich etwas irreführend in dem Sinne, dass ich das als Effekt einer populistischen Demokratie lesen würde. Die amerikanische Politik ist ja nicht gewisserweise ein Verrat an einer sonst gesunden Gesellschaft. Es ist ja nicht eine Situation, sagen wir mal, von einer korrupten Elite. Ich meine, die amerikanische Elite bereichert sich, aber nicht in dieser simplen Form über die Politik, sondern die Politik, die wir und dieser Erosionsprozess, den wir beobachten, ist Ausdruck einer gesellschaftlichen Veränderung und geht sehr, sehr tief auf beiden Seiten.
Und der sagt auch?
Es ist also nicht so, dass es eine heile amerikanische Demokratie gebe, die dann irgendwie von Trump unterwandert wird, sondern die amerikanische Politik und die Erosion der Institutionen ist ein legitimer, wahrhafter Ausdruck eines zunehmend polarisierten, dysfunktionalen, zynischen, instrumentellen Ansatzes der amerikanischen Bevölkerung an sich in ihrer Welt und in ihrem Umgang. Ich meine, nehmen wir das klimapolitische Beispiel. Ich habe es ja eben angeführt, man kann mit dem Kongress ganz schlecht Klimapolitik machen. Obama hat es im ersten Anlauf gescheitert. Was haben sie in der zweiten Amtszeit gemacht? Sie machen über die Administration Klimapolitik. Das heißt, sie stellen alle administrativen Schrauben auf grün. Ohne Mehrheit zu haben. Also ohne, dass sich demokratische Legitimationen zu schaffen, verwenden sie die Staatsapparatur, um gezielt eine hochpolitische, in einem Amerika extrem kontroverse Politik durchzusetzen. Was ist die einzige Antwort darauf, die den Republikanern offen steht? Kannst nicht über den Kongress arbeiten, da wird das Thema nicht besprochen, sondern du gehst an die Gerichte. Du verwendest die Gerichte, um gegen eine administrative, nicht durch Mehrheiten gedeckte Politik Widerstand zu leisten.
Und dann nimmt das Ganze seinen Lauf.
Das ist das große Dilemma. Ich meine, Szenarioplanung im Sinne von nicht Planung, sondern was könnte man als Szenario planen? Das Einfallstor, um 250 Jahre amerikanische Demokratiegeschichte zu revidieren, ist, sechs Leute zu überzeugen, einen Text zu schreiben. Und wir wissen, dass die da wirklich korrupt sind. Das ist ja eins der großen Themen, weshalb Joe Biden jetzt auch sagt, wir müssen das mal reformieren. Erstens, Amtszeitbegrenzung auf 18 Jahre, was ich schon mal lächerlich finde. Also in Deutschland sind es 12 Jahre und das ist schon lang. Plus einen Ethikkode, den man auch wirklich durchsetzen kann. Das sind ja wirklich vormoderne Prinzipien, die da jetzt gerade gelten. In deren Sicht für eine Organisation, die mit 10.000 Mann Stärke und einem Budget von vielleicht 3 oder 4 Milliarden Dollar das amerikanische Politiksystem übernehmen möchte, für die ist doch das Einfallstor Supreme Court wirklich die einfachste Hürde, würde ich jetzt mal so sagen.
Aber es ist ein generelles Spiel, das gespielt wird, sagt Luz.
Und was geschieht als nächstes? Die Ernennung von Richterinnen wird politisiert, weil auf einmal alles davon abhängt, wer die Richterinnen ernennt. Und mittlerweile ist Amerika ein Flickenteppich an Federal Court circuits, die jeweils von verschiedenen Präsidenten ernannt worden sind. Und danach bestimmt sich, in welchem Teil Amerika welches Recht du bekommst. Der Prozess fängt an mit dem Versuch, der Demokraten progressive Politik unter Umgehung des Kongresses zu machen, weil sie dort keine Mehrheit haben. Ich sage das nicht als Kritik. Ich will nur beschreiben, wie dieser Prozess auf beiden Seiten läuft.
Umso wichtiger ist es, jetzt wirklich ernst zu nehmen und die Texte auch nochmal neu zu lesen. In der Politik geht es um Macht.
Ja, ja, aber wir sehen auch hier, dass damit, also man kann ja sagen und tu es tut, dass ja die Demokratie lebt.
Es geht nicht darum, demokratisch mächtige Position zu erringen, sondern es geht um Macht. Noch mal eine Stufe genereller. Ja, ja.
Wollen wir nochmal weiter?
Das heißt, der gesamte amerikanische Staatsapparat ist im Spiel. Nur ein Teil davon wird über Wahlen ablaufen. Und ein sehr großer Teil über einen inneren Kampf innerhalb der Staatsapparatur. Und das ist, um es klar zu sagen, auch in Deutschland der Fall.
wir beheben uns immer mehr in diese Richtung. Er sagt dann noch zu den Republikanern.
Demokratie in gewisser Weise lebt sie in brutaler und populistischer Form auf. Aber was daran zu Brüche geht, ist die Verfassung. Was daran zu Brüche geht, sind die Institutionen. Die Rechtsberater von Trump reden buchstäblich über Post-Constitutional Times.
Auch das ist interessant.
Wenn die Verfassung im Wege zur Macht steht, musst du sie beseitigen. Sobald du Mehrheiten dafür hast, und wenn du keine Mehrheiten dafür hast, machst du es trotzdem. Du musst halt unrevidierbare oder erstmal schwer revidierbare Zustände erwirken. Dieses Supreme Court-Urteil ist zum Beispiel eins, das ist nicht revidierbar. Also wie lange sollen die Prozesse jetzt, bis drei Richter gestorben sind und dann hoffentlich ein Demokrat die Nächsten ernennt. Also in 100 Jahren vielleicht eine Mehrheit für den Gegenentwurf.
Lass uns noch fünf Minuten machen, damit wir noch einmal die Klammer bekommen für Deutschland. Bundespressekonferenz, Marco Buschmann mit vielen anderen aus anderen Fraktionen. Worum ging es nun? Um das Bundesverfassungsgericht. Du hast schon gesagt, das ist doch so, dass es da eine Amtzeit für die Richter von 12 Jahren gibt. Ja, aber wo steht das? Wo ist das festgeschrieben? Könnte man nicht auch sagen, wir verringern die Amtszeit oder wir setzen die Pensionsgrenze runter, wie das in den Polen geschehen ist. Also die Frage ist, was ist eigentlich im Grundgesetz festgelegt? Und Marco Buschmann führt aus.
Heute ist ein guter Tag für die Verfassungsordnung und die demokratische Kultur in unserem Land. Denn eine ganz breite Allianz seriöser Demokraten, eine ganz breite Allianz von Parlamentariern zusammen mit dem Bundesminister der Justiz stellt eine Initiative vor, um das Bundesverfassungsgericht weiter zu stärken.
Und alle Fraktionen außer AfD haben sich getroffen und beratschlagt.
Nämlich als vor 75 Jahren das Grundgesetz in Kraft trat, war das Bundesverfassungsgericht ein Experiment. Das war etwas Neues. Ein solches Gericht mit einer solchen Machtfülle, nämlich der Machtfülle, auch Gesetze des demokratisch legitimierten Gesetzgebers zu kassieren, also aus der Welt zu schaffen, das gab es in Europa nicht. Dieses Experiment war die Lektion aus der bitteren Erfahrung der Weimarer Republik, dass nämlich das Mehrheitsprinzip alleine nicht sicherstellen kann, dass jede Mehrheit unter allen Umständen immer die Verfassung wahrt und insbesondere auch die Grundrechte der Menschen respektiert.
Ja, das haben wir ja an dem Verhalten der FDP gesehen. Die Mehrheiten waren da und dann gab es doch wieder eFuels.
Tja.
Deshalb war man zu der Überzeugung gelangt, ein solches Gericht zu benötigen. Und dass es ein Experiment war, merkte man daran, dass in der Verfassung, wenn man erstmal vergleicht mit den Regelungen über den Bundestag oder den Bundesrat, relativ wenig festgelegt war. Die meisten Regelungen hat man dem einfachen Gesetzgeber überlassen, weil man erstmal schauen wollte, wie sich das Experiment entwickelt. Das Experiment ist aber gelungen. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat in richterlicher Unabhängigkeit von seinen Kompetenzen Gebrauch gemacht. Es hat zum Gelingen unserer Verfassungsordnung unschätzbare Beiträge geleistet. Es ist ein Eckpfeiler unserer liberalen Demokratie geworden.
Also, sehr gute Performance. Ich will trotzdem mal ein bisschen kritisch dadurch, dass es der FDP-Mann ist. Wenn er jetzt sagt, ja damals hat man gesagt, der einfache Gesetzgeber im Sinne von der Bundestag und darüber gibt es aber den nicht einfachen, besseren, was auch immer, Verankerungen im Grundgesetz. Das Grundgesetz ist, wie Norbert Lammert immer so schön sagt jetzt, aufs Doppelte gewachsen, aber es ist nicht doppelt so gut geworden. Weil das Grundgesetz hat man ganz schön oft angefasst und die Frage hier muss man sich jetzt stellen, warum denn bei so einer zentralen Frage nicht? Da kommt eine Handschelle für den einfachen Gesetzgeber im Sinne von Schuldenbremse rein, kommen 100 Milliarden, Trump wünscht sich aber zwei Prozent rein, aber das kommt dann nicht rein bis hier hin.
Um das klar zu machen, Artikel 94 Grundgesetz lautet, das Bundesverfassungsgericht besteht aus Bundesrichtern und anderen Mitgliedern. Die Mitglieder des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes werden je zur Hälfte vom Bundestag und vom Bundesrat gewählt. Sie dürfen weder dem Bundestag, dem Bundesrat, der Bundesregierung noch entsprechenden Organen eines Landes angehören. Schön noch alles mit Dativ. Nun ist aber nicht hier zu lesen, etwas zur Amtszeit oder zum Beispiel zur erforderlichen Wahlmehrheit. Das heißt, man könnte das also anders...
Allerdings regeln andere Bundesgesetze, die nun auch nicht unterferner liefen, sondern halt...
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Also die kann, das kann man ändern mit entsprechenden Mehrheiten. Und darum haben die sich ja getroffen, dass das in... also es soll jetzt ins Grundgesetz rein, damit das nicht mehr irgendwo in der Schwebe hängt.
Ja, aber ich...
Also die machen ja ein konkreter Szenario aus. Es könnte jetzt so eine Regierung wie in Polen sein und die sagt...
Ja, aber ich finde, so in der Schwebe, es ist nicht in der Schwebe, sondern der Bundestag entscheidet mit einfacher Mehrheit darüber. 50 statt 66 Prozent. Das heißt, noch nicht Schwebe und es ist auch nicht der einfache Gesetzgeber, finde ich, auch wenn es vielleicht eine juristische Formulierung ist, sondern trotz dem man jetzt Ansinnen hat, das hier etwas besser abzusichern, ist der Bundestag immer noch die zentrale Einrichtung für politische Entscheidungen. Und nicht einfach der einfache Gesetzgeber oder oh, da wird es aber gefährlich, wenn wir das Null dem Bundestag überlassen.
Naja, man macht das ja schon aus Gründen. Also führen das mal noch weiter aus.
Und zu diesem gelungenen Experiment gehörte zweitens, dass die unterschiedlichsten Mehrheiten in unserem Land, die es ja gab, eines immer respektiert haben, nämlich auch dann, wenn einem eine Entscheidung nicht gefällt, nutzt man die Möglichkeiten des einfachen Gesetzgebers nicht dafür, um das Gericht dafür irgendwie zu sanktionieren oder um es an die kurze Leine zu legen. Dieses Erfolgsmodell Bundesverfassungsgericht war übrigens auch ein Exportschlager. Es ist eine wichtige Rechtsquelle für viele andere Verfassungsgerichte und viele andere Verfassungsgesetzgeber haben diese Institution auch übernommen, insbesondere unsere Nachbarstaaten in Mittel- und Osteuropa.
Hier verweise ich nochmal auf den Salon, in dem ich das Buch von Philipp Manow vorgestellt habe, der nochmal zeigt, woher kommt eigentlich dieser Begriff der liberalen Demokratie. Das kommt daher, dass da Verfassungsgerichte etabliert werden in den Ländern, dann spricht man von der liberalen Demokratie. Das heißt aber nicht, dass ohne Verfassungsgericht keine Demokratie wäre. Tuus hat ja auch gesagt, ja, in gewisser Weise ist es ein demokratischer Akt. Wenn die das jetzt da kurz und klein schlagen, wenn sie die Stimmen dafür haben, warum macht man das denn jetzt eigentlich, dass man jetzt sagt, wir müssen da mal dringend etwas erweitern im Grundgesetz?
Was passiert in dem theoretischen Fall, der in Deutschland, Gott sei Dank, auf Bundesebene ein theoretischer Fall ist, in anderen Ländern aber passiert ist, dass es obstruktive Minderheiten oder gar Mehrheiten gibt, die nicht wollen, dass das Verfassungsgericht gut funktioniert, möglicherweise auch eine Richterwahl blockieren oder verweigern. Dort wollen wir einen Ersatzwahlmechanismus etablieren, der es, Sie wissen, dass der Bundestag und der Bundesrat wählen, die Richter, dass das jeweils andere Organ als Ersatzwahlorgan eintreten kann, wenn eine solche Blockade auftreten sollte.
Das heißt, wenn die AfD blockiert, also die Mehrheit dafür hätte zu blockieren, im Bundesrat aber nicht die Mehrheit hat, dann kann man über den Bundesrat trotzdem dann Richter ernennen und man legt damit das Gericht nicht lahm. Konstantin von Notz von den Grünen wird ein bisschen deutlicher. Höchste Gerichte drohen eben, zu einem politischen Instrument zu verkommen, wie man das gerade in anderen Demokratien sieht. Und der Konsens, Deutschland vor solchen Diskussionen und solchen Bewegungen zu bewahren, hat uns zusammengebracht. Jetzt ist es auch so, dass man zum Beispiel in einer Reihenfolge festigen will für die Fallbearbeitung. Ja, wir wissen ja, man kann Fälle liegen lassen endlos, dass das dann auch nicht möglich ist. Auch Johannes Fechner von der SPD blickt nach Osteuropa.
wir haben in Osteuropa leider sehen müssen, wie schnell der Rechtsstaat abgebaut werden konnte. Und oft war der erste Schritt, dass die nationalen Verfassungsgerichte lahmgelegt wurden. Da gab es die verschiedensten Tricksereien, dass zum Beispiel neue Senate geschaffen wurden oder dass die Altersgrenze runtergesetzt wurde, sodass Verfassungsrichterstellen frei geworden sind, die man dann mit eigenen genehmen Personen besetzen konnte. Das werden wir verhindern.
Was hier also geschieht, ist auch eine Machtabsicherung. Also man kann ja sagen, naja, also eine Machtabsicherung im Sinne von hier wird das natürlich verkauft, als wir müssen die Verfassung schützen. Aber man kann ja auch sagen, es ist ja, wenn die AfD demokratisch gewählt ist, dann hat die ja den Zugriff. Vorher war das ja für euch auch kein Problem. Ich mache mir diese Position nicht zu eigen. Nur ich will deutlich machen, es beginnt also jetzt auch hier ein ganz klares Spiel damit, wie kann man nicht nur diese Institutionen resilient machen, sondern es geht jetzt auch schon darum, dass man ein bisschen politisch da eingreift. Denn wir werden jetzt gleich sehen, dass manche Sachen nicht reinkamen und da ist dann die CDU wieder in einer bemerkenswerten Position. Erst mal hören wir uns an, was getan wird, noch mal Fechner.
wir haben in der Tat sehr intensiv diskutiert und beraten und wollen im Grundgesetz absichern, dass eben nur mit zwei Drittelmehrheit diese Grundlagen des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes abgeändert werden können. Also ein hoher Schutzmechanismus. Zum Beispiel regeln wir, dass es nur zwei Senate geben wird. wir regeln, dass es acht Richter pro Senat geben wird. Und der Minister hat es auch schon gesagt, wir regeln einen Mechanismus, der eingreift, dass eine Richterstelle schnell wieder besetzt werden kann, dass es also keine Hängepartie gibt.
Ja, also er sagt ja schon, es ist eine sehr hohe Hürde, 66 Prozent. In Amerika gilt ja für diese weit reichenden Folgen 60-40. Das hätte man hier auch mal überlegen können, grundsätzlich. Weil 66 Prozent ist auf der einen Seite eine recht hohe Hürde, auf der anderen Seite aber auch eine leicht zu erreichbare Hürde, weil 33 Prozent ist ja dann Minderheitenvotum. Das, was hier verhandelt wird, gilt ja ebenso dann auch für die Länder, soweit ich weiß. Und wenn du dann aber Thüringer Ministerpräsidenten hast, die selber vielleicht keine Regierungsmehrheit haben, aber irgendwas geduldet ist, wie auch immer, eine 33 Prozent Veto gegen verfassungsgebende Mehrheiten, dann wäre man vielleicht bei 40 auch ein bisschen besser aufgestellt.
Man hat sich ja hier noch nicht mal so zu allem durchgerungen. wir hören jetzt erstmal Andrea Lindholz von der CDU mit einem eigenartigen Argument.
Die Debatte, ob man das Bundesverfassungsgericht im Grundgesetz verankert, entteilen und es damit auch stärkt, die gibt es lange, die gibt es seit den 90er Jahren. Und einem Argument haben wir uns auch nicht verschlossen, wenn nicht jetzt im 75. Jahr unseres Grundgesetzes, denn wann dann soll man diese Diskussion führen?
Also war jetzt der Geburtshoch anders oder eher eine aufsteigende AfD?
Naja, ich sag mal, der Buschmann ist ja ganz klug eingestiegen mit so einem Experiment. Und wir sagen jetzt mal, es ist geglückt.
Aber Konstantin von Notz ist glaube ich hier der Ehrlichste, der schon genau weiß, warum sie das jetzt da machen. wir hören Ansgar Heveling von der CDU.
Das Erfordernis, Richterinnen und Richter mit zwei Dritteln im Bundestag zu wählen, steht im Bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetz. Das ist uns wichtig und es kann natürlich Situationen geben, theoretisch, in denen es eben eine destruktive Minderheit gibt, die die Zweidrittelwahl verhindern könnte. Das war uns Anlass auch zu überlegen, muss man dafür einen Mechanismus finden? Das Grundgesetz gab bisher nicht die Möglichkeit dazu. Durch eine Öffnungsklausel soll das in Zukunft geändert werden, sodass es im Bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetz auch die Möglichkeit gibt, einen Ersatzwahlmechanismus vorzusehen, dass also ein anderes Wahlorgan, nämlich dann der Bundesrat, wenn der Bundestag keine Wahl vornehmen kann, die Wahl stattdessen vornehmen kann.
Diese Öffnungsklausel hat man jetzt im Grundgesetz platziert, nicht die Zweidrittelmehrheit. Denn die Journalistin Claudia Kornmeier von der ARD stellt die entscheidende Frage.
Was Sie jetzt nicht aufgenommen haben, ist die Zweidrittelmehrheit für die Wahl der Richter ins Grundgesetz. An die, die das nicht wollten, warum nicht? Welche Befürchtungen waren damit verbunden? Und an die, die sich das vielleicht gewünscht hätten, wie groß finden Sie das Problem, dass das jetzt so bleibt, also dass das in einem einfachen Gesetz bleibt?
Also man hat das interessanterweise nicht aufgenommen. Es geht dann so hin und her. Und Bushman sagt auch, es muss sich jetzt nicht jeder hier bekennen. wir haben das ja auch so gemeinsam ausgemacht. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass das sehr auch mit CDU zusammenhängt. Ich finde eine Argumentation, zumindest um dir den Gedankengang nachzuvollziehen, sinnvoll von Stefan Thome von der FDP.
Neben all dem, was gesagt worden ist, was auch zeigt, wie die Diskussion ernsthaft verlaufen ist und man Argumente und Gegenargumente auch abgewogen hat, ist eben klar, ein hohes Quorum, zunächst mal natürlich sympathisch und nach hoher Sicherheit klingt, hat als Gegenstand gemeint eine niedrige Sperrminorität. Und das ist eben das, was man entgegenhandelt abwägen muss. Und deswegen gab es auch gute Gründe, neben all dem, was vielleicht dafür gesprochen hätte, abzuwägen, ob man eine solche Sperrminorität dann auch zu sehr gleich in Stein meisen möchte. Es gab gute Gründe, sich dagegen auszusprechen. Das war der Grund für das Ergebnis.
Ja, das verstehe ich gut. Weil du kannst deinen Richter blockieren. Wenn du zwei Drittel Mehrheiten brauchst, dann kann ein Drittel im Parlament einfach sagen, oh jetzt müsst ihr schon euren nächsten Paragraph ziehen, der Bundesrat macht das oder sowas.
Ja, und der Bundesrat, also wenn man sich jetzt mal von dieser, ich glaube ja, dass das sehr stark jetzt gemacht wurde, dass man resilient ist gegenüber der AfD. Das ist glaube ich sehr deutlich geworden.
Das sollte man da auch nicht verstecken. Ich meine, die verweigern der Partei seit Jahren, mehrere Legislaturperioden, Bundestagsrat, und die sitzen ja auch komischerweise nicht mit da auf dem Podium.
Das hat ja Grunde. So. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass natürlich die anderen Parteien hier im Einklang erscheinen. Aber du weißt ja, wie das so ist. Und du weißt auch, dass Friedrich Merz erst gar nicht davon überzeugt war, das überhaupt zu machen.
Der wollte das gar nicht.
Der wollte das erst gar nicht. Das heißt, man sagt sich jetzt, naja, bevor wir uns da in merkwürdige Abhängigkeit reinbegeben und können dann nicht mehr so ordentlich taktieren, wie wir das vorher konnten, lassen wir das lieber mal sein.
Als CDU weißt du ja auch, dass du relativ locker nur noch kleine Partner brauchst, um auf 50 Prozent zu kommen. Ja. Für eine 15 Prozent SPD, weißt du, na egal, 50 oder 66, ist eh nicht unsere Entscheidung dann und so.
Aber wir haben jetzt, ist ganz klar mit dieser Richtung zu tun, dass also das Liberale an der Demokratie, insofern liberal ist, man versucht hat, alles festzuschreiben. Was wir bei der Schuldenbremse kritisieren, sind wir jetzt durchaus mit Blick auf die AfD bereit zu guttieren. Konstantin von Notz macht nochmal diese Opposition auf. wir leben in einer systemischen, in einer systemischen Auseinandersetzung zwischen den Demokratien und autokratischen, diktatorischen Systemen. Und wir müssen unsere Demokratie wehrhaft und resilient aufstellen, damit wir eben diesen Angriffen begegnen können. Das heißt aber, dass man einen technokratischen Weg geht und diesen technokratischen Weg...
Na, ich bin mir nicht so sicher.
Also, na, das ist ein technokratischer Weg, sonst würde man ja sagen, brauchen wir nicht, wir kriegen das ja politisch gelöst.
Wenn man sich jetzt von außen sozusagen nähert, würde man sagen, die Regeln sind jetzt ein bisschen anders als vorher. Das heißt aber nicht, dass sie jetzt mehr ausgedacht sind oder artificiell oder so. Waren vorher auch, genau. So, die Frage ist dann, warum hat man das nicht früher gemacht, sondern jetzt? Na klar, dann kommt so der empirie-druck. Man sagt dann irgendwie, das ist es. Nur, das wird natürlich, gerade wenn der empirie-druck da ist, also der AfD und so weiter wird thematisiert, dann hast du ja eine Diskussion. Also solche Sachen werden jetzt diskutiert in den sozusagen Special-Interest-Fachjournalen. Irgendwie Juristen machen sich jetzt Gedanken dazu. Und ich glaube, die werden relativ zügig zur Frage eins kommen. Wie weit kann man eigentlich einen parlamentarischen Betrieb gegen Bevölkerungswillen absichern? Also wie groß kann die Spannung da werden? Und zweitens, wenn man ein Einfallstor schließt, welches andere öffnet man denn dann? Wenn wir von TUS gehört, über die Richter ist man ja nur gegangen, weil das so einfach war. In Amerika noch mehr, wo jeder Richterspruch immer gleich Gesetzeskraft hat. Deutschland noch nicht ganz so sehr. Jetzt versucht man trotzdem ein Einfallstor, das man im Ausland beobachtet hat, hier zu schließen. Ich würde sagen, schaut euch lieber noch mal die lokalen Staatsverträge für die Medien an. Sind die Medienhäuser eigentlich abgesichert, so wie wir uns das wünschten in dem Experiment, als wir sagten, kein Volksempfänger mehr? wir machen das jetzt mit Haushaltsbeiträgen und so. Was ist eigentlich ein Haushalt? Denn da befürchte ich ja, dass wir nur ein komisches Urteil, und vielleicht kann man sogar komisch streichen, nur ein sehr gut begründetes Urteil davon entfernt sind, dass hier irgendwo wirkliche Sendeanstalten von heute auf morgen sozusagen sich juristisch neu aufstellen müssen. Oder halt wirklich Mehrheiten über die Parlamente da kommen und sagen, und das ist ja zum Beispiel, hier sagt man jetzt, okay, das ist der einfache Gesetzgeber. Also diese Medienstaatsverträge, soweit ich das verstehe, sind in den Staatskanzleien nicht mal Ministerpräsidenten angelegt, also eines Wahlamtes, sondern der beruften Staatssekretär, also ein Leiter seines Büros, und der kümmert sich um die Verträge zu den Medienhäusern. Das ist ja noch weiter weg von einfachen Gesetzgeber. Das ist ja dann wirklich Verwaltungsaktebene. Also da würde ich so sagen, sind du... Ich glaube, jedenfalls derzeit in Deutschland ist, wie wir Diskussionen führen, sehr viel wichtiger zu beobachten, als wie im parlamentarischen Prozess die Abläufe sind. Ob jetzt 50-50 oder 66-33 Mehrheiten. Ich finde es trotzdem gut, dass sie das mal so gemacht haben, dass sie auch zeigen, dass das geht, dass man darüber nachdenkt, dass die CDU nochmal sich entblößt und wir sagen, oh Gott, ihr Blöden, macht wieder euren eigenen Soße draus. Trotzdem glaube ich, ein Einfallstor so ein bisschen zugemacht und dann sitzen die Heritage Foundation-Strategien gleich da und suchen sich die anderen Dinge.
Ganz richtig. Und da ist Marco Buschmann zuzustimmen, wenn er auf die Grenzen dieser technokratischen Schritte verweist und das ist jetzt der letzte Clip dann.
Weil jetzt ja vielleicht auch so ein bisschen spielerische Energie losgetreten wird, kann es eigentlich die perfekte Verfassungsordnung geben, die jedes auch nur irgendwie denkbare Risiko ausschließt. Und da möchte ich sagen, auch wirklich als begeisterter Verfassungsjurist, das wird man nie finden können, sondern kluges Verfassungsrecht kann Dinge in Bahn lenken, sie kann Missbrauch erschweren, sie kann Korruption erschweren, sie kann Destruktivität schwerer machen, sie kann die Institution über eine gewisse Zeit stärken. Aber zu glauben, dass, wenn wir dauerhaft antidemokratische Mehrheiten im Deutschen Bundestag hätten, das Verfassungsrecht allein alle Probleme lösen können, das ist eine Illusion. Und deshalb bleibt neben dem, was wir hier tun, eine andere Sache mindestens genauso bedeutend, vielleicht noch viel bedeutender, nämlich, dass seriöse Demokraten dafür sorgen, dass sie so viele Menschen immer sorgen, dass es möglichst niemals im Deutschen Bundestag eine antidemokratische Mehrheit oder eine antidemokratische qualifizierte Minderheit gibt.
So ist es.
Ein begeisterter Verfassungsjurist. Ja, er kann sich wünschen, dass es seriöse Demokraten gibt, aber die haben keinen direkten Zugang zur Wählerschaft. Das läuft über Twitter, Tagesthemen, Bild, News.
Naja, da muss man sich...
Das sind immense Probleme.
wir sprechen ja über Blüthorn dann im Salon. wir wollen noch mal darauf hinweisen, also im Salon sprechen wir über das Buch Unhaltbarkeit auf dem Weg in eine andere Moderne von Ingolfur. Blüthorn, welche Texte hast du sonst noch mit dabei?
wir lesen ein Diskussionspapier. Angesprochen, ich will noch mal die Namen. Es ist ja nicht nur Malafalani, Mafalani, also Aladin El-Mafalani, sondern auch Baro wie Chenta Raghabad, Nikolas Karanikolas, Nadia Rückert, Melissa Sedei, Marie Borst und Daniela Broder. Also ein sehr divers zusammengestelltes, meinen Aussprache-Gewohnheiten nicht entsprechendes Gremium, aber beauftragt von der Bundesregierung, sich die Jugend anzuschauen. Dazu passend, also zu dem, was wir eben sagten, ist diesen riesigen Vanity fair-text 22, der immer noch aktuell ist, weil er uns ungetrübt von der Aktualität programmatisch, ich habe in dem Falle auch ein bisschen Claude zur Hilfe genommen, liste mir mal wirklich auf, was steht da inhaltlich, wer hat da was und wie kann man das als Programm deuten und so. Außerdem dieser wahnsinnig wirklich, also Israel Klein ist so ein wahnsinnig kluger Typ, er hat diesen Text gemacht, wie sollte man jetzt mit der Harris-Kandidatur umgehen unter der Maßgabe, dass man jetzt nicht ewig lange und Michelle Obama und so. Also da sind wir mal sehr gespannt. Außerdem, was habe ich noch? Vanity fair, was ist das hier? Ah nee, das ist noch mal das selbe. Also ich habe da noch was für, eventuell zu den Wohnpreisen diese JLL irgendwas Anwalts-Dings oder was. Keine Ahnung, die haben so ein paar Zahlen zusammengestellt.
Ich werde ein Buch vorstellen, das sich mit dem Opfer-Nationalismus auseinandersetzt.
Ja, sehr gut.
Das ist eine sehr interessante Perspektive, die da eingenommen wird.
Ist es gut?
Ich finde es sehr inspirierend, sagen wir so. Ich finde, es ist ein Buch, das sicherlich auch Widerspruch zum Widerspruch einlädt. Aber es ist in der Tat eine interessante Überlegung, die hier getroffen wird. Also inwieweit jetzt also ein neuer Nationalismus dadurch entsteht, dass man sich als Opfer sieht oder auch tatsächlich Opfer war. Das ist etwas, was wir besprechen sollten. Dann habe ich noch einen sehr merkwürdigen japanischen Roman gelesen, den ich vorstellen werde. Und den Rest halte ich noch offen. Ich habe da mehrere Texte. Dazu entscheide ich mich noch.
Okay, sehr gut.
Dann kann man uns also im Salon hören. Dort werden wir ausführlich dann erst mal über Blüthorn diskutieren. Man wird dort dann auch im August unseren Live-Sommersalon hören können. Das ist also auch dann möglich. Und man kann natürlich alle alten Salons hören. Und wir haben es schon gesagt, es gibt dann diese moderate Preissteigerung von Steady dringend erwünscht oder erbeten. Jedenfalls kann man uns also bei Steady für, wenn man ein Jahresabbo abschließt, für drei Euro im Monat hören. Und für die einzelnen Monate ist es dann etwas teurer. Bei Apple und Patreon haben wir dann auch diese Preisanpassung vorgenommen. Aber bis zum 24. August, wie gesagt, kann man noch zum alten Preis, also ab 2,50 Euro im Monat den Salon abonnieren. Und dieser Preis bleibt dann auch. Es gibt dann keine Preiserhöhung ab dem Preisanstieg, sondern man kann sich jetzt nochmal das günstige Abo sichern und so auch unseren Podcast unterstützen, worüber wir uns natürlich sehr freuen. Und dann sehen wir uns wieder im Salon.
So ist es, bis dahin.